okay
we shall all use our microphones
so
for anybody who didn't get on the
streaming and is interested one of the
things we're going to talk about is
whether what we should do is simply move
some of the text from this bill
to the section that is already the
patient's bill of rights it's
rsa 151 colon i think it's 21.
but i'm going to go through the changes
that i made here anyway just so we're
all on the same page
in
the section on
miners i just changed the reference to
hospital
and i'm sorry i couldn't change it on
the ones with numbers
so you're just going to have it that's
on the front page
under roman one um instead of healthcare
facility licensed pursuant to
151.2 i said hospital as defined in
and gave the specific reference and
because i thought it was less likely
that a child is going to be in a nursing
home or other things i just said
hospital there
but that's entirely open to negotiation
if people want to put more things in
for the adults i put the reference their
nursing home and rehabilitation facility
and i don't have the right references
for those but i
will find somebody to help me out with
those
i didn't change any of the language just
the definition
then when we go down to roman four
we talked about who provided the
personal protective equipment so i
struck out
provided that any such required
equipment she'll be provided by the
health care facility i wrote provided by
this facility or provided by the visitor
and approved by the facility
so that that leaves a certain amount of
autonomy in either direction
then when we go down to seven you
remember that the department was
concerned about the
the
[Music]
informational materials and we thought
that those were better left to the
facility
itself
we will require them to have the
materials but they develop the materials
because it's not a one-size-fits-all and
and it's not what the department of
health
human services does so i just struck out
all the references to dhhs
and left the requirement that the
uh facility
write up the informational materials
in eight
the um
limitation of liability to arising out
of this section
and i struck c
failing to follow the guidelines of cdc
because that was the part that i thought
that dhhs objected to the most
but that's all still negotiable so
that's that's just what i put down to
uh
think about
for next time but i
i wanted to talk about that and i wanted
to talk about what you thought about
just lifting the pieces
does anybody hear from dhhs oh good yeah
oh sorry
can't see that far
my apologies um
but i did want to just ask people how
they thought about lifting part of this
and just inserting it into the patient's
bill of rights where it would be
balanced with everybody else's rights
and
i'll stop talking now somebody else may
talk
thank you madam chair i um i just have a
couple of thoughts so in
your roman numeral one
instead of i just i'm concerned about
limiting
further
where
parents can
be accompanying a child
i know it is rare but it does happen
where children need to be in long-term
care facilities
so if we could do like if there are
other facilities that you want to put in
there i'm more than willing to
incorporate them i just
i was i was thinking about the
difference between adult care and child
care and i'm more than willing
to insert whatever anybody else thinks
needs to be inserted there yeah i think
it's i think that line is
i think in statute is
comprehensive the way it is
um
so i don't see any reason to limit it
well the problem with it being left to
all of 151 2
is it applies to renal care facilities
it applies it applies to a whole range
of things that are
sort of different
sort of care
right it's it's lots of
lots of different sorts of facilities so
and it doesn't incorporate
when you get to the adults it doesn't
incorporate things like the nursing home
so
which we want to incorporate
thank you
i think one of the important things is
that with minors
it's a very different equation if you're
having them go into having a parent
going with them to a dialysis center or
somewhere else as opposed to an adult
having somebody at one of those
outpatient care facilities
i would really like to see that the
parents allowed to go
just about anywhere as long as it's as
long as it's not a risk obviously they
wouldn't go into neurosurgery unless uh
that was specifically arranged but i do
want to see the parent being able to
stay with the child
okay
and i do like uh more specifically
limiting it for adults since we are
looking to make sure we have the
residential care facility and we want to
make sure that we don't cause problems
in the outpatient
okay as well
so thank you
okay
yep uh also uh the infusion centers as
well for kids
um oncology uh that's uh would be a real
a real plus to
have them uh
at that time
uh um i'm sure if i are the infusion
centers regulated under 151 too i don't
know if they're part of
a hospital a subsidiary
that would probably be the case i'm not
positive well if if they're under a
hospital
regulated as a hospital we're okay yeah
i i know adele oncology units are
standalones
right so
and i don't know
i'm sure they go under 18
they may not go under 10 or under 5.
the language
representative gay that we're
so i think
if i may
that
leaving leaving rsa 151 colon 2
reference there and then just adding any
other facilities that we're concerned
just saying you know pursuant to rsa 151
colon 2 and
and broaden it to the other facilities
we want to add just not limiting it
because there are a number of facilities
under that statute that we still want it
to apply to
but i do like putting this all in the
patient's bill of rights i think that's
great
and it makes sense i believe that
um
they're already required to post the
patient bill of rights in these
facilities
but maybe someone from the hospital
association or the department can
clarify
paul i'm pretty sure um that they have
to they have to be posted
yeah
things have changed since i was in
practice
the first first year i was at concord
hospital you could buy cigarettes in the
lobby
in the lobby of the concord hospital
i couldn't believe it
we've changed a bit
sorry
i do have another question
on under section
romans 6 i'm sorry
if there were an outbreak of some kind
say like we had in the past with mrsa
there was a hospital that had a really a
major
outbreak of mrsa
to have any changes occur
would require the governor or the
legislature
that seemed like a very very very slow
yes
is it your opinion that that would not
be covered by the exceptions in 3
and specifically a the presence of
visitors would be medically or
therapeutically contraindicated in the
best clinical judgment of health care
professionals i think i could yeah okay
i could yeah
and b is the presence of visitors would
interfere with the care or rights of any
patient so that's where we're back to
balancing
the rights of the one versus the rights
yeah one could interpret that i would
agree the other ones yeah i would agree
i could be interpreted that way i was
just being more
i
if if
if we moved it what i would prove what i
would propose doing is simply moving
to the patient's bill of rights
and making making three a subjection so
that it's clearly that you know the
children's rights is the next one on
following all the other rights the
adults rights of the other and those two
paragraphs are subject to three
and then we don't have all of the other
stuff
so
i'm i'm wondering both from from all of
you and from all of the people out in
the audience if if that is an approach
that
might get us all a little closer to
being on the same page rather than on
anybody out there
yeah
yes
um
okay
and one and two are actually framed
as being patient-centric because it is
the minor who is admitted has the right
and the adult who is admitted has the
right
so that
you know i can look at the language of
the patient bill of rights a little
closer and
i'm sorry i'm so late really picking up
on that but when i started reading the
patient bill of rights it it made a
great deal more sense to me that
this ought to be there
and that may
actually
solve the issue of
having to define which facilities it
applies to too
i'm not sure but anyway go ahead
thank you madam chair i i would not
support moving those three sections and
striking the rest but i do think that we
may want to tie something into the
patient bill of rights referencing this
i think that the additional information
in here is very important
and i'm also concerned with striking c
in roman 8
there are other ways in which the cdc
and other federal guidelines can be
implemented
this makes the state an agent of the
federal government and our departments
an agent of the federal government and i
don't think that that's appropriate
and so i believe
so i'm not in favor of striking c and i
want to keep roman four through eight in
there
okay
yes
thank you madam chair i have just have a
very simple question when we talk about
patient's bill of rights
our patients rights
for a child does that mean the child's
rights are expressed as expressed by the
parents
do the parents have the same rights
as the child
their child the patient
patients rights apply to all patients
desires expressed
by their parents okay so that is
illegally the same
i'm not going to give you a legal
opinion representative that's what it
thank you uh so
representative i'm just uh a li i don't
follow you on on number on roman numeral
8c
so
the way i read it it's saying
that
they're not required
to follow the guidelines of the cdc or
other federal guidelines
and that
action
can
sorry
well what i would there's a lot if you
start there's a lot in there but if you
start at the beginning of
paragraph eight it says unless expressly
required by federal law or regulation
comma the department
shall not take any action
arising out of this section against a
healthcare facility for
so
we've already said unless expressly
required by federal law or regulation if
we then say they can't do it to follow
federal law of regulation
then we've created a
a conflict right in the language of the
statute i chose to take out c
because i am on the side of wanting us
to comply with cmc guidelines
we've already had that discussion we
don't all agree on that
but i was drafting it so i got to leave
in the piece i liked
if if somebody wants to do it another
way that's fine but
what i'm
beginning to hear is that there isn't
a lot of room for agreement here and i
want to know whether that's the case or
whether we should continue to push
forward and try and draft something that
we can all agree on
mike my question with those is because
guidelines are not a regulation so if
there's a regulation to follow the
guidelines then that's something that
that where they could take action but
otherwise you're promoting the
guidelines as something that that's
stronger than it is i do know that back
when cigarettes were in the hospital
cigarettes were recommended for nausea
for women and that was part of
guidelines pregnant women so
we just want to make sure that
guidelines regulations and laws aren't
confused too much
but if this becomes the one discussion
point we can always look to
bringing it with and without that are
you are you
interested in pursuing one where we have
all of these sections are you looking
only to trim it to the part the one
through three and the guidelines
i would absolutely prefer to take one
through three and put them in
the patient's bill of rights
and leave it there
but what we could do
was we could do
one
amendment that does that which i think
we're all pretty much agreed on
and then there might be a further
amendment which moves
other things to somewhere else
would that be an approach um i i think
maybe the competing amendments might be
an approach if you wanted to work on the
one of moving to the patient's bill of
rights just with sections one through
three i can take the lead on retaining
these different sections and figuring
out the best way to make that work okay
so
yep
you just turned it off sorry to be a
stickler
i'm still concerned about um
roman 3a
um yes i believe that it allows the
facilities to
at any time bar visitors and
that
you know completely eliminates the bill
you know and its application
representative woods
by the same token
a lot a lot of times these are very
emotional times
and the
patients
families do want to be with them and i
understand that but trust me
it is not
good medical practice
to let the patient have the upper hand
in getting into
questionable situations it's just not
it's just
it's not in the patient's best interest
let's say you have a compound fracture
well here here's a situation
a 16 year old girl gets wrapped up in a
tree three broken limbs and her skulls
wide open i happen to be the first one
on the scene
she's from concord
family was surprised that she was on the
way to the hospital wanted to come in to
see her
that is not the time for the family to
come in when i'm
happen to be the first one the trauma
surgeons were right behind me
but that is not the time to have the
family
come in
because they'll faint
well i've had that have i've had doctors
faint when i set a fracture so it's not
just
but
i think it's uh to to i understand uh
leah's concern
but i think in terms of patient care
uh that i i think
um making it such that the family could
come in at any time uh would be
contraindicated it's just uh
i understand the concern
and i i agree that and there are going
to be some there's going to be some
doctors and nurses that uh and you your
nurse you you know there's some nurses
that wouldn't be so kindly
and we have to deal with that but i
think in this particular situation i
think
we really are talking patient care
in this particular situation and the
patient has to come first
and thank you representative and i would
agree with you um so maybe there's some
way that we can clarify you know that
in certain for procedures and you know
in certain trauma situations
but
my concern is that you know case cases
of covert go up
um and reach a certain number and
immediately they shut out all family
members and people are dying alone in
the hospitals again rules are meant to
be broken and that's just so i mean and
people are i'm sorry i'm for
interjecting and can you right a little
closer to your microphone i i
i completely agree and
i i understand that there are going to
be some you know
personnel in the facilities that
wouldn't make the decisions that should
be made but i think we have to err on
the side of making sure that patients
are taken care of well the other thing
is that i think we need to be very clear
and i think that representative cushman
this was not a reaction to wanting
somebody with the patient every single
minute of every single day with the
possible exception of a dying patient
who is not getting a lot of medical
procedures they need somebody to come
and sit and hold their hand quietly in a
corner
as opposed to somebody who has an open
fracture that needs to be dealt with
i didn't get the sense that anybody was
saying that somebody needs to be there
every single minute of the day i think
the thing that they were
worried about was not having the
equivalent of normal visiting hours
where you could come in
see your patient
you know and and
comfort them and be with them and
encourage them to the extent
possible it
i didn't ever see this as a guarantee
that anybody could be anywhere at any
time because that's just
as far as i'm concerned that's just
madness
because there are times when there are
procedures and
i do think that we need to be
particularly careful with the
matter of children who need
a trusted adult with them at almost
every time and particularly when things
are scary
and
there's already the very definite
provision in the patient's bill of
rights about patients who are dying so
um
i think maybe yeah go ahead
thank you i think that maybe one path
forward is making it so that the agent
for a durable power of attorney or
surrogate
has more access even in those situations
so that if the patient
is
unable to make their own health care
decisions their their trusted person is
able to have access to the greatest
extent possible in those scenarios
so that's that
if that seems reasonable i will work
towards getting that into the amendment
that i'll be working on
my concern with that is that the person
who is your durable power of attorney
for health care is not always the the
nearest and dearest in the person that
you want
right there all the time
that's true but if they're going to be
making health care decisions and you
have a patient on a ventilator and
nobody can see them
if you need to default to somebody it
should be that person who's chose who is
able to make those decisions
maybe a separate carve out but the
health care
agent already has the power to make
those decisions
under the under the
power that they've been given that's
that's what they do they're able to be
in person even during covet no they're
they're there to make decisions for the
person but it is a totally different
function
the person i've picked as my durable
power of attorney is my agent
is my stepson because he's here
but if my sister arrived
she would be the person
i would want to be with me as opposed to
the decision maker i mean there are lots
of they're just two completely different
functions
and i think that for purposes of this
we need to focus
on
the person that's closest to the patient
and
the other thing is that gazillions of
people don't fill out durable powers of
attorney for health care reforms
gazillions of people do
and i certainly have had the experience
and i'll bet
that representative cushman has too
my
aunt had a living will because durable
powers of attorney hadn't been invented
and she said that she absolutely didn't
want to have any interventions of any
kind and she absolutely said she didn't
want to leave her home
but
when she was in her last
episode of her last illness
she asked to be taken to the hospital
she voluntarily agreed to several
extremely invasive diagnostic procedures
and it wasn't until she got weak enough
that she could not speak anymore that
somebody called me and said what do we
do now
and i was faced with somebody who had
said very firmly that she didn't want
anything but more close in time she had
said yes please
i want to go to the hospital i will
consent
and so i felt that i was bound at that
point to honor what seemed to me to be
her closest in time wishes because
that's what she wanted to do
and
i mean what we really want is for people
to be really thoughtful and
working the best they can to honor what
somebody wants sometimes you can't tell
but
yeah go ahead thank you uh is there any
way to write that in as an amendment no
so that you can have a choice of
somebody no
no we really need to focus on one thing
or another thing but i mean that is our
concern is how we treat people
then not leave them isolated so how do
we spell out
if we're not going to have a crowd come
in and visit
but under really crisis situations
people do need somebody well this
already says that they say a person i
mean it's already in there but we don't
want to spell out that the person is
the two people that you i don't i won't
speak for anybody else you defined two
people who are critical one who makes
decisions and one who is a strong
emotional support
so it seems like
you know since we're talking about
crisis situations where nobody is
permitted to come in
that we ought to spell out who can
because
that was my question is under what
circumstances yeah and if that was my
child with
three broken limbs and a gash on their
head
and they were still conscious
i would want to see
see my child even if it was momentarily
so people could be stitching her up and
setting setting bones i'd still like to
reassure i'm here
i apologize i have to get to another
meeting um i'm going to
recess i i will
we can have a discussion about whether
we're going to meet again i'm not
entirely sure we are and so far we have
not reached a complete conclusion and
i'm sorry about that but these are
truly tough and difficult issues so
with that i will close the subcommittee
meeting and let people get to their
so
okay good morning mr chairman and
members of the committee
we all know that issues of gender
identity are constantly evolving and
being debated around the country in many
areas of life
my bill does not seek to settle or put a
stop to that debate
what it does do is clarify and preserve
the status quo
in a limited but significant way i and
the women co-sponsors of this bill
seek to clarify and codify that in
certain contexts
the state of new hampshire has a
rational interest in differentiating
between the male and female biological
sexes
this is something that in new hampshire
we already do every day
for example the police routinely
incarcerate men and women in separate
facilities
this is something we all take for
granted
but i'd ask the members of this
committee to pause for a moment
and contemplate how unique this
phenomenon is
remember that our country guarantees
equal protection under the law
the government can't take people of
different races and nationalities for
example and incarcerate them in
different facilities
but because of the deep
biological differences
that exist between the male male and
female sexes it's been implied that our
state has
for a long time claimed certain
interests in differentiating between
these two groups of people most
important among those interests to my
mind are women's rights and the
protection of women
this is because of the unique physical
vulnerabilities that women have
statutory clarification is important
because
already new hampshire's laws about
gender identity are being abused and
stretched way beyond the meaning which i
believe the legislature intended
last year the manchester school board
adopted a policy integrating biological
males and females in both sports teams
and bathrooms on the basis of gender
identity
one of the justifications given for this
policy
was our state law allowing
non-binary gender identities on driver's
licenses
and this is what actually alerted me to
this problem
now whether or not you agree that what
the manchester school what the
manchester school board did this is the
misreading and an abuse of our current
laws
our state laws simply do not require
these kinds of policies
our state laws on gender identity
such as our law allowing people to put
an x on their driver's license
do not say or mean that school districts
are prohibited from having intramural
and interscholastic sports leagues
composed of biological women
the point of my bill is narrow
to clarify that laws regarding state
identification
do not mean that public entities
are prohibited from differentiating
between males and females in athletic
competitions
criminal incarceration or places of
private intimacy like bathrooms
male and female are real categories of
people
which the state can recognize
having explained what my bill does i'd
like to give some specifics about why i
believe these clarifications are
important
let me first look at the issue of
women's sports and then address the
question of having separate physical
spaces for women in context where women
may be vulnerable
when it comes to young women's athletic
competitions the state has a very
specific interest in differentiating
between the two sexes
to illustrate this i'd like to give the
example of alice and felix
the most decorated female olympic runner
in history
miss felix has had an extraordinary
career competing against other
biological women from around the world
actually miss felix has won more olympic
medals than the male athlete usain bolt
the single greatest sprinter in the
recorded history of the world
but how fast is miss felix compared to
males
felix's lifetime record for the 400
meter sprint is
49.26 seconds
according to public data from high
school leagues high school
which i have linked in my written
testimony hundreds of high school boys
in the united states alone can beat that
record in fact i happen to know that one
of the boys whose names you could see in
the records that's in my uh link at the
bottom
is a graduate of phillips
exeter academy with a 400 meter time of
49.09 seconds
much faster than miss felix
and while i don't want to diminish this
young man's accomplishments i can tell
you that he has not enjoyed anything
approaching world fame
nor did he even go on to become a
professional athlete after school
imagine that the world's next alison
felix perhaps a young woman here in new
hampshire
has to compete against biological males
and as a matter of course
these are already the conditions in
connecticut
where biological males have won
15 state championship titles
in girls high school athletics
all with times that would not have
qualified them to compete in the boys
state championships
as more areas adopt policies like
manchester's new policy
a career like miss felix's will become
far more difficult if not impossible
i hope this example shows why affording
young women an opportunity to compete
against members of their own biological
sex is important
finally i want to return to areas in
which we need separate physical spaces
for women
over a year ago this month california
integrated biologically male and female
prisoners on the basis of self-declared
gender identity
and the results have been horrific for
women prisoners
just months after california's policy
was adopted
the wall street journal reported that
dozens of biological males had already
transferred to the central california
women's facility
many of whom had not had any sex
reassignment surgery or even taken
hormonal medication
i don't wish to be crude about this but
i think it's important the committee
knows the details of this sensitive
topic
one former inmate of this facility told
the wall street journal the following
quote
they're getting a full erection so
you're locked in this room
24 7
with a man and there's nothing you can
do about it if you tell the police you
don't want to live with a man
or you're afraid or whatever you'll get
a disciplinary infraction
so you're basically punished for being
scared
unquote
when i read information like this i fear
for my granddaughter
and do you have a granddaughter or a
daughter i'd like you to think about
this
the manchester school board's current
policy which i mentioned earlier
integrates biological males and females
in bathrooms and locker rooms
while we don't yet incarcerate based on
gender identity in new hampshire
that is the only
logical outcome if our current laws are
stretched to mean that the state can
never differentiate between the
biological sexes
this committee should act to clarify our
state law to preclude
absurd and unnecessary interpretations
of this kind
both to help protect athletic
opportunities for young women
and to protect women's physical safety
and privacy
thank you
thank you representative gould would
there be
questions that you would take from the
committee
[Music]
representative gould
oh
yes like i could take a few okay
thank you mr chair thank you
after your testimony i'm is this bill
this has nothing to do with
discrimination uh based on their
people's gender it's just that the state
and public entities can differentiate
between the biological male and female
sexes in places of uh
champ
and also
you know criminal and incarceration and
uh
private places of like bathrooms
has nothing to do with the
so does this bill apply to all people
to what
does this bill apply to all people as
far as evaluation of their gender and
sex
in certain places
they would have the ability to
offer certain
accommodations for people based on their
biological sex
follow-up representative yes thank you
so who decides
who gets evaluated and how would they be
evaluated okay that's an interesting
question about how they'd be evaluated
is that what you asked
i'm asking who would make the decision
that someone should be evaluated
if they should be evaluated yes
okay well so mainly i'm concerned about
those three areas the uh sports uh
you know competition and criminal
incarceration and places of private
intimacy
so um and we
for example in uh
incarceration we just take it for
granted
we don't ask for their chromosomal uh
report or their dna
mr chairman
still didn't answer my question about
how they would be evaluated okay well so
far there has not been an issue about
that we haven't asked them for their
do you realize that
that the way that this
this bill is written
that it would
it is against our constitution
in article 2b
the right to privacy
an individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent
okay well actually what i'm talking
about it's implicit now laws because uh
for example we do just automatically put
men and women's prisons and women
okay thank you very much is there any
further questions representative gay
thank you mr chair
i don't have covet i'm allergic to foods
and
sometimes i eat the wrong ones
thank you for taking my question
i'm going to say how i feel and you can
respond because i don't know how to put
this in a question
there seems to be three three
points to this bill
i'm comfortable with two of them and not
with the third one
uh caitlyn jenner has spoken out about
sports and uh definitely thinks that a
biological voice one moment
right yes
okay uh are you aware are you aware that
caitlyn jenner has very much supported
not allowing biological boys who are
trans to participate in sports because
that's just impossible
perhaps if children are very very young
when their transition may be but
from all accounts it
it sounds like
she's right that
they have a physical
advantage
so you're aware of that okay thank you
for that a question i your
question was if i knew about caitlyn
jenner and yes i do i just learned about
that
instance and that
that person is not in favor of having
biological males in women's sports
biologically women sports
are you aware that
there's a difference
well do you think there's a difference
between teenagers in school
in new hampshire
are you aware that different schools
have different policies but a lot of
times they make a separate bathroom they
designate a bathroom for the trans kids
so they don't have to deal with the
pressures from
non-trans kids who could be kind of
obnoxious i don't quite understand what
the question is
are you aware of how the high schools
are handling it
as opposed to a public bathroom
where
people
don't have signs on them whereas in high
schools everybody knows who's trans
okay well i'm not actually don't know
specifically what's going on in that
respect but
with with this bill it clarifies that a
school can differentiate between the
biological males and females
okay well i don't know of any specific
instances that you're referring to now
one more one one more follow-up thank
you
when it comes to incarceration that also
i'm
are you concerned about incarcerating
it sounds it sounds like you're
concerned
and
but what's the solution
because
if you just leave it the way it is
it's either dangerous for people who are
just saying they're trans and aren't
and it's dangerous for the people who
really are trans
to be mixed in with the people who
are not so kind
yes i understand what you're
leading to with that actually uh
well this bill will hopefully ward off
any laws in the future that might
uh
make those people be to get together a
woman you know have to have a
biological male in her prison
that's the main goal here and as for the
other part
i guess they'd have to have
another space maybe for the people who
who would be concerned if they are in
the men's prison yeah that's what i
would think yes thank you yeah
waves off thank you very much
representative representative kirk
thank you very much um
i mean yeah i'll answer to anything kirk
you know i got him
so i was concerned going back to the
issue of public bathrooms
um i do remember actually when he had
the transgender rights bill many years
ago could you repeat what you're saying
yes i i'm going back to the question of
public bathrooms and and the
implications of that because i was
curious
uh how it works in terms of comfort for
females
when a very clearly a male appearing
person walks in when we had our
hearing here about transgender rights
years ago i remember going to the
bathroom and a transgender male so
biologically female
he has a heavier beard than i do though
that's a low bar and he walked in he was
into the men's bathroom and was very
comfortable and a fit how would females
feel if he walks into their bathroom
when he looks very masculine
because that's what would be required
under this could you uh ask the question
just uh
more specifically how would females feel
if a very masculine looking transgender
male walked into their bathroom
and they would have no reason to know
that this is a biologic
female or born as a female how do you
think that would make them feel
how the
the woman or the girl
in the bathroom would feel if a
biological male walked in yes a very
masculine appearing biological male who
is a transgender
uh male 1 you mean he says he's a woman
in his head
no transgender male so therefore he was
born biologically a female but
identifies as a male but according to
this bill he would have to use the
women's restroom even though he is a
very masculine appearing transgender
male well there are tom boys now that
are in a woman's bathroom i mean that's
been going on
for as long as i've been alive and
it's the biological female so
she's not going to have an erection or
something
okay thank you very much
on that is there any further
questions one little one
one more follow-up how would you
classify and how would you deal with
intersex people because that is a real
phenomena that does occur where they are
not actually clearly male or female
repeat the question again a little more
clearly how would this if this became
law how would it deal with intersex
individuals who are not clearly male nor
clearly female
biologically or biologically
biologically would that mean they would
have had uh operations
not necessarily they don't always have
sorry may i respond
they don't always have a
an operation they may still be intersex
would that mean they would have had
hormonal medication to change them not
necessarily
so biologically they're still a male is
that what you're saying
intersex has characteristics of both
what's that word intersex they have both
characteristics of the male and female
t-e-r-s-c-x yes it is i've never heard
of that phrase actually sexuality is not
clear the binary always because there
are people are born with with with uh
genitalia that are confusing and look
maybe female on the inside male on the
outside or vice versa or oh you mean
they were born that way yes literally
yes yeah
okay
that's the biology i'm sorry but that's
the
biology well they would have they would
have had those uh conditions since they
were born and
i would think that
those
issues would have been resolved through
all those years
about what bathroom they go into i mean
when they're five years old they'd have
a certain bathroom to go into even
before they
reach puberty or whatever
that's what i would think thank you
thank you for that
we have
another question
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for letting me ask you a
question
um i'm gonna shift gears a little bit
uh would your bill require any school or
agency to adopt any specific policy
no the uh
the town or the school could adopt
whatever policies they want
okay thank you so much yeah
thank you
thank you thank you representative gould
okay thank you very much
you all uh recognize
representative catherine pujol o'brien
who is a co-sponsor of the bill
and uh before we
hear madame o'brien food home o'brien uh
we have a very strong support here for
testimony so we'll be doing a
approximate three minutes for each
individual to make sure everyone is
heard during the time that we have so
make sure you're succinct until the
point
uh in your testimony for us to get
educated together very quickly
representative
thank you i'm catherine prudom o'brien i
represent the town of derry
i know this is a very sensitive issue
and it's a sensitive issue for a lot of
people in our communities
and i want to just start out with the
premise that i am trying to be kind and
thoughtful and understanding
of the pressures that we all are going
through and the special circumstances
that individuals have
this bill may not be absolutely 100
perfect to everyone and there may be
some changes that that are
anticipated or
proposed
and i'm not
opposed to that necessarily
uh
but i want to talk about the
some of my own experiences when
when representative gould was talking
about the woman the women at a women's
prison who
had to be housed with people who were
born male
i recall this a personal situation that
i had that i will explain in a little
while but it's really difficult to talk
about but i'm going to get there
uh i know three minutes uh first of all
speaking about the corrections
institutions the uni the united kingdom
ministry of justice
reported that
uh trans inmates who i identify as women
but are housed with
natural of women born female
had an exponentially higher rate of
sexual assault of sexually assaulting
the the natal females
and that
comes from an article that i just read
in the daily mail from may 18 2020
written by don shaw so you can look that
up i'm trying to be very factual about
i'm concerned about
women that are competing in sports
that it won't be fair to them to be
competing with people born male
that's that's unfair
um there was a privacy concern brought
up by one of the representatives
regarding our constitution
well when you are in the prison system
you do have to go through some
examinations to find out what your
gender is that you know we're not
all of us right here would be
comfortable doing on the daily on a
daily basis but that's that is what
happens there
um
okay so my own my own situation is when
i was a teenager i was in a living
situation that was
not good and i was um
there's sexual abuse and i was placed
into a
group home in the foster care system
when i got there it was an all-female
group home
excuse me
and when i found out that it was
becoming
uh co-ed um i became very alarmed
because this was my i was a teenager and
there are a lot of foster homes for
teenagers so this was the only option i
had
my social worker was looking for a very
long time for a place for me to live
and um
i didn't have i didn't have a lock on my
door didn't have my own bedroom and the
woman that ran the home said that
she had a lot of problems with boys
coming in in the middle of the night
hitting on girls when they didn't want
it
which you know you can figure out what
that really means i was
looking at bridges to live under and
places i knew in the woods to go live in
because
i couldn't figure out where i was going
to find a safe place otherwise
and
i ended up going back to the place where
i originally lived
um and barricading my door with
furniture so i could be safe
and that is not something that would be
afforded to the woman that was described
by
by representative gould in the in the
prison system
it's hellacious and you need when you're
in the when you're in the correctional
institution you want to be focusing on
the next steps that you have to take to
be healthy and
get better
and that's what i'd like for the women
in the prison system in our state as
well we just want to protect those women
and
if there are any questions i will do my
best to answer them i may not
be perfect with that but i will do my
best thank you representative our
questions for representative putin
o'brien
representative gay
thank you mr chair
are you equivilating
god it's not a good word
are you making it equivalent are you
assuming
that
putting trans people
in their uh
sexual
where they feel they are
in prison are you assuming that that's
the only option
that and that all trans women are
dangerous no absolutely not absolutely
not thank you for that question i really
appreciate being able to to say that no
i don't think that trans people are
dangerous i think that
there are vulnerabilities that will be
exploited though and i
i've also spent time talking with i was
in a rape survivor support group and
i've spent a lot of time talking to
convicted sex offenders and i just
i can just tell you they'll exploit
anything that they can
they could even pretend to be trans just
to make an exploitation of of a
vulnerability
so i i'm glad you asked that question
because i would really like to say that
no i don't think that all trans people
are dangerous absolutely not
and
is that the only the options that we
have right now a male prison or female
prison are those the only ones we have i
think that it might be good to explore
other another option which would be
placement appropriate placement for
trans inmates as well that they could be
treated well but
perhaps separated
for for the safety of of all people
thank you
mr chair
um thank you for taking my question do
you realize
that transgender women
with breasts
and a vagina
based on this legislation could be
housed
in a male institution
i think that it would be good to explore
some other options for very specific
individual concerns that you're talking
about
follow-up
you have mentioned that maybe there need
to be separate institutions to house
these people what would the cost to the
state be
well they don't necessarily have to be
separate institutions but they could be
separate
housing uh options such as a different
area
okay i would i would i would like to say
thank you very much for your question
and i want people treated fairly and
equally people of all kinds
and that's
that's what i hope will happen
that is my aim
and that includes the trans community
all right thank you
one more follow-up yes one more
thank you mr chair thank you
i'm going to go back to a question i had
before
who decides who should be evaluated and
how will that decision be made
thank you i think that's a good question
when you go into the into the
penal system
that that's already a decision that's
made and that's already an assessment
that's made
i think that you you pro i'm gonna move
quickly and to say that i think you are
talking about maybe some concerns about
on the street when people are coming
into a bathroom or something and people
may fight amongst themselves in the
public
about someone looking
in a way that they are concerned about
and is would be scary to them
i think that is a that is a concern
and i don't want that that to happen i
don't want any i don't want people to
fight with each other and and have a
potential for possible violence in those
cases but what i am seeing in many
businesses more and more now are
individual bathrooms where that is that
concern is automatically
off the table when i go to the grocery
stores and other places that's happening
more and more and that's a that would be
a
sensitive and appropriate way to address
the issue i hope you would agree with
that
i i i am concerned about the same things
leave it at that answer right there
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
i am
wondering if the approach that we are
taking
to deal with aggressors and aggression
which is the problem
is the wrong approach
somebody who commits an assault somebody
who is gaming the system
somebody who is putting other people in
genuine fear
is the problem
and what we would you agree that what we
need to do
is address the people who are the
aggressors and the problem
and the people who are the aggressors
and the problem
are not the transgender people
so
why would we be
burdening the transgender people
for the acts of people who are
aggressors and ought to be
stopped from their aggression and if we
have a problem with the prison
population
should we not be addressing the
aggressors in the prison population
rather than burdening a community that's
already
burdened enough
thank you for that question
i think
that's true yes we should
attack the people
that problem not the people but we
should attract attack the problem of
people that are being aggressive and i
think this is a tool that will help to
what about the women that would have to
be in a in a prison system
with
men men
who were born male
and now identifying as female that may
be more of a risk to them
i think this gives a tool to to our
community to address this issue in the
same way that if i were on the uh
if i were in the united kingdom ministry
of justice and i was reading this study
from 2018 that i first talked about that
i would i would be wanting
i would want a way to address this issue
because when it hadn't been addressed
they're dealing with a different problem
now
okay thank you representative folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question i was
very intrigued by the report from
england that you were talking about
and
to be honest i didn't even know that
they were doing
transgender
uh populations in different prisons
and so
you know i'm like looking it up really
quick um
and i've i've found something and i'd
like to
get your opinion as to whether or not
you think this is kind of where a
basically within the
prisons
a transgender accommodation unit would
be established
and
then for the sleeping arrangements but
then during the day the the population
would be together
um but the thing that was very
interesting to me and this is my big
question because it addresses
a couple other representatives questions
is that
they had to obtain a gender recognition
certificate i'm assuming that means
there was a prison psychiatrist that
they had to go to and state yes this is
really
who i am
this is how
i want to associate
would it be appropriate for
someone who wants to declare themselves
transgender after they've gotten to
prison
you know so there's no history yet of
them
would it be appropriate for them to have
to see
the prison psychologist for a while to
weed out the people
that are the aggressors
and let allow
the ones that are not the aggressors
to be able to be part of one of their
their units that
are
separate but equal within the prison
i don't know the all the details on that
and that would be an appropriate
question to ask
a representative from the corrections
department thank you thank you
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative i need some education i
apologize of all in the form of a
question if you would yes um i
you quoted an article from the daily
mail
uh variously you said it was 2020 or
2018.
for the committee daily mail is right up
there with the new york post as a source
of reliable information for those of you
who checked the new york post
can you give me some idea of how common
a problem this is in new hampshire are
we talking about
thousands of people are we talking about
hundreds of people are we talking about
22 i mean how extensive a problem is
this
thankfully we're a small state and that
means we're going to have a small prison
population and and
so when you're talking about numbers
they're not going to be the same as what
they experience in the united kingdom
the article that i talked about if i
said 2018 i apologize i mean it came
from from the the daily mail written by
don shaw and it was published on may 18
and it referenced the united kingdom
ministry of justice so if you do not
trust that specific article you can of
course go and read
the reports that the ministry of justice
has put out and you can go backtrack in
that in that manner and find the correct
information that way even if you do not
trust that specific
source you can of course go back to the
united kingdom ministry of justice my
question mr chairman follow up many in
new hampshire
i do not have that information for you
if there's a if there is a
representative from the corrections
department that would be
a person to ask those specific numbers
of chairman thank you sir yep yep
no uh representative canuck
i was just curious about your comment
about the um
having a place to go co-ed
which seems quite different than
transgender identification the
phraseology we have always been taught
is it's a consistent and persistent
identity
identity or identification over a period
of time not a casual today i think i am
now suddenly a female
and so
aren't those really quite different to
go co-ed versus to have a person with a
persistent and consistent belief that
speaking i look i was never in the
corrections institutions myself but i
can
there are some parallels
in a group home in the foster care
system you're in a place you can't leave
you don't have a choice you have to stay
there it's
it's
it's it's not
you you'll
face repercussions if you leave and they
they'll be terrible and because you're
you're forced to stay there you're
forced to be with people you do not know
and you don't know their intentions you
don't know where they're coming from you
just met them recently you hope they're
good but you have to protect yourself
you're gonna get hurt follow up your
follow-up website i was actually
speaking about the group home not about
incarceration you used that example and
i'm asking how does that example fit
when we talk about going co-ed versus a
transgender person who has a persistent
and consistent identification as the
other sex
to the person to to a female that's
that's in there and has to live there as
i said and you can't leave and you are
with strangers there is no difference
thank you very much
any further questions for the
representative
thank you very much representative
like to call
ms holly stevens
representing nami of new hampshire and
there is a
document that she has provided the
committee
which is being
passed out
ms stevens thank you for being here
today and uh we need to ask because we
have about 20 more people to speak with
to confine the comments to three minutes
i will be as brief as possible chairman
thank you for meeting the goal
chairman and members of the committee my
name is holly stevens
i am the public policy director of nami
on behalf of nami new hampshire i'm here
today to speak in opposition to house
bill 1180.
specifically
i'm here to talk about the high risk for
depression suicide attempts and suicide
deaths for trans individuals
by way of background nami new
hampshire's connect suicide prevention
program
has been designated as a national best
practice in suicide prevention
intervention and postvention
um and it has been trained in over 40
states and 35 tribal nations
there's a chart on the
written testimony and it shows that
suicide is the second leading cause of
death
for individuals in new hampshire ages
10 to 34.
it's the third leading cause of death
for individuals ages 35 to 44
and the fourth leading cause of death
for individuals 45 to 54 in the state of
new hampshire
suicide deaths are only the tip of the
iceberg in contrast to suicide attempts
and the human and economic impact of
suicide deaths and attempts is
significant
a small but important subgroup
of individuals in this
pool of statistics
are people who are dealing with gender
identity issues
there's an emerging body of research
showing that trans
people are likely to attempt suicide at
an alarmingly higher rate than their
peers in the general population
a 2021 study indicated that people who
undergo hormone therapy or gender
affirming surgery
had significant reductions in
psychological distress including
restricting people to
their quote unquote biological based sex
or their gender assignment at birth
as laid out in the proposed bill
is harmful to the mental health of trans
individuals
and as indicated in the previously
mentioned studies that are
included in the testimony
it's likely to increase the risk for
depression suicide and suicide attempts
in trans individuals and i just want to
say something that's been on my mind
since last week which is
bills like these in and of themselves
going through the process is harmful
to individuals who are affected by these
bills
there's a bill heard last week and this
one too that the longer they're
in the house and discussed and voted on
it sends a message
to the trans community um
and so i just want
i just want individuals to think about
that that the longer it stays in this
committee
the more harm it's going to do thank you
ms stevens will you take questions i
will take questions related to my
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking questions um i i
appreciate the
not appreciate i'm incredibly saddened
and troubled by how much higher the
suicide rate is in trans in trans people
and i
think that that is something that we
need to make sure that we never ignore
and we never gloss over i'm curious as
to
whether you believe that continuing to
recognize the biologic sex and the
and the
recognized gender
if that's something that might actually
lead to catching more suicide ideation
within the criminal justice system or
anywhere else because it is a specific
risk factor and i'm curious if you've
thought about that i don't quite
understand are you tell are you asking
if
trans individuals are identified as
trans going through the process
that
it would be easier to keep an eye on
them for suicidal ideation is that what
you're asking
my question is the health risks there's
both suicide and also
men trans men have a two times increased
risk of cancer and if their specific
health needs
are
ignored if we don't also recognize their
i know it's a hard question it is a hard
question because you know with with the
privacy
laws in this state you know a couple
years ago it was introduced into the
constitution you know i think that a
person and their doctor
there are a lot of reasons that people
are at higher risk for lots of
different medical conditions a lot of
family history goes into it
and it's up to that individual and their
doctor
to discuss what those are and i think
that that is left best left between
somebody and their doctor to discuss
their entire health history and what
they might be at risk for
thank you
thank you any further questions
representative ackman thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
i have to say i'm i'm a little shocked
by our last statement there um
the
here in the house we received all kinds
of bills this is where we hash out ideas
and and work on solutions some never
make it
um some do but we have to be able to
just to discuss things these things
am i wrong in thinking that you just
were
kind of telling us not to discuss these
things in essence censoring us from from
talking about this bill because we may
offend somebody
that was not my point my point was just
to provide education
that
just bills like this coming forward can
be harmful
you can take that for what what you will
i mean
it's it's a fact
and
um
so i just wanted to present that
thank you
thank you representative representative
pearson
thank you mr chairman uh do you believe
that the longer
bills like this are in committee before
being passed into law
the more female athletes will lose
in the sports for which they train so
hard
and title ix the liberalism of its day
that's not something that i can comment
nami new hampshire doesn't really weigh
into the fairness of sports so i don't
have any information on that but there
might be some other folks that do
okay thank you very much
thank you
oh excuse me representative gay thank
you mr chair um would you have any
objection
to the sports section of this proposed
bill
being retained
as opposed to
the other bill the other two sections
being dealt with individually as
because they all seem to be very
different from absolutely stupid too
important so do you have any problem
with that section with the sports after
people like
like a very famous trans
athlete has
supported
i'm not able to weigh in on pulling this
apart
this bill
on its face is harmful um
and i
all three parts of it are harmful um and
okay one one more question
would you believe
it is very harmful
to excellent women in sports
who are now losing
to biological males
would you believe that is harmful and
that i don't know but i'd be more than
happy to take a look at any studies that
thank you ms stevens thank you
she may approach the bench thank you
very much and
three minutes thank you
good morning everyone thank you mr
chairman and to the members of this
committee for giving me the opportunity
to speak with you today my name is
caroline levitt i am currently a
republican candidate for the nomination
in the first district but today i am
with you as a concerned lifelong citizen
of this state and a former competitive
athlete
aside from my family our small
businesses my friends and my education
athletics was a major part of my
upbringing in this state
my innate passion for softball in many
many years of hard work earned me an
athletic scholarship to compete for the
ncaa division two at st anselm college
i spent years making sacrifices and
working tirelessly to achieve my
athletic goals and compete at the
highest level that i possibly could
and it's difficult for me to imagine if
a biological man who was no doubt bigger
stronger and inherently physically
superior to me had taken my well-earned
starting position of third baseman on my
middle school high school or especially
collegiate softball teams
it's difficult for me to imagine as a
young woman standing at third base just
feet away from home plate being forced
to face a man as he steps up to the
plate to hit the ball and right now in
our state that is a possibility that
women and girls may face given our
existing law
recently we have seen many instances of
injustices against biological women in
athletics as biological men unfairly
compete against them and win big time on
the track in the swimming pool and on
the court
the most recent and perhaps egregious
example is the case of leah thomas the
university of pennsylvania swimmer who
continues to crush her female opponents
and break records by unprecedented
margins
how is this fair
anyone with a little bit of common sense
will look at leah thomas's physical
stature
their hands
feet
lungs and recognize that leah thomas
should not be competing against women
but we live in a state and a country in
which this is allowed to occur because
our leaders at all levels have failed to
stand up for the basic truth
that biological women and men are
inherently different
but equal
today you all have an opportunity to
stand up for this basic truth you all
have an opportunity to ensure that such
unfairness is not allowed in our great
state the bill before you today provides
necessary guard rails to our law which
align with federal law title ix which
exists because women championed it and
pioneered it for decades and it was
signed over 40 years ago and we live in
a country now where it is being violated
before our very eyes
lastly
i would just like to add that the bill
before you today goes much further than
the field or the locker room or the
prison cell
competing fairly and safely and
competitively in athletics made me who i
am it gave me lifelong friendships
provided me with great memories but most
importantly it ingrained in unwavering
inner confidence and steadfast
determination in me to achieve my goals
i want every young girl in this state to
have the athletic opportunities that i
did
so as a woman as a lifelong new
hampshire citizen and a former athlete
who has competed at a very high level
please stand up for truth today please
support house bill 1180 and when i'm
elected to serve in congress i pledge to
stand with you at the federal level
thank you very much thank you ms levitt
do we have questions from the committee
representative cannon
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
how often
in new hampshire
has this been an issue
we certainly have not seen the
ramifications of this in our state yet
but as our law stands and as we see the
trend of this across the country taking
place
i can imagine the flood gates will open
and we have to stop this in its tracks
before it occurs why should we wait for
a young woman to be unfairly competed
against on the track on the softball
field or in the swimming pool why should
we wait for that unfairness to occur why
should we not take action now to stand
up for the basic truths that i just
thank you very much
thank you for uh representative gay
uh i'll ask the thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question i'll
ask the same question do you have any
problem with this uh bill being
separated into portions so that we can
can you explain your thought process on
that please
representative if you don't mind there
are three parts to this
bathrooms
prison
sports
do you have any problem separating out
sports into a
separate bill
the truth is relevant in all three
instances the truth is the same in all
three instances like i said whether it's
on the field whether it's on the track
whether it's on the court biological men
and women are inherently different and
the ramifications in all three areas
that this bill includes
it doesn't change that truth and so i
think the legislation as it stands is
appropriate and again i encourage
everyone to support it
thank you mr chairman
the initials lgbt question mark
i sometimes get those all mixed up but
they all
have something in common
in terms of transgender
all of these individuals
are subject to
severe stigma
in our society
and i'm concerned that this legislation
is going to
increase that stigma uh to a point
obviously
individuals in these various categories
are like every other human being they're
subject
to
difficulties
including mental health problems and
we've heard about suicide
so that i'm very concerned and i hope
you are too
that we don't increase
the
stigma that already exists but in fact
are trying to
alleviate rather than
yeah
would you agree
you
of course and as the speakers prior to
me
mentioned we don't want to see anyone
feeling that way we don't want anyone in
our state to suffer from mental health
issues and we certainly don't want to
see people taking their own lives
but again i stand for the basic inherent
truths that i mentioned that biological
men and women are inherently different
and we should not be allowing such
injustice to occur in our state
period
oh okay any further questions
for ms
levitt thank you very much miss oh oh my
nothing else okay thank you very much ms
lovett
okay i'll call uh
mr chris urschel
representing
glad
glad and he has a
testimony that he's provided
to the committee which is going around
and
please keep your overview to three
minutes sir if you would
thank you chair pearson thank you
members of the committee my name is
chris urchel i'm a new hampshire
licensed attorney and i'm here on behalf
of glbtq legal advocates and defenders
glaad which is a major legal rights
organization serving the lgbtq community
in new england and nationally i'm here
today to express glads opposition to
hb1180 i know you are um you all know a
lot about the path toward equality for
transgender people here in new hampshire
you've heard about it or we'll hear
about it from others who are testifying
today
in 2018 and 2019 after years of
bipartisan effort this body passed
legislation to protect the rights of
transgender people in new hampshire
in 2020 and 2021 efforts to undermine
those protections specifically aimed at
children have been itled
here we are again in 2022 confronting
yet another bill that's targeting
transgender people this time the bill
singles out vulnerable youth and
additionally incarcerated people
first i want to clear up something about
what the text of the bill actually does
versus what it does not do
the bill does single out transgender
people to send a message that they're
not welcome the bill is stigmatizing and
hostile because it draws a line around a
category of people those whose gender
identity is not the same as their natal
sex and tells them that their gender is
not valid it is absolute in its terms
its bluntness is what belies its cruelty
at the same time i want to mention what
the bill does not do despite what others
have
suggested in this room today it does not
change the rules for participation in
school sports the new hampshire
interscholastic athletics association
sets policy for eligibility in new
hampshire schools
that policy directs school districts to
look holistically at a student's daily
life in the community to determine
eligibility for participation on a
sex-separated team birth certificates
and driver's license they're not even
mentioned in the policy sure a birth
certificate might provide some evidence
of a student's consistent assertion of
their gender identity but nothing in the
policy directs school officials to rely
on a birth certificate i want to add
that if this bill were a renewed effort
to prohibit transgender girls from
playing school sports that bill would be
in violation of house rule 36e which
prohibits similar legislation from being
introduced in a second year session
and a bill was already introduced last
year to override the policy and the
current policy and that bill was itled
the last thing i'd like to explain is
that hb 1180 is unconstitutional
the supreme court has made it very clear
that laws of this nature cannot survive
review under the 14th amendment to the
u.s constitution
back in 1992 in colorado the county of
denver as well as the cities of aspen
and boulder introduced protections for
gay and lesbian people against
discrimination
and
many people did not want those
protections and there was a vote in a
state to uh to to amend the constitution
to prohibit protections for um lgbtq
people
and the supreme court ruled that that
was unconstitutional uh the reason is
because it singled out a politically
vulnerable class of people imposed on
them a quote a special disability
the court said that this unusual method
of singling out a group for different
treatment proves that the bill quote is
born of animosity toward the class of
persons protect affected now i'm not
saying that every law that could
possibly impact transgender people in
new hampshire is automatically rooted in
animus that's not what i'm saying in
fact i've testified before this very
committee on other bills and i've never
previously claimed that any legislation
legislators intent is uh to
intentionally harm transgender people
but this bill this bill is different
hb1180 serves no valid purpose at all
other than to stigmatize and
delegitimize uh transgender people
specifically calling out transgender
youth and transgender people who are
incarcerated the law is cruel and it's
unconstitutional and has no place here
in new hampshire and i'm happy to take
questions um there's been a lot of
misinformation that i've heard in this
room today and i would like to help
clarify for anyone who has questions all
right thank you attorney herschel
questions for the
attorney representative pearson
thank you
um you
just to make sure i heard you correctly
you use the term special disability sir
do you believe that transgender people
are disabled
that's not the um thank you for the
question that is not the uh when the
supreme court used the word a special
disability they were not referring to
disability in the sense that we
understand it today we understand the
understanding of the court in the in
saying that was that it imposes a
disability on a class of people by
giving them different treatment under
the law that's not the health disability
context that we're commonly used to
hearing the word
does that answer a question
it'll stipulate that it does
is there any further questions
representative cannon
thank you mr chair
would you believe
that with all the legislation and the
focusing on transgender people and
the challenges we face that there are
times when i walk down the street and i
i would believe that because it's true
that many many transgender people across
the country
and across the world in fact
including here in new hampshire face a
lot of threats of violence against their
person and um and to that point
arguments that there should be separate
facilities for people who claim to be
transgender because apparently a lot of
people believe that people would pretend
to be transgender in order to harm women
so the idea that i've heard in this room
that they should be put in places with
transgender people and isolated from
other people so that transgender people
are subject to um to to assault is is is
an obscene suggestion suggestion in my
view
thank you for the question
thank you very much representative knuck
just a quick question uh the
a lot of conversation came around the
athletics in itself has been presented
again as kind of a binary either male or
female but can you clarify because i
don't know the answer how many
transgender identity transgender females
so biologic males identifying females in
let's say middle school and high school
who are competing are on hormonal
therapy
testosterone blockers and would that
equalize that physical advantage which
would otherwise exist if it were a
non-treated biological meal thank you
for the question there is no evidence to
suggest that a pers a transgender girl
who has been
treated with
puberty suppressing hormone therapy at a
young age
has any any different performance in any
athletics there's no evidence to suggest
that and that is um that is a an
increasingly large percentage of
transgender youth in um in
in new hampshire schools and so to
suggest that they should be excluded
from sports because they have some
advantage that they don't have is uh is
is overbroad and absurd thank you for
the question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
are you aware that there are actual
skeletal differences between biological
males and biological females and that a
female's hips actually the when you hang
a skeleton
the
the femur
angles in
and then the the calf the the
shin bones angle actually will go
straight down from that angle and that
the males actually are straighter and
that the upper body strength of a male
whether they're
taking hormonal
treatments or not still
gives them an advantage over females
biological females thank you for the res
um for the question respectfully um your
suggestion that there's a categorical
difference between the skeletons of
people born male and people born female
is false there's not a categorical
distinction between skeletons
furthermore the the
the concept that people who have taken
puberty suppressing hormone therapy from
the time they were a young person before
um before going through puberty that
they would have any difference from a
person of the same gender
and their skeleton system is not rooted
in science or evidence there's no
evidence to support what you just said
for those people and
moreover
information about a particular person's
what i can speak to is the fact that
hormonal like
natal males and natal females have
categorically different hormonal body
like their bodies produce different
levels of hormones of different types of
hormones that is categorically true and
so to the point to the extent that that
was your point um then you're absolutely
correct um otherwise otherwise i don't
um
i would need to see evidence to support
your other claims one follow-up delemus
thank you mr chairman
would you believe that i was a a
psychology major and a bio minor biolog
biology minor in college and that there
is
very
clear evidence of the differences
between
male and female skeletons
um i
would believe your credentials as you
described them but i would disagree that
there is any evidence that a person who
has been
on puberty suppressing hormone therapy
from the from a young age has a
different skeleton from somebody of the
same gender
thank you thank you very much
representative chair pearson
thank you mr chairman
do you think that males and females and
i'm talking biological groups here not
social constructs
that males and females are real
categories of people that exist
and therefore the state sometimes is
justified in seeing this difference
between categories
um thank you for the question to the
extent that the first part of your
question was an existential question and
i do not have an answer for it to the
extent that the quote the state has an
interest in recognizing that different
people of different genders
have different
different cultural social and physical
physical roles i agree
follow up
you're saying you can't answer the
question that males and females
are separate biological groups without
claiming that is merely existential is
that your statement um respectively that
wasn't your question but um but
can you restate your question then so i
do you think that males and females
as biological groups
are real separate categories of people
what do you mean by real
okay the question is the question sounds
strange to me i'm having trouble
understanding i'll accept that as your
answer
thank you we'll do
uh representative pearson
thank you mr chairman
um i'm a
bit of a history
not i'm actually a published historical
author and i've i've
had the fortune of attending some or
being in the presence of some very
amazing archaeological finds through
museums of throughout the world
especially recently in the british
museum
archaeological digs occur are these
archaeologists incorrect when they
identify the bones they find as male or
female based on the characteristics of
um thank you for the question i assume
you're referring back to rep delemus's
question
in which case i think i can clarify what
i was answering to make
to
help you help you understand what what
the point is that i was making when i
said that there is not a categorical
distinction between any skeletal
elements of males and females what i
mean to say is that there are people who
are born male who have skeletal who have
a range of skeletal
you know
possible skeletons and there are a range
of people born female
possible skeletons and there is overlap
between each element of a person's
skeleton there is overlap between
potential male skeletons and female
skeletons so no i don't believe that
historic historical uh
architecture sorry not architecture but
uh
archaeologists i do not think that they
are incorrect to make distinctions
between bodies based on the evidence
that they have i just i'm making the
point that the distinction is not
categorical and that not every single
male skeleton is identical and not every
single female skeleton is identical
as as one who grew up with exactly the
same sized hands as her older brother i
appreciate that answer
uh
would you agree with me that there are
individuals born in this and every other
century
who are not
entirely male nor entirely female who
have
characteristic some characteristics of
each gender
and that sometimes children are born who
appear biologically female
and
from an external point of view are not
identified as chromosomally male until
they hit puberty
and so would you not agree with me
that the determination of biological sex
while clear in many individuals
is not as binary as we have been
accustomed to thinking of it as
thank you so much for the question and i
believe that your question actually
underscores a lot of the points that i
was uh you know trying to articulate
here and you articulated it much better
which is to say that
biological sex has is not and has never
been a strict binary although the number
of people born with intersex
characteristics that you were describing
is a very small percentage of people
those people do in fact exist and have
always existed and have always suffered
from
exclusion and stigmatization and um and
and other and other um maladies because
of their status being born on intersex
thank you for the question
a follow-up representative weber
so is it possible that there are people
who are identified at birth
as being of one sex and that sex is
recorded on their birth certificate
and it is later determined that that was
incorrect
i would agree that it that it that
people can be classified a certain way
on their birth certificate and that
their birth certificate would then
reflect something that isn't consistent
with their intersex characteristics for
those people who are born that way
that's absolutely true and there are um
numerous examples right now in the field
of olympic athletics right of people of
women who are born women identified as
women their entire lives but because
they were born with differences in um
sexual development that they that they
are are being singled out as being
ineligible to participate in sports um
so so yes you're absolutely right that
this has
always been um an
okay no nothing further thank you
attorney
um i promised the committee that i would
give last week that i would give written
testimony on a different bill and i'm
you
for the members it's uh house bill 1077
just for the record to make sure
you all get your copies
okay thank you so much for your time
thank you very much attorney i'd like to
recognize uh hope i pronounced the name
he's representing himself and he's in
you have three minutes sir
thank you mr chairman and committee for
allowing me to testify
um i'm going to come at this from a
slightly different point of view
right this uh house bill 1088 is
attempting to amend rsa5-c
colon 87
and rsa 260 which are two two existing
laws that we have
um we have to have specificity in our
laws or they become meaningless and
unenforceable we can't have a law that
continually allows the goal post to be
moved based on the latest ideology
this is what we have been doing on these
two laws by categorizing people by
gender rather than biological sex
biological sex as you all know refers to
a person's physical characteristics at
birth and their genetic makeup one x and
y for male
two x chromosomes for female with few
exceptions this is unambiguous the few
exceptions i'm talking about are the
things that have been discussed relative
to intersex
uh issues here today according to the
national library of medicine point zero
one eight percent of the births have
intersex characteristics
okay that's that's documented um
so gender identity and biological sex
are different they are not equal
right so biological sex is objective and
specific
gender is subjective and fluid we have
to be specific in our definitions
relative to our existing legislation
that's in place as law and that's what
hb 1180 is attempting to do it's not
about bullying anyone as some have
stated i've heard that several times
it's about seeking rationality and
reasonableness in identifying a person's
true biological sex aside from what they
may choose regarding gender
it's about seeking fairness safety and
emotional well-being
for our citizens in all scenarios
it's your duty as legislators to make
that happen
and i urge you to support
1088 as an otp
thank you chairman thank you sir have
the questions for mr pankasek
being seen thank you very much for your
testimony i do have written testimony to
leave with you here i made you 22 copies
so you don't have to oh thank you for
i'd like to recognize
taylor
lamin
who opposes the bill
and is representing
himself
um yes i represent myself and unh law um
lambda our queer advocacy group on
campus and so
um thank you for
um today and good morning
um lamb to the queer advocacy group at
unh law strongly opposes hb 1180
state recognition of biological sex we
stand in salah in solidarity with the
trans and non-binary communities that
this bill would affect
discrimination has no place in our
society let alone in the state of new
hampshire
yet new hampshire is the only northeast
state to introduce an anti-trans bill in
2022 joining arizona alabama indiana
kentucky oklahoma and south dakota our
state and country at large needs to move
past the stigmatization of these groups
ones that have faced far too great
oppression throughout our history
according to the mayo clinic and as you
may know
some but not all transgender and gender
non-conforming people might experience
gender dysphoria at some point in their
lives
gender dysphoria is a diagnosis
diagnosis listed in the dsm 5 a manual
published by the american psychiatric
association to diagnose mental
conditions this term is intended to be
more descriptive than
the one that was previously used which
was
gender identity disorder
the term gender dysphoria focuses on
one's discomfort as the problem rather
than identity
a diagnosis for gender dysphoria was
created to help people get access to
necessary health care and effective
treatment and so when i hear people
earlier testifying to
um
their
issues that they faced in sports or
their perceived issues as a competitive
swimmer um throughout my entire life i
never once felt threatened by
a trans athlete competing against me
um and i think that a lot of the
testimony here today actually undermines
the mental struggles that that community
faces
um
the trans community and non-binary
people deserve respect in all settings
especially public ones free from the
fear that a public entity will create
inequalities discrimination and mental
health barriers based on their
respective identities
according to glsen
one sixty percent of transgender
students report having been prohibited
from using the bathroom or locker room
that aligns with their gender identity
76 percent of transgender students felt
unsafe at school because of their gender
and transgender people are at a very
high risk of experiencing violence
throughout their lives starting even
before adolescence
two these bills hurt students academic
achievement including lower gpas so i
want to re-emphasize the importance of
the stigmatization that a continued
conversation in committee and outside of
it continues for our um
for our community
three such bills would create a public
health crisis research shows that as a
result of hostile school climate
transgender students are more likely to
abuse drugs than the general population
and so i will conclude
my statements now to honor the time and
i will answer any questions in my
individual capacity unaffiliated from
unh law all right thank you sir other
questions
done being seen thank you very much for
your testimony and for providing in
writing
like to uh
recognize next
and
she's in support of the bill and
hi my name is madison goldstein i'm a
senior
not even close
i'm a senior at bishop curtin high
school it's okay and i live in bedford
i'm a multi-sport female athlete in
support of house bill
i have done ski racing since age 6 and
rowing since age 12 and i will continue
to row at the college level as a
recruited athlete
throughout my years in ski racing i have
been training amongst both boys and
girls but our races are always divided
separately
at practice my coaches would always send
me down the course right after my friend
brady they would tell me to catch him i
never could and i still can't no matter
how hard i try he always beats me
whenever a guy beats a girl's mile time
or 100 meter freestyle no one thinks
much of it
it's expected but whenever a girl beats
a guy's mile time or 100 meter freestyle
it's a big deal
i can't believe you just beat a boy
that's crazy or i can't believe you just
let a girl beat you
boys have a larger skill to amass in
girls they have wider shoulders and
longer limbs and a lot more testosterone
so i expect my friend brady to beat me i
try my hardest but i know i probably
won't beat him but that's okay because i
don't compete against him only in
practice
but if i did compete against him i'd be
discouraged it wouldn't be fair he's
almost a foot taller than me he has at
least 50 pounds on me he has more muscle
mass than me and he's got a lot more
testosterone than me
sports present an opportunity to have
fun show off your talents and improve
always aiming to be the best
but i won't have fun if i'm competing
against someone biologically different
from me
like my friend brady i can't show off my
talents as he will always beat me and i
may improve but i stand no chance
against him so i will have to aim for
second best
i am genetically different from brady
down to the weight and strength of my
bones and that is something no one can
change
don't let the female athletes of the
next generations be discouraged
please consider voting to keep athletes
competing against those with whom they
are biologically similar thank you for
listening thank you miss goldstein uh
questions for
miss goldstein
not being hurt oh excuse me
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question it might be a hard
one but
if you had to compete
with a biological male
who identified as a female and that was
something that became prevalent in
skiing in your sport
would you quit
um what would there be purpose to your
to to competing against someone like
that
i would probably start out trying but i
think i'd get discouraged pretty easily
um competing against someone who
is a lot taller than me
and maybe way more than me and just like
biologically is different than me um
would be pretty discouraging and i feel
like it wouldn't be fair
follow-up
thank you mr chair
um
would you believe
that my mother was a
phys ed director for the laconia school
system for decades and i grew up
as a child
competing
and
running and playing and being steeped in
women's sports
and would you believe
that
i am well aware of the differences and i
know how disappointing it can be when
you have to compete against someone when
it's not fair
yes i believe you it's very um
i'm sure we don't have this issue yet in
new hampshire but i'm sure it would be
very disappointing for the next
generations of female athletes thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much ms goldstein for taking my question
is it also unfair for you to have to
compete against a female athlete who is
six foot two inches tall and maybe
weighs 250 pounds more than you do or
has a longer arm reach
for swimming
um i already do compete against as a
rower i compete against girls who are
six foot tall i'm actually very short
for a rower but i have worked very hard
and i'm going division one i'm going to
lehigh university and i am very excited
about it
i do already face disadvantages but i
know that
those girls are biologically the same as
me they may be taller than me but
some of the boys on the team are almost
seven foot tall and most of their those
girls aren't seven foot tall so to
compete against someone who would be two
feet taller than me rather in that sense
wouldn't be fair but if they're
biologically have the same
bone structure and strength as me then i
think i face a shot at being able to
beat them
thank you for your answer and thank you
congratulations on your achievements
thank you
representative soloway
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
goldstein for taking my question
congratulations on going to lehigh
um
do you think that if you trained for the
biathlon and i'm confident you know what
the biathlon is
or that if you trained for competitive
sculling and i'm sure you know what that
is
or if like dana patrick you trained for
automobile racing might you be
competitive regardless of gender
um i might be competitive yes but if i'm
competing against a biological male who
is also training the same amount as i
am then i might not be as competitive
okay thank you for your answer
representative gay
thank you mr chair
there are two other parts to the bill so
i wanted to know if your opinion of one
of the other parts in your school there
may or may not be trans students are you
comfortable in the same bathroom with a
we do have some trans students at our
school
personally i have never been in a trance
or in a bathroom at the same time as a
trans student
um
we do
i think the majority of them just go to
the personalized like single stall
bathrooms um but that is something i
thank you very much miss goldstein
we recognize uh jacob maxwell
who opposes the bill and represents he's
here to represent himself
i'm jacob maxwell i live in concord new
hampshire
i'm here today to speak against this
bill this bill and all the others like
it have only one intended effect
to eliminate the existence of
transgender people by any means
necessary
half of all transgender people
are children who are not accepted and
supported in their community will
for some of you this is the point and i
hope the shame of this cruelty follows
you for the rest of your life
for others you may not believe the
statistics or the severity that these
bills have on a fragile and marginalized
crew group
to those of you i need you to look at me
i need you to look up from your boredom
and your phones and your doodling
this is not a game this is not a
political football to be kicked around
this is life and death
this is a chance of happiness
versus a short life of despair
this is about a human life
this is my child's life
there is no gray area there are no
difficult choices
it is life and death
vote down this bill or forever live with
that shame of your actions
i know that this bill is not about
sports but i hear what everyone's
talking and i see what is coming
my daughter is transgender she has
challenges understanding social norms
and this year she joined roller derby
and i watched her skills grow
exponentially
i watched her skate in a pod of other
kids
all holding hands and trying to move as
one group
the goal was not competition
it was a practice of holding each other
up as a team
i've watched my daughter change and
learn the skills that would bring her
through her life successfully because of
teamwork
she is as deserving of these experiences
as any other child
the act of denying these experiences is
discrimination and unconstitutional
thank you
recognize mr ian
hoyt
three minutes mr hoya
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee ian hewitt i'm general counsel
at cornerstone which is a christian
advocacy
organization i wanted to make myself
available to answer any questions about
how this bill relates to state and
federal non-discrimination laws and i
hope to and look forward to answering
some tough questions about that but in
my testimony i wanted to focus on how
clarifying the debate around this bill
is
because oftentimes in this area you will
hear people on the other side of this
issue say something like for example
the state can differentiate between men
and women it just can't differentiate
between transgender women and
non-transgender women now that kind of
statement can be confusing and
disorienting if you're not initiated
into the kind of well-constructed system
of jargon that cultural progressivism
has created around issues of gender and
it can be unclear at first glance
whether people in that group see any
role at all for biology but the debate
around this bill very clearly
illuminates that issue representative
gould's bill is so modest that it would
not even exclude a single biologically
male athlete from competing in women's
sports in new hampshire it simply says
the state
can recognize biological males and
females as real groups of people and can
differentiate between people on that
basis which has always been part of
federal constitutional law in this
country
and internal agency policies in new
hampshire and yet we have heard from
naomi and from glaad that that by itself
is invidious discrimination and is
illegal somehow and you don't need to be
a lawyer or a constitutional scholar or
a philosophy professor to tell that if
the state can't even say it reserves the
right to consider biological sex then
the state can never differentiate
between people on the basis of
biological sex and if we go one premise
deeper i assume my opponents here don't
think they're telling you to ignore
reality
so it follows just biological necessity
that opponents of this bill don't even
think biological males and females are
real groups of people
um and in fact we can hear that in terms
like sex assigned at birth the idea
being that the two sexes which are 1.2
billion years old are purely imaginary
arbitrary social constructs assigned to
you by society and this should raise
alarming questions not just for whether
some biological males can compete in
women's sports but whether we can even
in the first place have separate sports
sports leagues and prison facilities and
so on for these two apparently imaginary
purely socially constructed groups of
people and i would love to take any
questions legal or otherwise
questions from mr
hewitt
representative thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question i just
want to follow up on representative
gay's
question would you explain the
distinctions between the three elements
of the law
yes i would like to speak to what
representative gay said and i think that
what representative gay brings up is
important and raises an important
opportunity for clarification
because as i said earlier this bill does
not compel any school board or any
entity to adopt any particular policy it
reserves the right of state agencies in
the state to differentiate based upon
biological sex so it would not
automatically exclude anyone from
anything now in the area of
incarceration and i i believe it was
representative cannon raised an
interesting hypothetical about
what about someone who's taken hormonal
medication they've had gender
reassignment surgery do we really want
to incarcerate that person in a men's
prison it's actually already the policy
of the new hampshire department of
corrections that they will consider on a
case-by-case basis in such cases uh
which facility to assign
that person to now this to my knowledge
hasn't actually come up
yet but they would make a case-by-case
consideration in that in that instance
and i think that's the right policy
however that presumes that the state can
take into consideration biological sex
and can differentiate on that basis in
california for example california's
prison policy is even someone who has
had no hormonal treatment who has had no
gender reassignment surgery and other in
other words someone who looks like me
if they consistently assert that they
are female in california that person
will be transferred to a women's prison
because in california it's based on
gender self-declared gender identity
period
so even our status quo in new hampshire
where we can make case-by-case
considerations and that is appropriate
that requires that the state retained
the ability to consider
biological sex and treat these as real
groups of people not purely fictitious
social groups
okay thank you representative cannon
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
you've indicated that the state prison
system already has a procedure in place
to identify a transgender person where
it might be appropriate to incarcerate
them
why do we need a statute
to do that
well the statute doesn't determine where
anyone is incarcerated the statute says
that the state can recognize biological
males and females as real groups of
people and can differentiate based on
that basis
the new hampshire department of
corrections policy just just so i'm
absolutely clear it doesn't say you
assign people based on your gender
identity in new hampshire what they do
say is that in cases like that the new
hampshire department of corrections will
consider all the factors including the
safety of the inmate the safety of other
inmates and they make a case-by-case
determination unlike in california where
it's automatic based on consistently
self-declared gender identity and i if i
could give one specific example of why
this is important if you'd hold on that
because we have many more people to
testify and we're over time right now
and i apologize but uh was
there a follow-up rep canon yes i just
if you focus on the follow-up but we do
need to move forward yes
so
so you said this that still is there's a
procedure already in place that's
actually fairly extensive
so why is this statute a law
required
since it's already done here in new
hampshire
well i i think the example i was about
to give is actually responsive to to
that question mr chair and the example i
was going to point to was there is an
11th circuit court of appeals decision
about a florida case
where this was a case about bathrooms it
wasn't about prison but the same
reasoning applies where these school
districts said well we want to
differentiate based upon biological sex
and the 11th circuit court of appeals in
that case said they ruled against the
school board and they said to the school
board biological sex the 11th circuit
court of appeals said they said what are
you even talking about
this
transgender boy in this case the 11th
circuit said
his driver's license from the state of
florida says that he's a male and his
birth certificate says that he's a male
and according to the 11th circuit court
of appeals
a gender identity simply is what the
state says it is the law does not
recognize any other biological sex
quote unquote so if if we were to adopt
this bill the answer to your question is
that the new hampshire department of
corrections would retain the ability to
make case-by-case determinations and
could consider factors like the factors
you raised hormonal treatment surgical
treatment and consider biological sex
also as opposed to automatic assignment
based on what the state says like in the
11th circuit or based on
consistently self-declared gender
identity like in california
all right thank you uh
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
attorney hewitt for for taking my
question
um so we've heard the word
discrimination used on a number of
occasions here in testimony
and
at the federal level discrimination is
defined under under title vii
so there was a landmark case several
years ago heard by the supreme court
bostock versus clayton county and i
assume you're familiar with that um so
i'm trying to
understand
sort of from
essentially said that the
prohibition on discrimination based on
sex
extends to transgender people and
um
sexual or you know different sexual
orientations
um how how might the boss stock case be
applied if this were to become law in
new hampshire
i think that's a great question i think
that the boss stock interpretation of
title vii can be very helpful as we
think about this bill and i could
explain that in a couple of minutes or
less i hope with your leave mr chair not
here not today okay but in terms of
there will be a further discussion on
this but we need to hear from everyone
because we have other scheduled meetings
well i'll do my best to give a few
sentences i suppose my word please my
few sentence answer would be bostock
explained when a law prohibits
discrimination because of a certain
factor we change that factor and see if
we get a different result in the
scenario so if you fire let's in new
hampshire for example we have a state
statute prohibiting discrimination on
the basis of gender identity so if a
male employee comes into work and says
that he identifies as a woman and you
fire him to determine if there is gender
identity discrimination we change the
gender identity so suppose the
biologically male employee comes into
work and identifies as a woman
would you have
excuse me as a man that identifies as a
man we're going to change the gender
identity would you fire him presumably
no so there was gender identity
discrimination now that the distinction
and the way this is particularly helpful
is suppose a biologically male athlete
wants to compete in women's sports
identifies as a woman and is denied to
determine if there's gender identity
discrimination under bostock what do we
do we switch the gender identity
so instead we imagine a biologically
male athlete identifies as a male and
wants to compete in women's sports would
the result be different no the result
would be the same he would still be
denied so what has happened there is not
gender identity discrimination like in
bostock what's happened there is sex
discrimination and sex differentiation
is allowed under limited circumstances
thank you very much
i will recognize representative weber
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
you've stated repeatedly that
this doesn't mandate anything it permits
somebody from taking
uh
natal
sex
whatever we're calling it into account
when making a determination
my question is
where is the protection
when somebody arbitrarily says
the only consideration we will ever
consider
is the sex you were born with rather
than anything
that has transpired since what is the
protection for transgender people under
that scheme
well for example in the hypothetical i
just gave which would be under under 354
a which is our state nondiscrimination
law clearly if you fired a biologically
male employee for identifying as a woman
that would be a violation of our state
law and there isn't anything in this law
that would change that
um so we we do have state
non-discrimination protections for
transgender people and those would
thank you very much
mr hewitt
and no further questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
like to recognize
i think it's abby
maxwell
let's get the rating correct uh opposes
the bill and represents
herself
hi
you getting your clock on there
three minutes no i don't hi thank you
for taking my testimony i'm here to
oppose this bill my name is abby maxwell
i'm going to speak a little bit
differently than i planned today because
i'm listening to all of this
misinformation in here and it is
shocking um
so i currently work at the library at
the st paul's school and my typical job
there is to work the circulation desk a
few days ago my boss asked me to speak
to her civil rights class instead about
transgender rights so the students could
get a glimpse into the human side of the
issue
i would rather not spend my time opening
my family's wounds to strangers but i'm
unclear what other option i have if i'm
going to at least try to protect my
daughter this seems to be the only
pathway
i went to the class and i told them my
story my daughter is transgender she
socially transitioned when she was six
the summer before second grade we lived
in the small town that my father had
come from five five miles from my
grandfather's and great grandmother's
childhood home in the county my family
has been in for some 300 years a week
into her school year our governor signed
the law that granted her equal
protections our district began the
process of passing a policy to comply
with the law and protect the students
neighbors and strangers alike came out
of their woodwork to speak against
transgender people in general and
sometimes my daughter in particular they
had all the usual claims transgender
people are a threat to bathrooms and
locker rooms to sports they also claim
that my daughter threatened the mental
health of their children and that using
her correct pronouns was in for speech
not surprisingly during this time period
our seven-year-old was relentlessly
bullied at school
with enough digging i found out that the
bullying would never stop because
education around her around her
transition had been blocked the
superintendent had made a rule that the
word transgender could not be used in
the classroom setting when pressed he
wrote me a letter to say that my
daughter's identity was inappropriate to
her second grade class
meanwhile parents we had been to
birthday parties with advertised
meetings in the local paper
get-togethers for those against
transgender rights
my husband and i kept our doors locked
and our curtains drawn
when we had the energy to drag ourselves
up off of the ground we packed our house
we thought we would return west to the
liberal city where we had met but then
our daughter has no civil rights there
she has no civil rights in more than
half the states in this country and it's
getting worse by the minute
before that class my boss had warned me
that though her students were
intelligent and respectful sports was
the one place where transgender rights
was hard for them as many were athletes
themselves
but the students were great just as my
boss had said they would be they asked
me questions most of which were along
the lines of wait what happened
one kind teenage girl asked if my
daughter had any experience with sports
i told her about skiing and roller derby
i told her that it was remarkable to me
to watch how a vital sport how vital a
sport can be to a human and to their
embodiment i was tempted to get in the
weeds as my boss and i had briefly done
before entering the classroom to say
that these bans on trans girls in sports
threatened one of our most vulnerable
groups of children in some states as
young as kindergarten that many of the
girls they attempt to ban have access
gender at affirming care and have bodies
indecipherable from their cisgender
peers that even if they don't the
suggestion that only girls of a certain
size should play is reminiscent of the
dystopian novels i read
that trans athletes have been included
by law in the state of california for
years and there has never once been a
single problem reported that they've
been included in the ncaa for a decade
and in all the legislative hearings last
year lawmakers all across the country
could only ever repeat the same two
athletes over and over again which is a
percentage that is close to zero
but the facts don't seem to matter i've
been to some of these legislative
sessions before first they attempted to
criminalize my daughter's health care
and the second to ban her from playing
sports with all the other girls that is
there's a supposed fear that her body
will be too big or have too much
testosterone to play but then there's
also an effort to outlaw the care that
will spare her that future
taken together i am unclear what i am
supposed to understand as the goal of
course the facts don't matter there will
always be the possibility that a trans
girl will come along in any body at all
and win
in a world of infinite possibilities
either you attempt to block that rare
particular fate by squelching out the
existence of an entire group or you
accept transgender people as a vital
part of the fabric of humanity
thank you
i would happily take your questions
we have questions for ms maxwell
none being here we thank you for your
testimony
i'd like to recognize
he's in support of the bill
okay three minutes mr burley if you
ah thank you dear legislators as a
competitive athlete and the father of
ten and seven-year-old daughters with
their own lofty athletic goals
i urge you to support hb 1180
most people will readily admit that men
possess certain physical characteristics
that give us a distinct advantage in
many sports
biological males are on average bigger
faster and more physically aggressive
than their female counterparts
anyone of sound minds should accept this
as an indisputable fact
don't agree with me let's ask caitlyn
jenner about her opinion on this subject
or maybe ask the female student athletes
who were recently humiliated by two
transgender athletes at the ivy league
i went to the lawrenceville school in
middlebury college where i was a highly
decorated football basketball and
baseball player
to this day i actively compete at a high
level as an amateur skier and platform
tennis player
as an athlete and father i can say
definitively that transgender
individuals have no place
competing in sports against athletes of
the opposite sex
it is patently unfair and disgraceful
that this type of nonsense is permitted
regardless of your sexual identity
anyone born male has no place competing
as a woman in amateur athletics
period and end of story
while i fully support giving trans
athletes the opportunity to compete i
also refuse to stand idly by as we watch
biological men destroy their female
competitors in the name of sport
you have it in your power to put an end
to this insanity and ensure that we
re-level the playing field for all
athletes in new hampshire
i respectfully urge you to vote in favor
of hb 1180 thank you
thank you mr burley any questions for mr
burley
representative pearson thank you mr
chairman mr burley did you hear
as i did
just a few minutes ago
the statement that there's only really
been two transgendered persons stealing
the trophies from females and did you
with me
see
in the last year or two
every couple of weeks
another event another team another place
another name
two is old old news did you see that
with me
any further questions for mr burley
thank you very much sir thank you
i
he opposes the bill and representing the
aclu of new hampshire mr connect
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is frank knack i'm
policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire and we're here in strong
opposition to hb 1180.
as my colleague from glad mentioned
driver's license or amended birth
certificates aren't required in order to
be recognized by the gender that you are
but this bill is going to invite
discrimination and exclusion that will
be in violation of the us constitution
as well as title ix of the civil rights
act i think it was mentioned a little
while ago
some questions about post bostok
and just to clarify two federal appeals
courts in the in the years since bostik
have affirmed that title ix prohibition
on sex discrimination likewise prohibits
discrimination against transgender
students when assessing single-sex
spaces and activities
and i think it's also important to kind
of get rid of some of the myths that we
continue to hear
when we talk about prisons according to
the national center for transgender
equality
trans people incarcerated are 10 times
more likely to face sexual assault by
other incarcerated people and five times
prison staff
that is deeply deeply deeply concerning
in addition
again getting back to the to the debate
over uh quote unquote advantages in
sports
transgender people of all ages have been
participating in sports consistent with
their gender at all levels including the
olympics since 2004.
in all those years there has been
absolutely no categorical dominance by
women and girls who are transgender at
any level
athletic success is based on many
factors that vary from sport to sport
trans athletes like other athletes have
no single body type there is absolutely
no merit to the claim that women and
girls who are transgender automatically
have advantages in sport
in fact
particularly when referring to young
people many trans athletes have
physiological characteristics that are
typical of peers with their gender
identity and not their assigned sex
this means that a girl who is
transgender may have more physiological
characteristics
typical of non-transgender girls than
transgender boys thus any data
purporting to compare the relative
athletic abilities typical of
non-transgender girls
and uh not of non-transgender boys
girls and non-transgender boys simply do
not apply to most transgender youth
i'm happy to take any questions any
questions
i just had a question of the chair was
there written testimony and if so did it
get stopped somewhere uh not we've not
received anything
i will be submitting written testimony
but we were as i think a lot of people a
little confused with what this bill was
trying to do until we heard it explained
and i wanted to reserve the opportunity
to
have the sponsors i just i just wondered
if something had gotten stuck somewhere
but i will definitely be sending thank
you information out with sites to
everything that i just noticed okay
representative gay
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
do you differentiate in any way between
a trans person whose change is done uh
very very young like you know before
first grade
and
like the swimmers that we're talking
about which was done after they
became
uh adult
adult size they weren't adult age yet
but they were late teenagers
from it is not my place to decide who's
what someone considers their gender
identity
uh so that it's not my decision
any further questions
oh follow me representative folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question i was trying to take down
notes um and so i just can you we go
back to
i think i heard you saying that
transgenders are often
uh victims of attacks in prisons yes
okay
um
by
other prisoners as well as staff yes so
this is according to the national center
center for transgender equality uh trans
people are 10 times more likely to face
sexual assault by other incarcerated
people and five times more likely to pay
sexual assault from prison staff
would
follow up
safer
if we had separate but equal units
within a prison
system
so that they were more protected
from
other inmates
who might mean them harm just because
they're trans
or
they could have
guards that were more carefully trained
in being responsive to trans would that
would that make it easier for trans
prisoners
what that would result in is you would
be discriminating against the class of
people from the government's failure to
protect them and so it's the burden is
on the government our prisons and jails
have
endemic violence and i think it's
important that the state correct that
issue
and do so on an individualized basis but
not to have broad category
to categorize entire people and then to
segregate people based on those
characteristics
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
anecdotally i have recently
become familiar with the
inner workings of
federal prisons
and
in the particular prison that i'm
thinking of they actually are allowing
male
biological male
prisoners because it's a it's a
biological male prison
to go to go through
uh surgeries and
and transition into
their identification as a as a female
do you know
in that circumstance are those prisoners
who get
federal funds to change their
orientation are they reassigned
to female prisons after they transition
i it's just a i just was wondering i'm
not familiar with how federal prisons
are
set up at this point but i'd be happy to
look into that and get back to you okay
thank you
for the questions representative pearson
thank you mr chairman mcmahon
you
presented a national level of statistics
and a question has come up in this
committee several times during this
hearing in reference to the state of new
hampshire
do we have circumstances in the state of
new hampshire
specifically to back up the national
in reference to prisons
folks in the corrections field
committing crimes against inmates in new
hampshire those are that's based on the
national survey
i do not have anything specific from new
hampshire
no further questions being seen thank
you very much mr kanek thank you
in support of the bill and representing
herself
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members i want to start by
saying the bottom line is is that we're
talking
this bill is about
biological sexes and it's about
protecting all people so the fact that
it keeps being divided and saying well
we need to protect the transgender how
about we just protect everybody
this bill allows for that this bill says
the state is not going to dictate it
will be dictated at the local level and
if that person's individual rights of
autonomy is violated they have they can
take appropriate action
so that's the bottom line here i am so
tired of so many people working so hard
to divide us it is time to stop that and
i want to personally apologize for the
folks that feel
whether it's
justified or not
that they feel afraid because they're
different the bottom line is we're all
uniquely different if i had lived my
entire life being fearful because i was
under five feet tall where would that
um with regards to suicide for
transgender um
i believe that i believe that it's a
huge problem i also believe it's also a
huge problem for folks who are different
in any way shape or form
we are looking at we need to be looking
at that
the disease
not i'm not saying transgender is
disease but the the the mindset
that i'm different so i need to be
fearful we need to be looking at that we
need to stop saying well you know you
look different so i should be afraid of
you
that's like saying i'm open carrying so
you should be afraid of me new hampshire
prides ourselves on being able to open
carry
and we're here saying because you choose
to
appear different
in the world
i'm going to discriminate against you
it's not fair it's not appropriate
um it's
same thing with color of skin same thing
bottom line is
everything about
this bill is good the problem is is that
everyone's focusing on the transgender
population that's not okay stop focusing
on the division
i love the fact that i that i have
transgender friends who belong to my
females motorcycle group do i identify
them as transgender no i identify them
as lydia and bonnie
and i always will and that's what needs
to start happening and so we need to
start we need to start wrapping our as a
society wrapping our
our arms around all our uniqueness and
all our differences because the bottom
line is there's there's bad actors
everywhere
this bill will help protect
us from bad actors regardless of
how they identify
thank you
thank you miss chester is our questions
for miss chester
and being seen thank you very much for
your testimony
i'd like to recognize uh miss jennifer
smith
who opposes the bill
and representing thank you
mr chair and representatives i
appreciate you taking my testimony
um three sections to this bill
um three minutes is going to be hard i
hope maybe we can cover some of it in
questions there's been a lot of focus on
sports
i did send to all of you this morning a
copy of my testimony against hp 98
because that was in committee
last year was voted
on inexpedient to legislate after a lot
of study by the children and family law
committee
21-0 it went on the consent calendar in
january of this year
had this
bill about sports been brought
it would not have been allowed as a bill
about sports
so i think you can take that off the
table although i would be happy after
all the misinformation i've heard
to address things about the sports
but there is in my testimony to that
committee
a good deal about why
this does not make sense
to have what i would call invidious
discrimination against transgender
females
in this state or any state although it
exists in many other states
the other two sections of this bill well
i think the criminal justice system is
currently dealing with this as best they
can
it's something that worries me and i
know as of a couple of years ago there
were 10
transgender people in
prison they were in a section of the
men's prison trying to be protected
i assume and i hope it's true that
because they had not completed
transition
i completed transition some years ago
i am very much not gender dysphoric
anymore as a female
thank you
i i hope that that kind of thing is
still allowed
and
to get to the the last part it's it's an
absolute mess if you pass this bill that
allows governmental units of any side
school boards whatever
to have their own policies separate from
the state policy
which is enshrined in our
non-discrimination statutes
what happens then we'll have a school
board in one place say
the transgender girl can't use this
locker room
whereas a transgender girl is
participating on the sports team from a
team that's coming there
please
let's be real
and as for what bathroom i am going to
use i'm definitely not going into any
men's room
thank you
and if different communities can say oh
you don't belong in here do i have to
carry a map that's the what community
i'm allowed when i go
somewhere to enjoy myself
please
this bill is nonsense
just get rid of it
i will take any questions i am by the
way i am a medical doctor
i have
when we first brought these bills
around gender discrimination statute
i testified on behalf of the public
health association we've retrenched a
little bit about how many bills we try
to cover so we have not got a position
on this so i am representing myself
but i have a lot of information about
this okay uh then dr smith is there any
questions from the committee
thank you very much dr smith for your
testimony
i'll
bevan walford
is are they still still here
oh excuse me there you are mr seven
representing himself already um
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for your time today i did you
hit them okay yeah just get right up on
the mic if you will yeah mr chairman if
i would ask especially for the folks
that are watching this at home you kind
of they really need to eat the mic in
so good okay
alrighty um as a former athlete and avid
weight lifter i find it unfair for trans
athletes to compete against their
cisgender counterparts for instance a
biological male track athlete
transitioning into a female has a clear
biological advantage in competition
men have a greater capacity for muscle
growth and potential whereas women fall
short
this leads to a huge gap when competing
i support trans athletes but i have but
to have them compete against anyone
other than
those of the same biological sex seems
simply unfair
um
just
it's just i don't know
that'll be it
thank you mr walford and questions for
mr walford
thank you for your testimony sir thank
you
dr uh
recognize
and he's representing the new hampshire
i think this means i'm the closer for
the group um
but members of the health and human
services committee my name is sean locke
i'm here on behalf of the department of
justice i'm an assistant attorney
general and director of the office's
civil rights unit which among other
things
enforces in conjunction with other state
agencies the state anti-discrimination
laws contained in rsa chapter 354a
the department does not take a position
on the underlying policy but is here to
provide some general information
regarding confusion we see arising as a
result of the proposed legislation
during the 2019 legislative session
the legislature included in rsa chapter
354a
protection from discrimination for
students in public schools this includes
protection based upon gender identity
this bill presents confusion in that one
set of laws requires schools to prevent
discrimination based upon gender
identity but the proposed legislation
purports to permit
public entities to limit access based
upon sex versus gender identity
this could expose schools to liability
to come as they try to comply with both
laws or as they if they choose to comply
similarly this could create confusion
regarding how the state as an employer
can best protect employees from
discrimination based upon gender
identity examples came up kind of you
know there's been discussion here about
which bathrooms to use
hiring an individual as an employee this
changes the laws with respect to
driver's license and birth certificates
if those are changed the sex markers or
the gender markers are are changed there
is no way if those are presented as
someone's lawful identification for the
state as an employer to kind of look
beyond that without a series of invasive
personal questions that would lead to
challenge charges of discrimination
based upon a person's gender identity so
it's unclear exactly practically how
this effect really plays out
a second set of issues could arise under
federal law in 2020 as attorney hyatt
described the u.s supreme court issued a
decision in a case called bostick versus
clayton county the case addressed the
question of whether the term sex for the
purposes of title vii which is the
federal
employment discrimination laws
includes gender identity
a sixth to three majority concluded that
title vii does prohibit employers from
discriminating based upon gender
identity
the current administration has
considered this applicable to title ix
as well as multiple circuit courts
across the country have also upheld
challenges based on gender identity
under title ix using relying upon the
decision in bostock
and other anti-discrimination laws the
proposed legislation risks exposing the
state and the political subdivisions to
lawsuits under federal law or brought by
with that i'm happy to take questions
questions for the attorney
done being none being seen thank you
catherine
paterno
close
she's in support of the bill and is
hello and thank you my name is catherine
petternell i'm testifying in support of
house bill 1180 i'm from wolfeboro the
mother of four daughters two of whom
are now ages 19 and 20 but they have
experience with a transgender athlete on
high school sports teams
freshman year my daughter joined the
cross country team she came home and
told me that there was a male to female
transgender athlete on the team
my daughter said it wasn't fair and was
there anything that we could do about it
i told her if you want to make a federal
case out of it
yeah
in retrospect i kind of wish we had
because this is becoming a much larger
societal issue than we ever imagined
to clarify i have nothing but compassion
for someone struggling with gender
identity this child was included at our
home
first any teams events hosted by my
family to my knowledge this child was
never outwardly bullied by any member of
the teams nor did this child ever
exhibit any negative behavior toward any
teammate
what stands out to me is that although
my daughters never felt it was fair that
they had to compete for team positions
with the biological male
they do not feel comfortable speaking
out about this issue
one would think that my 19 year old
division one soccer player would feel
threatened by the possibility of a
biological male becoming part of her
team or having to compete against a
biological male she's about my size
most men
and most women that she plays with tower
over her
when she trains with men she's always
more hesitant to stop their shots than
when she trains with women
as their mother i believe that my
daughters were the recipients of
subversive bullying they knew they could
not speak out about the inequality of
having a biological male on their team
this child's needs were underlying the
essence of the meaning of the team
as the saying goes there is no i in team
in this situation one was found
i believe it was an unfair situation not
only for my daughters but also for the
transgender child
no one should have the focus of the
needs of an athletic team be on that be
based on their own personal needs
thank you
thank you very much do we have questions
none being seen thank you very much for
being here today
i'd like to recognize uh representative
the gentleman opposes the bill yeah
and
i have two minutes
okay yes thank you i'm representative
timothy oregon i represent
stratfor county district six the towns
of durham and madbury so this uh
bills like this come by every year and
going way back to my first term which
was uh seven terms ago and um
i mean the whole concept of biological
male and female is uh
is uh
somewhat is severely misguided since uh
you know
there's a lot more to your gender
identity than uh you know
what type of uh genitals you have or
whether you have an x y chromosome or
whatever and um so you know this is
this is a very um there are some people
who aren't
who uh don't fit in the conventional
categories um
and
in terms of uh
we brought up the uh
the bathrooms which actually restrooms
in the bill you're actually free to use
whichever restroom best fits uh what
your gender expression is and that's i
see no reason to change that loss i
hesitate to even bring up that issue
because you might try to fix that issue
and they'll just create more confusion
so uh
so a person should be able to use either
the men's or the ladies bathroom
depending on uh what they feel most
comfortable with and what the other
people in the bathroom are most
comfortable with um you know it's
it's you know it's illegal to harass or
assault someone in
in a
restroom or any similar place of what
they call intimate privacy regardless of
uh
what gender you're presenting as or what
you know so
there's no need to make more law there
as for athletic competition um
i
i don't think there's been any
case here in new hampshire high school
inspired miss paterno said i don't know
of any case where uh a fema a male to
female uh transsexual has had an unfair
advantage on their uh on their thing i'm
certainly aware that men tend to be
larger than women so i'm certainly aware
of that basic biological fact there's a
lot more than size that comes into it
and um
there was a case
here in new hampshire where a uh a male
to female transsexual won the women's
championship in division one race
championship in one event in
women's track and field and um you know
she
you know she
didn't blow away the field and in fact
if she had entered the olympic trials
that same year she would have uh
finished far behind the last place
finisher so she was uh
what she accomplished was certainly uh
certainly amazing it took a lot of hard
work but she definitely did not blow
away the field and there's um
you know there's a really no
no cases of really you know there are no
cases like that i know somebody i see
one of my colleagues is looking
incredulous but that you know actually
is specific cases none of them have
really you know outclassed a transition
they've all had
what they call cis females who
who can compete on the same level or or
or higher and um also another thing is
misconception there in sporting
competitions those are all private
organizations and there are many
uh public schools that even the uh
even the nhiaa that um that that
regulates
uh
you know scholastic competition that's
actually a private institution that just
happens to have many uh public schools
as members so like you know sporting
competition is almost entirely
is almost entirely a non-governmental
activity we don't really
have we have little of any um
uh jurisdiction over it so can we take
questions oh sure why not yes yeah
whether i can answer them no that's all
that
well we'll stipulate you you might so
uh it's your questions for
representative oregon
none being seen thank you for your
testimony thank you
and our final
card of today is representative leah
cushman
okay
thank you mr chairman
members of the committee so i am a
co-sponsor of this bill and i'm in
support of it um this bill simply
declares that the state has a an
interest in differentiating between male
and female
it allows school districts to have
female and male only team
sports teams if they choose
it allows local control
it allows the department of corrections
to continue considering placement of
inmates on a case-by-case basis
so they can decide the appropriateness
of a placement of an inmate and the
schools could have policies where they
take into account a number of
criteria that helps them decide how long
has the student been
in transition or has
been fully identifying as transgendered
you know
is there any history
that would make it a concern for that
person to be
in a locker room
with biological females it could be done
on a case-by-case basis it doesn't mean
that the school could just you know shut
the door completely on all transgender
females participating in
sports teams
and the same with the department of
corrections they can continue
to do this on a case-by-case basis they
can
it doesn't speak to determining
sex so the schools the the prisons the
jails they already have information on
what the biological sex of a person is
and as far as for sports it's written on
a health form and if a school district
decides to differentiate teams
and someone lies on the form they may be
disqualified then from participating in
to the
topic of intersex individuals it's it's
very rare but of course they are a small
subset of society
they are not covered under this law as i
see it
under this bill
it just doesn't apply if they're not
so they can't really be differentiated
this this bill is about balancing rights
so we're in a really weird
um extreme
pendulum swing right now where
the fighting for rights for the lgbtq
community and fighting for trans rights
is now conflicting with fighting for
um women's rights and there's like i
mean there are videos all over the
internet of the the fight between
the feminists and the transgender
activists
right so it's
it's an odd position to be in but there
are competing rights here
and it's not an attack on transgender
people
it's just an attempt
to balance those rights and and give the
state the ability to differentiate
and then
you know take appropriate action and it
can be done on a case-by-case basis
there's nothing in here that forces
us to extinguish transgender people
okay it's just
allowing the state
that purview
and and the subdivisions of the state
to take a look at these situations
and acknowledge that there are
differences
thank you thank you representative
cushman uh i will not take questions we
have questions what's that nothing i
will not take questions in the interest
of time thank you
no questions
okay that uh
no further comments
i will uh close the hearing on
house bill 1180
uh chairman pearson gives the committee
a five minute break and then we will
come back
to start and i hope finish
thank you charlie oh thank you sir
we did you worked such a good roll i
brother
oh
is
um
research
hearing
wow look at all the trees that died so
um
today's agenda does not list
oh now i can't find it
open the hearing on house bill 1347
relative to licensing requirements for
health care facilities that operate on a
membership-based business model the
chair recognizes representative cushman
the prime sponsor on the condition she
first introduces her guest
thank you mr chairman i have with me
today
my son lou come here
yeah
now what's his name his name is lucious
lucious
are you homeschooled
do you like your teacher yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members
so i'm bringing you hb 1347.
um this bill
speaks to competition
uh
there was some cross over between this
bill and representative mark mclean's
bill i wasn't sure if he was going to
file his bill again this year
uh so i
he did it's hb 1044 and we had a hearing
for that several weeks ago but so i
submitted mine with a twist and
by making it a membership based
exemption from some regulations on
healthcare facilities licensure
um after submitting the bill i learned
that there are some other barriers that
need to be eliminated in order to really
do what i was intending to do with the
bill
and i will address those um
later in my in my introduction of the
bill
competition works and consumers deserve
options employees also deserve options
um
in an article in forbes recently
it was said show me a health care sector
where there is no medicare no blue cross
and no employer and i bet that's a
market that works very well
lasik eye surgery is one example
the surgery center of oklahoma is
another example
it's a low-cost efficient health care
option
delivered in a manner that cuts red tape
and overhead
can benefit people with insurance and
people without for example an acl repair
at the oklahoma surgery center is priced
hundred and
ninety dollars for someone with a high
deductible insurance plan if that cost
doesn't reach the deductible they may
choose to go that route and pay for the
procedure in cash or with funds from
their health savings account if they
have one
this bill comes because insurance is a
racket is a racket
there are limited providers it's a
highly restricted market with little
ability for entrepreneurs to come in and
offer a better product
besides those on medicaid do you know
anyone who loves their insurance
most people i know wonder why they're
paying hundreds of dollars per month for
insurance because they have high
deductibles co-pays restricted places
that it's honored and it has limited
coverage
what insurance does is sell access to
pricing and makes the price the product
care should be the product that allows
for providers to compete by offering the
best care at the best price
right now many providers are limited by
the insurance companies as to what kind
of care they can provide and how much
they can charge for it 15 minutes for a
so our providers often don't even put
their hands on patients anymore
our head to toe assessment is gone
the health insurance industry has
resulted in more compartmentalized
health care more algorithm-based health
care less critical thinking and
innovation by providers and it has not
reduced the costs of health care
the free market medical association
says that by selling access to a
discount or price it is highly
beneficial to the establishment if the
charges are excessive
percentage-based payment models incent
price gouging and pricing games
selling access to a discount where you
benefit from the price being high puts
you at odds with the best interests of
the buyers and sellers of health care
believe it or not i used to be a
democrat a progressive liberal in fact
until i began to have a grasp among
other things of economics and the way
that markets work
the healthcare market in new hampshire
desperately needs competition we need
new options these large health care
organizations have brought up the small
practices have bought up the small
practices
most primary care physicians and
specialists work for large hospital
systems
which operate pretty autocratically
they limit options for treatment
never has the need for alternative
options been more clear than since the
beginning of the covet 19 pandemic
during the pandemic physicians would not
prescribe
any treatments for kova 19 in the
pre-acute stages of the disease because
the hospital systems they worked for
wouldn't let them
now we have a cms vaccine mandate for
health care workers that has resulted in
hundreds of nurses and other health care
professionals
leaving their jobs leaving the field or
moving to states like florida where
they're protected
this bill allows new facilities to be
open that are not subject to the cms
mandate because right now in new
hampshire they all are
there is no place for these health work
health care workers to go if they have a
philosophical or scientific objection to
getting a covet vaccine or if they don't
know how to pass the rigorous test of
um i'll preface the next portion of my
speech to say that i'm open to
amendments this committee does excellent
work
so there's plenty of room to work
together on this
this bill is a little bit different from
hp 1044 by rep
mclean
mine contains contains the same same
byte with a little bit of conflicting
language in the area of statute that
they both amend which was which is rsa
151 2 f
where hb 1044 says direct payment mine
says membership-based business so we
will need to think about that and
possibly amend it
what does the committee think you know
we're legislators we're elected by our
um constituents to make good decisions
so what would be the best way to move
there is some suggested language in the
draft amendment that i passed around
that you should all have
and if anyone doesn't have one let me
know we'll get you one
yeah it
i think it's on the right corner of your
i believe the way that h you're welcome
i believe that the way that hb 1044 is
currently written eliminates sections a
b c and d under rsa 151 2 f
my bill doesn't
seek to repeal those sections it only
allows for an exemption to a and b
so you'll see in the original hb 1347 in
section one paragraph two
it says section one a and b shall not
apply to facilities that operate on a
membership-based business model so this
means that these facilities would not be
inhibited by the requirement to accept
all forms of payment nor be required to
institute an assistance plan for those
without insurance
however they would not be exempt from
providing data to the department or
paying fees for licensure
the third piece of the bill is to permit
these facilities to have an emergency
room that is not open to anyone
regardless of ability to pay and which
is not required to operate 24 7
permitted that they make that abundantly
clear on their signage it's an obvious
burden that conflicts with the intent of
what the bill seeks to do to require
them to take
um
patients that pay for pay for their
services with insurance
this section does not exempt facilities
from emtala requirements under federal
law
which is that they must assess and
stabilize someone if they show up in
need of emergency services while they're
open regardless of payment so in those
dire circumstances if the emergency room
is open and someone comes in bleeding
from a gunshot wound they sustained
while walking through the parking lot
but are not members
or rely on insurance they won't be left
to bleed and die there is still an oath
that physicians take a code of ethics
they operate under
and federal law requires patients be
assessed and stabilized before being
sent elsewhere and again if we need
language to clarify that and to clarify
when the edu is open and when it is not
we can do that
those are the three pieces that i was
seeking to have done with the original
bill however there are two sections in
the draft amendment that i have
that are necessary to free up this in
industry
and i would have included them in the
original bill if i could go back in time
and i knew about these issues they were
brought to my attention by the josiah
bartlett society center for policy and i
did pass out a handout
where they talk about that and i do
agree with that organization sometimes
um
the statutes that govern these
facilities and their licensure are
complex and convoluted so it's hard to
find
where
the regulations need to be pulled off to
open up this market so if you take a
look at the amendment language i passed
out you'll see in section one that it
seeks to exempt these facilities from
the moratorium on the licensing of new
facilities without doing this the bill
really is pretty much meeting
meaningless as how can alternative
options spring up if there's a
moratorium on new facilities licensure
this piece is integral to hp 1044 and hb
1347 in my opinion
next in section 4 of the draft amendment
is language to exempt these facilities
from being prohibited from opening
within a 15 mile radius of a critical
access hospital which i also believe is
necessary for this bill to have its
desired effect of allowing market
competition in the acute and sub-acute
healthcare industry of new hampshire
so really i just want to open this
market up we need to allow alternative
options for health care to
be created and these regulations that
are in place are the remainder of the
certificate of need
board that used to exist in new
hampshire and these were the changes
that
kind of were left as that negotiation
through the legislature
and
they're still having a harmful impact on
our health care system and they just
need to be
they need to be worked out so that we
can open this market up for patients and
employees
will you take questions yes i will
representative canarch
thanks i am just a little bit confused
on the
because you were running through the
draft amendment which seems like you
sort of want to replace the bill with
that much faster than the rest of it the
the and i reviewed the other so question
in terms of the special facilities
within a 15 mile radius where is that in
your um
draft amendment sure that is section
one
um sorry is that it no that's the
moratorium sex section
oh thank you yes
section four
roman reigns oh yeah i'm sorry
okay so follow up please follow up
um i would have to ask you the same
question i asked um
when 1044 was presented
so if we're going to then allow a
standalone
emergency room this present open only on
certain hours not open all the time that
skims off the high paying customers
uh do you have any sense of what the
impact will be on our critical access
hospitals that tend to run on a razor
thin margin of about one percent
and need to rely on a revenue payer mix
that uh helps to reimburse because for
all
hospitals ews are lost their losses they
don't make money on on those
so
any sense of how that
what impact they will be if we have a
birthing center or an ew that opens up
within that radius
and how that might skim off and cause us
to lose our critical access hospitals
and maternity centers and ews
well
if those hospitals can only stay
functioning because they exclude
competition through other business
models
then maybe there's a serious problem
with the models that they operate under
well follow up then
follow up they could post their hours
for the emergency room yes critical
access hospitals don't post hours saying
we're closed between 8 p.m and 8 a.m
they have to be open all the time right
so wouldn't it be if you're going to
have a different business model wouldn't
they have to compete on the same level
no that's the beauty of competition is
you can offer a different product
and that you can offer different
services and you know it'll appeal to
some clients and not to others one more
follow-up and then i'll quit
so what does that gunshot patient do
when they have been shot up in conway
and memorial hospital is closed because
i mean close because they went out of
business because something else moved in
close by
what are they supposed to do just die in
the street this isn't to say that these
hospitals won't be 24 hours but it is a
burden especially for these hospitals
starting out to have to staff 24 hours
it's just a barrier of entry
so if there's a demand for 24-hour
emergency room care then the supply will
adjust to that demand that's how markets
work
the chair has a question for the
representative would you believe and it
is is it your experience
the driving around we see these well
they don't look like big hospitals
they're pop-up emergency room and it
gave you the hours have you seen them
i have urgent cares are a very common
occurrence now in new hampshire and
elsewhere
and
they are often 24-hour
facilities but they're not always
they're not always you're correct second
question is i had a nice chat with my
former vice chair dr marsh former member
of this committee
and he said as a member of the board of
trustees of his hospital he was kind of
worried when one of these
urgent care facilities
was going to open
nearby thinking they would skim off
all the cream and his experience as a
member of the board of his hospital was
they did not do that did i share that
with you before
you did not okay i'll share that with
you sometime thank you representative
merchant
thank you mr chairman looking forward to
that discussion
in regards to uh the question
representative
cushman thank you for taking the
question
my concern is i don't disagree with free
markets i think free markets have
actually been very effective in a lot of
ways and health care unfortunately has
not been
a good example of that however my
concern fundamentally here
is that when you look at this bill it's
almost creating two tiers of health care
one for those who can afford it
and those who can't
and i can share with you in other
countries i've traveled through they
tried something like this and it didn't
work
part of it is because you couldn't have
a way to subsidize those who needed
support financially from those who had
it so how does this prevent us getting
to a situation where we end up with a
two-tier system in this country where
those who have the money and have the
assets and have the wealth get one level
of care and everyone else gets a
different one
thank you for the question
representative
so i reject the premise that this would
create a two-tiered system um
based on the fact that
the idea that um
some people would be able to afford this
and others wouldn't and that it would be
differentiable like i know people who
can barely afford their health insurance
right now
and their deductibles are so high and
their co-pays are so high
it's a terrible
burden for them and it doesn't have much
payout so
this option would be better for them
they're lower income people but they
don't meet um you know the
income limit limit for
medicaid and they may not want state
assistance so they want to pay for their
own and then my second
comment
is that
there's nothing preventing any charities
from assisting with paying for
membership costs there's nothing
preventing
these hospitals from having a sliding
scale or facilities from having a
sliding scale for services we haven't
even talked about what the membership
costs are and honestly
like if you look at the direct primary
care model it ends up being cheaper than
paying for insurance
to to go with a direct primary care
physician
follow up to representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
given the fact that the state of new
hampshire actually has a very healthy
website
for people to go on and find out what
the cost is for a procedure including
cash
therefore people who have high
deductibles can in fact shop around
today
and do exactly what this bill is trying
to do without creating another form of
provider because if the person knows how
to use it and most of my experiences
most patients don't
wouldn't be better off to educate the
people on how to use what we have today
to help them become educated shoppers
when they have high deductibles to keep
their costs down would you know that
well
so
sorry i'm just like trying to
if that was the only thing that the bill
was trying to do was make
cost transparent sure
maybe
um but the bill's trying to
first of all
offer alternative options for businesses
remove barriers of
entry and
encourage competition in healthcare
those are
that's the
meat and potatoes right and then other
benefits will follow that prices
decrease as market competition increases
service
quality increases
value of what you're paying for
increases
okay and then
the other thing is
now we can allow facilities to open up
that do not have to comply
with federal cms regulations
which has had a terribly negative impact
on staffing and moral
distress
in our health care system in new
hampshire and elsewhere
additionally
more
the
paying for the service and the care
helps make it makes sure that the care
is the product right when you're paying
for access to discounts
it incentivizes the base price of health
care services to be higher so that you
can
wiggle and adjust the discounts and make
the market the discounts meaning what
the insurance will pay and reimburse
right and then the consumer it's just
convoluted this is more straightforward
allows the product here's the product
you pay for it
we will be uh putting this hearing into
i hope the correct term is recess
so we'll have recess during the lunch
hour and come back and we've got
questions from different people and a
guest appearance of paula minihan we'll
resume the hearing on what we were doing
before we stopped uh
1347 relative to licensing requirements
for health care facilities that operate
on a membership-based business model
representative cushman has been
presenting her bill
and is in the process of taking
questions the chair recognizes
representative cannon
thank you mr chair
thank you representative
do we have any sort of idea as far as
the
mag
magnitude of the cost that someone would
uh have to put out to join this
members only to join yeah
well for
i i don't know what it would be to join
you know that the market would would
decide that so
you know
a reasonable cost is whatever the
consumer and the provider of a good or
service
agree upon
so
you know that it could be
so what for example direct primary care
practices they charge about 200 a month
some are a little more expensive some
are a little less um the one that i am a
member of they cover
um 12 sick visits a year
and
and that's for a family of five
225 dollars a month for my family of
five 12 six visits for every family
member per year
i know some that are cheaper
and i know some that are more expensive
and
i know multiple that offer sliding scale
so it depends
um but i could see
you know that that's affordable for us
you know and i could see that being
extrapolated in a similar circumstance
where you don't have that
regulatory burden you don't have to meet
the insurance costs which can be up to
you know the administrative costs of
processing insurance claims which can be
35 percent of your total costs to the
business
so it i mean
i foresee that it would be
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman
um
having served on a similar
work group with representative knurk
about critical care hospitals
i
didn't really know anything about them
but i learned a little bit about their
during that work group and
so to go back and to piggyback on his
question about
um if one of these facilities was to
open within 15 miles i'm not sure why 15
arbitrary but um if it was open to open
did make the difference between a
hospital being able to stay in business
or not stay in business and there's no
telling that that would happen but if
that was the case or
if in the case that it had a close down
a labor and delivery
service because those are the
those are we learned that that was one
of the most vulnerable services for
so if a hospital was to close or if the
labor and delivery
would people who lived in that area who
perhaps had medicaid or even private
insurances or was uninsured would they
be able to get their care
at these new facilities
or would they be excluded because
they don't take any kind of insurance
thank you for the question
um so it'll be up to
these entrepreneurs who start a new
business whether
they have the option
you know
by
amending the law as written in the in
the bill in the proposed amendment
it doesn't say that they can't accept
insurance maybe they'll take some of
them it just says they can't take all
payers so but it really depends i mean
if
if there are insured people and they
don't have
an option
to find the care they're looking for
because uh maternity ward closed
um
and i'll come back to that thought too
you know then there's a i'm a need in
the market there's a demand so that's a
place where entrepreneurs step in but
none of this happens overnight like
these
you know business doesn't spring up you
know the next day there's a huge
competitor and
um it's going to take out the hospitals
i mean there there would be some time to
adjust
to the market you know ebbs and flows of
what's going on the operation of the
hospital i think that they would look at
you know maybe
if a hospital was in financial crisis
they would look at what they can do
besides closing wards i believe before
they would look at you know doing that
if that they're the only ones in the
area especially
follow-up follow-up
so um that's good to know that they
wouldn't necessarily exclude taking
insurances it wouldn't be
cash only
so
given that they're a private
business they could they could make the
choice whether to take insurance as well
right
but they would would they be excluded
from having to have a
uh
whatever it's called charity care or
free care policy like hospitals
sorry
thank you for the question i'm sorry for
uh cutting you off that's all right um
they are not excluded from they're not
prohibited from it they're just not
required
but
okay so they're not required like like
hospitals are currently
representative folsom thank you chairman
thank you for taking my question this is
a relatively
and so we don't have statistics on on
this but um is there a somewhat of a
consensus among the people who are
are looking into this option
as to what percentage of patients would
we be drawing away from a traditional
hospital
is this a large percentage of people or
small will you know
thank you for the question
i could
i don't think that there's
any data on it but
as far as direct primary care it's like
a very very very small
number uh a small percentage of the
healthcare consumer market
i don't foresee right now
the way it would work right is right now
most people have commercial insurance or
um
you know they have state insurance
very small number of people don't have
one of one of those
and
this would be a great option for them
and it would be a great option for some
people who have insurance but maybe it's
not a great plan
so they're not having the needs met
through that
um but i don't see it being at least at
first
being a big portion of the population
but if it starts to work
and people see that it's attractive and
that it's a better product and it's a
better way of doing it it could expand
but markets are kind of slow to respond
so it wouldn't again happen overnight
this wouldn't be pulling out the rug
from every comp you know
insurance honoring
and required
health care facility
representative do you think that as a
few of these hospitals get going and
they proved to be popular existing
facilities may think how can we
incorporate some of that
looks like a good idea and it might keep
some of our patients from wandering off
thank you mr chairman
yeah i depending on how we frame this
if we leave it open to them having a
membership
and
thereby being exempt from taking all
payers and if they see that they can not
only accommodate people who
who have
inadequate coverage or no health health
care coverage
but also incorporate some of this model
and accepting um
you know cash payment yeah it could be
broadened thank you representative knurk
thank you very much um if we look back
at the historical issue that for example
prior to medicare the great majority of
older adults were not
covered with insurance because the free
market says it's not worth it to take
care of expensive old people
because you can't afford them
so i'm curious what entrepreneur you're
going to find that somebody opens a
birthing center that's private
membership and it draws the
high-paying customers away
and now that you're left with the
medicaid
patients uh which is actually about 60
of births what entrepreneur in their
right mind is going to open up a
birthing center to deal with that
particular population to make money and
um
can you say can you frame the question
again well you keep talking about the
free market will rise we said what
happened i think representative shapiro
said if you if we pull away people and
this so this they lose the maternity
service out of a hospital you said well
the free market rise to do it
what entrepreneur in their right mind
would rise to try to start a birthing
center to deal with people a group of
people who cannot pay their costs
thank you representative
i i can't foresee what
what ways you know people will come up
with solutions to these problems but i
mean physicians
set out to help people
and groups of physicians often do have
charity
portions of their business
so i i think that the need will be met
regardless of whether it's through
accepting reimbursement from medicare or
medicaid or
you know if they decide to have a
sliding scale
they can these businesses can
accommodate people
follow-up
mike mike i thought you didn't hit it
that's what our hospitals currently do
they do have
take all-comers and they have to
unfortunately
subsidize the places that lose money
like ews and maternities with the other
payers
and so the issue is when you lose those
they already are doing that how are they
going to manage to make that into a
business that actually allows them to
have a profit margin that's in the black
not in the red they're right now running
about one percent margins in our
critical access hospitals
so you're you're asking
about the existing
hospitals not new entrepreneurs starting
new businesses well
if i may respond it could be either one
also again
who's going to be able to suddenly
figure out how to make money on medicaid
reimbursement that doesn't pay their
costs
thank you for the question
i think you're just identifying you know
existing problems with our system it
already is put putting this pressure
you know
on on the health care system to
raise prices on some people to
accommodate for others
you know
it's just a broken system and it needs
we need alternatives
representative cofoult
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
in previous testimony we heard that
federal control
specifically over
represents a barrier to asserting the
right to bodily integrity in our state
in other words healthcare workers in
particular
we can't assert that right to bodily
integrity for them
because federal control so can you speak
a little bit to
the impact that this
legislation would have on
that specifically and if there are other
areas around federal control
of our health care here in new hampshire
can you address those as well thank you
thank you for the question
so
i mean i feel like
cms
is a way
or has been shown to be a way that the
federal government can get its tentacles
into the way that new hampshire does
business right it just reaches out and
it turns a lever and it says you can't
do things this way or
we're gonna you know hold payment over
you or
and this would help alleviate that issue
so it would preserve our state
sovereignty and that we can make our own
rules for our health care facilities and
you know
they don't have to comply with the
federal government may not be you know
sometimes federal government makes
regulations that are not in the best
interests of new hampshire and we need
to be able to have
our own system that works for our state
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
are you aware that
one of the problems that's going on with
maternity care is that medicaid
reimburses for a certain amount of time
within the hospital and given that time
frame when they're no longer paid for
these mothers and babies
they don't have time to waste on a slow
labor they don't have time to waste on
allowing a woman to
birth off the clock and that drives more
expensive interventions that then have a
cascading factor on both outcomes and
costs
and do you think that
in a system uncoupled from that
those handcuffs of reimbursement we
might be able to provide
improved maternity care at a lower price
and that we might be able to have a
chance to do that
thank you for the question yes that
highlights exactly what the intention of
the bill is for
we have these very high health care
costs a lot of it is because of
convoluted regulation
and
price
uh negotiations behind the scenes
that are not transparent to consumers
and if we had
people paying for care
instead of insurance or being taxed and
paying for insurance
you know it would result in lowering
follow-up
thank you mr chairman and listening to
all of these challenges does it seem to
you like it does to me that the real
problem is the way that medicaid and
medicare reimburse
and not anything else
or that those are primary
thank you i i would agree that those are
the pr our primary issues they they
reimburse at a very low rate
and you know it just
skews the entire health care industry
and it
makes this choke hold on it where you
know it it
inhibits innovation it inhibits quality
care
you know something needs to be done it's
broken and we keep saying well
well but here's the problem we can't get
away from it because we depend on it
well maybe we need to stop depending on
it
any other questions representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh i just need a
little guidance as to how this gets
started and then how it would actually
play out being an orthopedic or retired
orthopedic surgeon
someone comes and
has a fractured hip and emergency room
is closed
but they're a member of the hospital
what what happens to that patient
thank you for the question
i'm not sure i i just want to remove the
barrier of entry i don't foresee really
a
hospital having
not having 24-hour emergency room
services
unless
unless they're just starting out and in
that event they say listen
when you start here as a member we're
not open these hours we're just starting
we don't have the staff yet
but
this is the closest emergency room
besides us that's open 24 hours a day
and i'm sorry we won't be here to
accommodate you that it's clearly marked
on our sign but we we offer services at
this time
um
follow-up
in other words i interpret that
correctly
for under the certain there's a whole
host of other circumstances then that
hospital that's getting started would
actually depend
both functionally and financially
on the good graces
of an ancillary facility and ancillary
staff would that be correct
thank you for the question
well it would be starting it wouldn't be
starting in a test tube there are
competing businesses around it that
are going to fill in where they can't um
you know where they can't their services
can't meet the need you know that that's
just one one more i'm just
i understand in other businesses this
people are not
business we're not selling
i don't take care of widgets when you
come to my office
and
what we're
i'm
i understand the market base because in
93 we decided to
deliver our health care in a
market-based system rather than a
government-based system but i guess my
concern is and i
i think i understand you correct and
correct me if i'm wrong is
this would depend on the good graces of
the surrounding
medical structure until this entity that
you're starting gets underway and can be
full full scale is that correct
thank you for the question i just don't
agree with your term good graces
the existing structure exists a new
structure comes in and offers a
different service and people can
take advantage of that but where it
doesn't fill that need they still
rely on what's already there
until
another business or that business can
then fill that
demand
the way markets do
right and the more demand for that thing
that's not being met the more
opportunity for entrepreneurs to come in
seeing no further questions thank you
representative for your testimony the
it says good morning but now it's
afternoon so good afternoon
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations for
the new hampshire hospital association
representing all our state's community
hospitals as well as our specialty
hospitals we are opposed to this bill we
do have concerns that this bill would
impede access to services if a health
care facility is not required to have
charity care policy in place
we also have questions about the intent
of the legislation and what the sponsor
is attempting to address i understand
better now that i've heard it introduced
i have not seen the amendment so i am at
a disadvantage there sounds like it is
much more um
expansive um than what um the original
bill is so that is um that makes me at a
disadvantage unfortunately um
but i you know have been around long
enough to understand um since i ran the
c-o-n um
board for a while
and earlier in my
career so the bill analysis states that
this legislation would exempt
membership-based healthcare facilities
from the adoption of certain policies
relative to access to care and financial
assistance
the bill requires membership-based
hospitals with emergency departments to
prominently post notices that the
facility serves members only
the way we read the bill any health care
facility not just hospitals could
discriminate against individuals that do
not participate in a membership-based
business model
and it is discrimination it's setting up
a bifurcated system that we obviously do
not support our hospitals are driven by
their mission to treat all
regardless
of their ability to pay
this does not do that um we are not
opposed to competition please understand
that that is not what we're opposed to
we're opposed to
having a hospital bifurcate the system
and only take those that can pay this
membership fee
which when you think about what how a
hospital operates they operate 24 7 at a
loss in many many of their departments i
have no idea how you could
calculate a membership fee that could
possibly cover
that
this membership fee on a monthly basis
believe me it's going to be more than
the bill allows for these types of
facilities if they exclusively provide
services to persons who are members of
their business
to not have a charity care policy all
hospital all health care facilities that
currently fall under this statute and
are licensed by the state of new
hampshire provide care to all patients
regardless of their ability to pay
we do not believe it is in the best
interest of the patients seeking care in
these facilities to not be assured that
the facility maintains a charity care
policy we are not aware of a licensed
healthcare facility that only accepts
payments under membership-based business
model i checked and um not this does not
exist throughout the country to my
knowledge further there is no definition
of such a model in the healthcare
facility environment
if this is attempting to expand the
direct primary care model to hospitals
that is a very concerning approach in
our opinion and does not it's not one
that the state of new hampshire should
embrace
how would this work posting a highly
visible notice as stated in the bill
that the facility serves members only
could lead to much confusion and
potentially catastrophic results what if
a patient in the middle of the night
needing emergency care shows up at the
nearest hospital emergency room which
happens to be membership-based facility
will the patient be turned away this
bill if passed could also violate
current licensing laws relative to
emergency departments and to clarify
emtala only applies it was mentioned um
and patala only applies to medicare to
facilities that accept medicare so this
amtala would not apply in this case if
they don't take medicare
nha does not believe this bill is
appropriate and we would ask that you
find this bill in expedient to legislate
and thank you for the opportunity to
provide our comments i think i had a
couple more
um
again
hospitals there are certain departments
emergency rooms are one that lose a lot
of money
ob is another one
and that is why unfortunately a number
of our critical access hospitals are not
able to provide
um obstetrical care um there are
alternative models so i i truly am um
confused um about why why we're um
considering this because there are
midwives they do have independent
birthing centers i think there's one up
north that is um struggling and trying
to get
enhanced reimbursement from medicaid
because they realize that they cannot
really make um the business model does
not work without medicare reimbursement
and we support that
we support hospitals having increased
medicaid reimbursement as well there are
two bills in the senate that actually
address that issue so we um and again
there are other ways i think to go about
this but
having a membership only
hospital is again
foreign to our understanding um have not
seen this anywhere else and i would like
to see the amendment to be able to
comment on that separately but um we um
i'm happy to answer any questions do you
does anyone have any questions from miss
minihan
all right betty gay rep sorry
representative gay
thank you
um
i have a couple of questions and one is
did i understand you properly that we do
have hospitals that are permitted to
exclude medicare
no um no the testimony of the sponsor
indicated that emtala would apply in the
in this case um under the bill and
what i explained was um if you accept
medicare which the i think all hospitals
i mean certainly all in new hampshire i
can't say all for the entire country
there are four thousand of them
but um would um ex i think most of them
do accept medicare um because probably
50 to 60 percent of the revenue
model that hospitals
follow which again is uh they didn't
make it up it's a health care model that
is um has been in existence for a long
time um medicare and medicaid probably
makes up 65 roughly 70 80 for a critical
access hospital
of their revenue so they could not exist
without medicare and medicaid so they
all follow mtala which is if you come to
the emergency room you will be screened
and and um cared for regardless of your
ability to pay representative gay on
follow-up yes thank you
does is it a fair statement to say
that
hospitals
have to make up the shortfall
from their medicaid
patients
by charging
more
you know they pay less so then all the
private pay people whether insurance are
out of their pocket they have to make up
that
no actually the charges are the charges
um everyone is charged the same i think
i um
it's called the charge master i think we
talked about this earlier this session
um which seems like a long time ago
um
but um they all charge the same as what
they're reimbursed is varies
the allowable is what is medically
medically appropriate um so that's
allowable is different and then what
medicare reimburses may be 80 cents on
the allowable dollar medicaid is
probably 50 cents on the allowable
dollar and what pri then they negotiate
with private insurers and then in
non
uninsured people may or may not pay
anything depends if they are unable to
or not
representative acton
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
i've been on the hhs committee for four
years now and and every single time
somebody comes in with with a new idea
of of trying to reform and and
um build a new system and fix some of
the problems those within the current
system who will admit that there's
it's broken
shoot it down so how do we how we can
innovate innovate our way out of the
current situation if we keep hitting a
brick wall every time
we have
new ideas come up
well hopefully not by bankrupting our
hospitals um that have been there
through the entire pandemic to remind
everyone that have treated thousands of
patients um so
when you try to change the system that
is a that is a macro issue um talk about
economics um the supply and demand just
doesn't always work in in health care
and i think anyone that's in health care
understands that right
professor soloway um he taught me well
um so
um that it doesn't always work in health
care unfortunately we are not opposed to
competition what we are opposed to is
again a bifurcated system where are
those that cannot afford a membership
only system going to get care they're
going to go to their community hospital
that is there to serve all but if they
are they don't have any that are paying
for their services they won't be there
they won't and that is why
when con was eliminated back in 2015
why it was decided um in 2018 um with
the um
expert
guidance from senator bradley and many
many in this room actually helped to to
develop the current system that we have
to protect our um our vulnerable most
vulnerable hospitals which are the
critical access hospitals so it is a
really complex issue but remember
medicare is 60 to 70. that is a federal
program 60 to 70 percent of their
revenue for hospitals
is um
is rece they receive medicare
reimbursement so it is a
massive issue
i would argue that
um we can um tweak things around the
edges but this is a
what is being proposed i would say is um
would is um not is not tweaking the
system around the edges it would be
catastrophic potentially
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking questions i know
one of the biggest problems we're facing
today is a shortage of hospital beds and
i'm not sure if you have the new
hampshire specific data but across the
country in the states that expanded
medicaid the number of hospital beds
declined by six percent while other
states increased
if we are resisting other ways to add
new beds through these innovative models
is there a way that you see for
hospitals to increase beds while they're
slowly getting blood dry by the medicaid
so
i would say
that
as far as the inpatient outpatient
pre-pandemic
i would say about 80 percent of critical
access hospitals were seeing patients um
outside of
their inpatient setting they are limited
to 25 beds
and they
the majority of what they provide is
outpatient and
again back to the special health care
services and why they why this committee
back in 2019
18.
passed the special healthcare services
bill is because um they are they allow
for competition because again so much is
done on an outpatient basis it just
needs to be more of a
fair equal
footing because
we want to ensure that those individuals
are that are competing with the
hospitals are providing charity care
because again the hospitals
do take all comers so the hospital
bed
scarcity has not honestly been an issue
until we had staff beds and we have
license beds
we had many more licensed beds in the
state of new hampshire than like then
staff beds for a long time and it wasn't
because of a staff shortage it had to do
with again more and more services are
being um provided on an outpatient basis
so i um again um we're we're still in
the pandemic and and things are are kind
of topsy-turvy right now relative to bed
capacity but um
i again we are not against competition
what we are against is um an un
fair play playing field and a bifurcated
system thank you very much we're only
going to take two more questions now
because we're running terribly late
please try to make the answer briefer
please representative soloway to your
student
thank you mr chairman thank you vice
president minigame it's always a
pleasure
being the third oldest member of this
committee i remember the world before
medicare and medicaid
now it has been alleged in testimony
here that we have an extreme shortage of
healthcare personnel we have a shortage
of beds and the system is broken is it
your opinion that the system is
inexorably broken
the system needs to be um
i mean it's it's just very complex
because the way health care financing
works as you're well aware we have
government payers and we have um
private payers if you will through um
through insurance so it's just a very
very complex system i would say we have
the best quality of care and new
hampshire i think ranks very high um in
the country so um and in the world we
have very very good health care so i'm
very proud of that um the system is um
is complex and certainly um there's you
know
i mean that that's that's a big nut to
crack if you will representative cofoult
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so
um you mentioned that your primary
concern is this sort of bifurcation it's
a two two sets of rules so
i guess i'm curious to know if
if this bill were amended to include an
impala like
provision or requirement
and or
if the bill were to
[Music]
sort of restore the the requirement for
charity care
uh by these membership-based
organizations
would you still be opposing the bill i
would need to see the amendment but
again
i would worry about how the patient is
um impacted um
i truly do not know and maybe um
someone can help me understand how you
could um how you could price this so
that it could be affordable
and then actually work for a
freestanding hospital and to me
some of the the discussion sounded to me
more like urgent care center that
representative pearson was talking about
we have a lot of urgent care centers
that are not open 24 7. open 24 7 is a
different totally different animal
i'm going to stop
thank you
[Laughter]
and thank you for coming i'd say don't
be a stranger but i don't need to say
that you're always with us and thank you
and russian you and i had a discussion
beforehand would you be willing to wave
go
actually i owe you 17 seconds from a
previous visit
thank you committee chair thank you
community members i'm coming today as a
citizen the bottom line is our current
system is broke bottom line we do not
get the services we need if we're
underinsured or uninsured we will go by
billboard after billboard of of
thousands so 36 000 a month is spent on
billboards just from manchester to here
that i see
from our critical care hospitals
36 000
a month
okay when when do you know the third
leading cause of death in this country
medical mistakes and that was prior to
covid
and medical mistakes that's 30 that's
we need a bill like this because we
deserve choice
my debt to you is now over a minute
this closes the hearing on house
bill 13
47 and before we move on uh
representative cushman his prime sponsor
you had indicated you might like to work
with a few people do we have some people
from both sides
who would be willing to work with
okay
saying none
just if you want to if you change your
mind on the way home give her a call
just remember everything has to be in by
i open the hearing on house bill 1487
relative to the procedure for withdrawal
from the vaccine registry
and the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr chairman
i'm andrew prout representing
hillsborough county district 37 the
towns of hudson and pelham
this bill removes the requirement for an
individual's current or previous
healthcare provider to be involved in
the process of withdrawing from
participation in the immunization and
vaccine registry
rsa 141-c
section 20 f
paragraph roman 4
sub-paragraph e requires the department
to maintain procedures for individuals
to withdraw from participation in the
registry and have their information
removed
administrative rule ag-p
307.07 paragraphs a and b established
that this may be done through an
individual's current or previous
healthcare provider respectively
the relevant form requires the signature
of the health care provider in addition
to the signature of the patient or the
parent or guardian
the unanswered question in all this is
what happens if the health care provider
does not wish to sign the form or is
otherwise unavailable
many vaccines are being administered by
pharmacists and other pop-up clinics
situation
is an individual without a primary care
provider supposed to track down the most
recent pharmacists they saw to get the
required counter signature
additionally this roadblock to
accomplishing the withdrawal is also out
of step with the other forms for the
vaccine registry
neither the form to request a copy of
your record from the registry nor the
form to make corrections to a registry
record requires the counter signature of
a healthcare provider
they may both be sent directly to the
registry administrator
despite the forms being developed at the
same time in march 2016 only withdrawal
form is not accepted directly from the
public
this bill seeks to correct that
disparity
thank you for your time and
consideration i'd be happy to answer any
questions
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
so thanks to covid and healthcare worker
shortages my family is without a primary
care doctor
would your bill make it easier for us to
to choose to opt out of that registry it
without having to find a new primary
care provider to do so
thank you for the question um
to clarify this isn't about opting out
of the registry this is about
withdrawing once you're already in it
and yes as written today the law and the
administrative rules that support it
would require you to track down your
most recent primary care provider
if this bill passes it would direct the
department to
make a new form that did not have that
requirement
follow-up um
and i assume there's no exemptions if
the former primary care provider is
deceased
there is
no mention of the law of what to do in
that situation
thank you
any further questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you so much
and the chair calls dr doug phelan from
the new hampshire medical society
who is
indicating he's in opposition to the
bill
thank you chair thank you committee for
having me today doug phelan family
physician in bedford new hampshire
speaking on behalf of the medical
society in opposition of the bill is
written
so here's where where i would sort of
come down on the registry
this is going to consolidate
immunizations into one record that's
going to be easily accessible quickly
available and secure as a resource for
providers of all stripes around the
state
i can tell you numerous times when i was
a resident in concord in my current
attending practice where i have been on
call and an outside medical facility has
paged the on-call provider
to
see if somebody is up to date on their
immunization maybe they were up in the
mountains skiing and they got caught on
a nail and they needed to make sure that
they were up to date on tetanus and the
hospital up there had no way of
verifying that information that's just
one instance and i know it might sound
rare but in all of the different
applications and permutations of when
somebody might need to check on whether
a vaccination is current or not
i have not found it to be exceedingly
rare
the other thing that i would point to
for this the utility of the registry is
regarding pediatric patient transfers as
a family physician i would love if every
patient stayed with their family
physician for years and years and years
on end but people move
and for various reasons change their
primary care providers sometimes those
records lag
and the utility of a central resource
for this is important we don't hold
patients up from coming in to see their
doctor if we haven't received their
records yet and not everybody keeps a
running tally of the immunizations
they've received and what dates upon
which they have received them
especially for children
and so having that type of information
at your fingertips is very useful for
safe medical care
a centralized resource of this
information would would make taking good
informed care of patients easier for
physicians it would be easier for
patients and their parents and would
also be easier for staff if you can
imagine tracking down all of these
records adds to that burden
having this discussion with patients is
important
if a patient declines there is not a
physician i know who would stand in the
way of this this is a primary tenet of
medical ethics this is autonomy
but doctor comes from the latin docere
and this is to teach counseling is a
large portion of what we do
and so that's a discussion that's
critical just like our council on
to be brief a couple more points
health care officials as well as public
health departments seem to eliminate
disparities in care this can be inside
the auspices of an office or a
healthcare system or within a city or
town
having access to this data helps them
target
those efforts rather than broadly
casting a net not knowing what
percentage of people have been
vaccinated to what and in what area
might they be needed
lastly most physicians uh i would say
and
not an expert in this but i would
suspect practitioners of all stripes in
the state have at one point in their
education training trained elsewhere
outside of this state
this is a very common thing outside of
this state it's something that providers
and physicians are used to having access
to we've been used to working with it
in a way to take good care of patients
and so that's why having access to that
being here in new hampshire it has been
different working without one i look
forward to the opportunity of working
with one
thank you
any questions for the doctor
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question doctor
i'm a little confused because this bill
is not a repeal
the vaccine vaccine registry bill this
is to allow
easy withdrawal
of private health information
by a patient or a parent or guardian
just without having to go through
a doctor and get a doctor's permission
to have their privacy
do you understand i do understand thank
you
i believe the testimony that i gave
still in large aspect applies to that
because of the importance of that
conversation with the patient with the
family
about the registry and the details sort
of going back to that importance and
primacy of the provider-patient
relationship and having that discussion
thank you mr chairman and thank you dr
fellow taking my question
we pride ourselves here in new hampshire
being in a state with a lot of tourists
that come into our state we're fortunate
in saying that
as a physician in the er i totally
understand the access to the database
and the importance it plays
however
when you have a patient coming from
massachusetts or maine or some other
state
is there information in that vaccine
registry
not to my knowledge no so what do you do
you do your best
you rely on the information that you
have at hand and you make a decision
informed with the patient is that also
true sorry
follow up that also true for children
who are pity who come here um with their
parents who are mobile
that again if they're all the vaccines
are in another state registry that's not
going to be in our state registry either
that's correct the state registries
would be separate thank you for the
clarification
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
so
once once a patient has a discussion
in regards to the registry
and then they have the information
necessary to make an informed decision
don't they have the
right shouldn't they have the right to
decide i mean
it would it would make sense to me that
if a person
if that's a person's right
you seem to want to
sort of squelch that and i want to know
why
the last part through me
i'm sorry the uh making a decision
making an informed decision is
pro-choice and and having the
information from
you let's say in regards to the registry
should allow
your patient to have that
decision-making right
i would say in this instance
the the effect of even this conversation
of the introduction of this bill of the
discussion and deliberation of this bill
is a sign that this issue is complex
this takes conversation and deliberation
i come from
a long history and school of medical
thought that the relationship between a
provider and their patient in my case a
physician and the patient
um is is
the premises is of the top preserving
that relationship
i want to continue to have that
relationship and discuss with patients
it's not a matter of standing between as
a barrier it's a matter of having an
informed conversation
follow-up
and then after having that discussion
don't you believe that your patient has
the right to decide whether or not they
want to
go ahead with whatever procedure or or
in this particular case withdrawing from
the registry don't they have that right
yes and we would do that right there on
the spot if that was their wish thank
you
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here to answer questions
especially as a family practice doctor
um i have a question and a follow-up how
long would that counseling about
withdrawing from the vaccine registry
take do you think
estimates it could be as short as a
minute and it could be as long as 10
minutes
estimating
then as a follow-up would you suggest
scheduling an entirely separate
appointment in order to make sure that
it has enough time and it doesn't take
away from other care in another
appointment
there's a lot of
complexity to that i try to save my
patients visits wherever possible and
try being cognizant that people are
working taking time off to come in for a
medical visit so i would try to
incorporate it into a visit
but it would understandably have enough
complexity to stand on its own
what's the billing code
[Laughter]
i have to ask you
oh boy that was not one i was
anticipating
i'm pretty sure there's a code in there
for counseling on preventive care i
believe there is
i supervise our billing person so there
it is uh did i see representative
soloway yes and then connect sorry uh
thank you mr chairman uh and uh thank
you dr phelan for taking my question uh
just a quick question we have we're
having a lot of discussion in this
committee about opt-in opt-out
on
immunization
databases generally
and
can you draw for us the distinction
between
a public health database
and a clinical database centered on
patients
it's a hard
in terms of the use the practical use
in terms of public health sort of i kind
of glancingly referenced it at the end
but it's in
the interest of public health
departments of public health at large
of which we often end up blurring the
lines in primary care but
to
be able to look at a population and see
what level of vaccination is here for
this if there is an outbreak of a
communicable disease if there is a if
there are resources that are available
to increase vaccination rates to know an
accurate percentage so that's on a
population level on a clinical care
based level that's more like what i was
referring to as far as that er
pages me and says i have patient smith
here
uh can you tell me about their
vaccination status
representative canuck
thank you very much so just to clarify
because we were talking about that if
the patient still wishes to withdraw you
of course would sign it
so would you agree that the signature is
really basically the documentation
of the informed consent discussion just
as we would do if we do any other
informed consent discussion like for
surgery we have a signature that
documents we had that discussion and
that that might also be helpful in terms
of any liability issues for example if
the provider
were not aware that the person withdrawn
and they released information they might
be held liable because they weren't even
aware that the patient withdrawn or
let's leave it at that so would you
agree that it's important to be able to
number one document the discussion and
to that that might help with liability
issues as well for the provider i would
betty uh i'm i really am sorry
representative that is my name it's okay
okay okay thank you very much thank you
do you admit that it could for people
who
realized they could opt out after they
had the vaccination do you agree that it
would be extremely difficult if you no
longer had that provider
i think there would be a level of
difficulty obviously like i said
providers move providers retire um
but i think leaving the freedom for
that discussion to be with a provider
still stands and there are
representative
weber
thank you mr chairman
so i guess i'm a little confused and
maybe it's a follow-up to a question i
heard earlier
um
if somebody got their
covet vaccine
facility that isn't there anymore
and they don't currently have a primary
care provider
how do and they want to get that
information taken out of the registry
for whatever their reasons are
how do they do that
that's a very good question i would
reference the importance and i would
sort of share from representative knicks
comments that there's an importance to
the discussion that is to be had so if
there's not a primary care physician
involved if that patient that
theoretical patient
got a cut and needed an antibiotic who
would they see
they might go to an urgent care they
might find a new primary care
physician or provider
that discussion could be had with a
licensed medical practitioner within the
state
representative folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question
um if someone does not have a primary
care because of the similar situation
and they call up a primary care office
they're going to have to make an
appointment if they don't have insurance
they're probably out a minimum of a
hundred and forty dollars just to get
that doctor's signature
would that be an appropriate way to
handle that
i think again sort of relying on the
importance of that discussion in the
same way that if that patient needed an
antibiotic because they were getting
cellulitis from a cut the importance of
having that shared communication with a
medical provider
is
similar in this case
so i would
sort of dispute some of the cost i think
there's ways around that
and in obtaining affordable medical care
or crisis medical care
but
the sort of underlying premise of that
relationship between a patient and a
provider i think stance
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um does it have to be
a new hampshire provider what if i got a
vaccination and then i've since moved
out of state and then i i don't want my
information to be in the database
anymore how would i go about
getting my information removed
that's a good question
not
sort of handling the administration of
dhhs myself maybe they have a way for
navigating that i think in my
recollection of the language right now
from the top of my head
getting in contact with the old provider
from new hampshire who
theoretically if that person that you
left and went out of state for also had
not retired
or if there was a covering provider in
the office to have that discussion with
i think that might be one option but
i would defer that question to the
thank you mr chairman also thank you dr
phelan for taking the question
in regards to
what i'm trying to understand is
the role of a patient in their care
versus the role of the physician
and i'm sort of getting confused here
because it sounds like everything the
patient should do for healthcare should
go through the provider
i don't think that's what we're hearing
at least i think that's what we're
hearing because there's a lot of times
in which a patient
should take control over their
healthcare themselves directly
otherwise really bog down the system
because right now my understanding is we
don't have enough healthcare providers
as it is and the time is extremely
valuable
so i'm trying to wrestle with the issue
of
patient-centered care that they control
themselves versus something which
requires the medical professional to
help them and i'm not sure with a
vaccine withdrawal qualifies at that
level can you help me understand that
please
sure
so
i think for a lot of the instances which
uh we've sort of alluded to through some
of the sort of questions and answers
here that i've given there are many
different circumstances where having
access to that database is helpful for
medical care
i think that is in an acute sense i
think that is in a preventive sense i
think that is for adult medicine i think
that's for pediatric medicine
because of the breadth and scope of this
because of the potential impact of
opting out
personally as a family physician i would
spend the time on that i think the time
on that is important i think that's
up for consideration here
but uh from a medical standpoint and
from a primary care standpoint those
conversations are amongst the most
doctor thank you so much i know you
gotta run i'm glad you stayed and
offered your perspectives thank you much
the chair calls abby rogers and anne
afternoon chairman peterson and members
of the committee my name is abby rogers
i'm the legislative liaison for the
division of public health services
i'm here with anne-marie mccurry uh
section chief for immunization and we
good afternoon chairman pearson and
members of committee i'm ian marie
mccurry i'm the immunization section
chief for the department of health and
human services
thank you very much for allowing us to
speak today
just as a little bit of a recap
immunization the iis immunization
information systems are the confidential
secure population
based systems
that record critical immunizations they
have many benefits
by preventing the administration of
duplicate immunizations
increasing the immunization rates
consolidating immunization records and
ensuring
accountability of publicly purchased
vaccines
as we had discussed on prior testimony
only providers who administer the
publicly funded vaccine are required to
report to the immunization
registry in new hampshire all other
vaccine providers are encouraged to
voluntarily participate so not every
immunization is recorded into the new
hampshire immunization information
system
additionally no individual is required
to participate in the immunization
registry they may have the option to opt
out meaning that no information is sent
to the ias by their vaccinating provider
and they may also withdraw their
information from the ies which is the
discussion for today meaning that they
can remove their existing information
from the system
the department is on in opposition to hb
1487 because it removes the health
repair provider from decisions that can
impact future health care and does not
inform the individual making the request
of the implications of withdrawing their
information
we also need to note that the
immunization registry was developed in
mind for childhood immunization the
pandemic coveted vaccination was a very
unusual event
so there's a lot of information that
should be considered under that
and having this
bill go forward would be dangerous
especially for those providers
especially caring for children
it is important to involve those
providers in the process to withdraw
from the registry
the um
people who are choosing to withdraw also
should know that they would be
responsible for maintaining their
immunization record the their iis
information would delete all
immunization information when they do
submit a withdrawal form this would be
problematic for individuals who are not
able to retrieve their vaccination
record from providers who previously
administered their vaccine
while hb 1487 aims to unburden those who
choose not to participate in the
registry does place the onus of
communication on the individual the
individual would need to inform their
primary care provider of their decision
to withdraw as the providers would not
have any knowledge about this decision
and if they had they would have also had
the individual signed an opt-out form to
prevent future information from being
sent to the iis
in the event that the patient fails to
communicate their choice to withdraw
and subsequently opt out the provider
would then become liable if records are
sent in the future
the removal of the provider's signature
from the withdrawal form also
eliminates the only mechanism that is
currently in place to validate the
identity of the person requesting the
deletion of iis records the department
is at risk of being liable for deleting
information in the event of fraudulent
requests to do so
while the requirement for the health
care provider signature on the
withdrawal form is an extra step for
individuals this step provides important
protections for the health care provider
and the department this step promotes
informed decision making improved
communication and provides protection
against fraudulent requests
thank you very much i'll be happy to
answer any questions any questions for
the members of the department the chair
thank you mr chairman
i don't think we want to discuss
political titles right now he's been
like a son to me all these years
i guess it would be proper to thank the
chairman for his um
his recognition his genetics and his
tuition money
with that being said
you mentioned an
opt-out form
that's involved where is that opt-out
form
record
kept
once once a person files that opt-out
form where is that record kept and
maintained
the opt out form is kept with the
provider so that way the providers the
opt-out form is completed by the
provider with the patient
and the opt-out form is what keeps the
information from coming to
the iis
upon the time of vaccination so that is
something that is done in the office
when somebody is receiving vaccination
the provider is the person that keeps
that record on file
and that's the mechanism that prevents
the information from flowing to the iis
follow-up thank you so
if your provider is
keeping this form and the state is not
attaching this record to
any sort of database that this
particular
resident is in an opt-out status
if as we saw with the i mean i assisted
the national guard with the rollout in
hooksett okay um as a fire service
liaison
so if a person was to go to an urgent
care or in this case
a vaccination
location or such as that and didn't go
through their primary care
that record would therefore then be
useless correct
the opt-out form would be useless
i think it's also important to
distinguish the difference between the
opt-out form and the withdrawal form
so this bill is related to the
withdrawal form the opt-out form would
be that the information would have have
not ever been sent to the department so
therefore a you know it's that's kept at
the provider level in the withdrawal
form is what is in question here under
the spill
one more if you if i could one more okay
so then
this does apply here in the sense that
if i opted out
with that procedure which is not
discussed here and then i went to a
different location they have now put me
into a database that i didn't want to go
in because they don't have my opt-out
form
and it may have been something that
slipped my mind and i do now have to
have a way to withdraw
because i never intended to be in it in
the first place
thank you for the question the opt out
form would be completed by any
vaccination provider
so if you went to a different provider
for a different vaccination that opt-out
would happen in advance
so the withdrawal form
would not apply because that information
would not be at the state yeah that's
not how that this all rolled out
with the military just so you know
and during the emergency order 76 the
any further questions representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so it sounds like uh
getting to the point of all of this is
that people deserve the right to opt out
they deserve the right to withdraw okay
right now it's very burdensome
you have to go through every
um you have to put an opt-in out form
with every provider that you've gone to
that has vaccination records
and you need to
withdraw through every provider who has
your vaccination records is that correct
thank you for your question the
withdrawal form would only happen once
with the um that because that would be
coming directly to the state to remove
any existing record
follow
follow up
okay so if one with drew then your
records are taken out
and then if you went to another doctor
and you
like and you didn't go back to that one
anymore and you went to another one
and that doctor
gave you a vaccination and sent or or
counseled you on vaccination and sent
that information
to the
registry
right
you did withdraw but you only withdrew
the historical data up to that point and
then if you didn't do an opt-out they
wouldn't be violating anything by
sending your information because you
didn't opt out is that correct
thank you very much for your question
that is correct and that's why we feel
as though the providers should be
involved in this decision so that the
patients can be thoroughly informed and
and that there's a mechanism for
communicating
the the process to ensure that there's
no problem one more information being
sent thank you mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question
are
physicians and medical providers the
only source of information on the
vaccine registry or can people find out
the information on it on its purpose on
how to withdraw and how to opt out
elsewhere
thank you very much for your question
that information about how to
is on the website and the testimony has
the links for those
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
so if this bill were to pass
and
somebody else sent in with knowing my
inability to remember these things
myself and my desire to remain in a
registry if somebody was particularly
annoyed at me and sent in a
request to withdraw
with my signature on it that wasn't
signed by me
is there any way that anybody at the
registry would know that that wasn't me
and would
and and
so
or
is there any way they would know it
wasn't me so that they could
follow up with what was going on
thank you very much for your question
this bill if enacted would remove the
way the only mechanism that the registry
would have the information about if it
was a valid request to withdraw or not
and that would be accurate that anyone
who had a person's name and date of
birth could go ahead and make these
fraudulent requests and that would be a
merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question i want to follow up
on a question representative cushman
raised
when the request to withdraw is made
the subsequent additions can be made
there's no permanent blocking of any
additional information coming to that
registry that correct this point in time
that is correct under current law
the administrative rules we are not
allowed to keep that record of the
withdrawal to request so it is a
one-time event we look to see the
request we remove the record and then
even that request to re withdraw is
eliminated
representative gay
thank you mr chair yeah i was really
fascinated about the withdrawal form
which goes straight to y'all
as opposed to
uh one at a time
um
the other form the the
opt-out form
sorry
it seems
is there any way there's no
is there any notification when you get a
withdrawal
to send it back to the person who
requested it so that you don't
allow somebody fraudulently to withdraw
somebody
thank you for your question there is no
any further questions on the folks from
dhhs
thanks for comings
chair recognizes we're now in the three
minutes
zone
so the chair recognizes laura condon
from bedford who speaks in support of
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is laura
conde and i'm from bedford
um i do want to mention up front that i
dhhs persists in mentioning the iis
which is the immunization information
system that is not the state vaccination
registry the iis is initiative and
program of the federal government that
has not been adopted in state statute
and um dhhs has been given no authority
to operate in iis there is only
statutory authority for vaccination
registry
it is important that the individual have
the right to withdraw from the state
vaccination registry without the
requirement of a doctor's permission and
signature doctors should not be the
gatekeepers on individual privacy rights
in fact as you've heard the doctor must
be a participant in the registry to
withdraw you from it um and would you
believe that my my current doctor is not
a participant in the registry and would
you also believe that refusal of a
vaccination is a registry event so if i
were to refuse a vaccination i could be
put into that registry and would not
have the opportunity to
withdraw
um
and and i here to mention here that they
they walk withdrawal and it was a good
point made by representative connerk
that the withdrawal signature is evident
in documentation of the conversation in
fact i would say that was a good point
and it certainly argues exactly why
patient documentation should be required
in the first place is an opt-in to this
registry that will provide that valuable
documentation that i think needs to be
had both ways going in and coming out
so i urge the committee to support this
bill thank you and i'd be happy to take
any questions thank you very much are
there any questions miss condon
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
uh miss conan
would you agree
the current method of withdrawing one's
private health information from the
vaccine registry to be an unfair burden
on those who are financially
disadvantaged because it requires them
to go and see their doctor and pay for a
visit
and that
that could be
thought of as a constitutional violation
of article 2b thank you for the question
representative cushman you make a very
good point that in fact um in order to
get the way this is currently stands in
order to get out of the registry a
patient actually would have to book
appointment with their doctor's valuable
time that should be spent on caring for
sick people simply to get a signature to
opt out of this registry so and and
again they could immediately get swept
back in and they'd have to go to each
and every vaccinating provider to make
sure they get um get taken out in fact
they
choose not to participate even requires
a signature of the vaccinating
vaccinating provider and hannaford
doesn't even provide the opportunity to
opt out
huge burdens on individuals thank you
representative folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question i just want to clarify
something you said um
you referred to the refusal of a vaccine
as a
vaccine event
[Music]
would that then
automatically go into the system because
you didn't bother filling in opt-out
because you didn't think that
it went anywhere but they could still
you you refused i know you can't hear my
head nodding but thank you very much for
the question representative folsom that
is exactly um correct the statute never
intended that uh vaccination refusal
would be a vaccination event but in fact
in the the vaccination registry rules
written by dhhs um refusal vaccination
is defined as a vaccination event and
recordable in the registry so write it
if if you go to a doctor and they say
you know would you like a flu shot you
say no thanks i'm all set
you don't realize that you've triggered
being put into the registry
it's not even intuitive thank you any
further questions
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions
uh you mentioned that requires a visit
to the doctor's office if you just want
to get out of the registry do you have
some data of how many physician offices
require that
um
it's not the physician office that
requires its required on the form
thank you for the question
no my i'll maybe follow follow up i
guess i'm trying to because i was left
with the impression that to get out of
the registry you'd have to go to the
doctor's office
for a visit and i'm trying to get some
idea how many doctor's office require
you
to come to the doctor's office if you
want them to sign you out of the
registry
thank you very much for the question i'm
trying to clarify my answer for you the
form in fact requires the doctor's
signature i don't know how else you'll
get that doctor's signature without
presenting to the doctor with this form
for the doctor to
impose a signature on and in fact we've
heard from prior testimony here that
there there are doctors certainly we
know that believe that of the doctor's
visit should be required
but i don't have an a number if that's
what you're looking for representative
woods uh thank you for thought would you
believe that offices and i know a lot of
offices that do not require that
so i was worrying i'm curious about the
number
uh that sort of get a balance because
we're here on both sides and i needed
some data thank you
thank you for the question i mean i
don't know how a signature could be
attained without physically presenting
this form but thank you
send it to the
i guess this is a would you believe
back when my children were young
and had a physical within the year when
they needed the camp form signed
you know in order to go to girl scout
camp boy scout camp i
dropped the form off at the doctor's
no appointment because they had had
their physical within the year and it
was signed would you believe that could
be a possibility in this instance
thank you very much for the question so
it certainly does seem plausible that a
form could be dropped off
which of course would require the
patient to take time off of work during
doctor's hours to drop off a form and
then if the doctor's not available to
sign it perhaps on a second day take
more time off of work to go up and
retrieve the form so thank you very much
do you want to follow up
okay
thank you thank you very much miss
condon and chair recognizes now paula
minihan
i told you not to be a stranger and here
she is again
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations
with the new hampshire hospital
association representing all our
hospitals we are opposed to house bill
as stated the bill would before you
would remove the requirement outlined in
rules that a health care provider
signature shall
not be required for withdrawal from the
immunization registry
and we believe that removing the
provider signature requirement would be
very problematic
as outlined in the immunization registry
administrative rules the provider is
responsible for submitting that
information to the department when an
individual elects and i apologize i was
using opt-out but it's really
withdrawing so i apologize for that um
the process is very straightforward and
the form is quite simple i did provide a
link but again that's for the opt out
form but the withdrawal form is very
similar i was just
moving a little too quickly when i was
doing this sorry um and
i did notice in the preamble of the bill
it talks about it being difficult to
find to track down former transient
providers for the purpose of signing the
form and then further on in the
preamble
it then talks about
removal from the new hampshire registry
requires a signature from current or
former health care provider so the fact
is the patient or guardian in the case
of a minor does not need to track down
the former transient provider to get the
form signed
um so we we believe as you know from
prior testimony we believe in the
registry we believe in
opting out and we believe that you know
we should fix the current system if it's
problematic
but eliminating that signature um by the
provider we we believe is is
a bridge too far and we can't support
that happy to answer any questions any
for
he's having trouble with your last name
no i'm having trouble with the mic
thanks for picking a fight
[Laughter]
it's already dangerous enough for the
two of us to be in this room together i
don't know that you really want to do
that
the
do i have the ability right now
to
see
what my registration file looks like the
content what's in it do i how do i go
about doing that i want to see what my
registration file looks like how do i do
it i am not an expert on that i think
the department could better answer that
any further questions for miss minihan
thank you thank you
the chair now calls kate fry from new
futures
thank you good afternoon members of the
committee my name is kate frye i'm the
vice president of advocacy at new
futures i will be very brief since
you've had a whole lot of testimony in
this area
we are also opposed to house bill 1487
regarding the
procedures to withdraw
we support policies
that support the health and wellness of
individuals and supports the public
health policy that decrease illness and
disease including vaccines and programs
like the registry that ensure equitable
and efficient broad distribution of
vaccines you've heard
the importance of the vaccine
or of the registry
excuse me but also the importance of it
to
individuals into families to keep track
of that information as well too it's
confidential there are varying ways to
there is a way to opt out confidentially
as well
um so they provide many benefits as you
know we were one of the last two in
state it um this is just one more
attempt to con to weaken the
immunization registry um and we feel
very important to note that it's fewer
than five percent of vaccine recipients
have chosen to opt out and most
recipients value the importance of the
registry so we just um urge you to um
uh vote and explain it to legislate on
seeing none thank you so much and this
ends the hearing on house bill
and
this opens the house bill
hearing
same co-sponsors
and same primary sponsor
expanding the prohibition against
discrimination based on an individual's
election not to participate in the state
vaccine regulary
registry prime sponsor representative
prout
thank you mr chairman
i'm andrew prout representing
hillsborough county district 37 the
towns of hudson and pelham
this bill enhances the existing
non-discrimination section related to
the immization vaccine registry
currently rsa 141-c section 20 f
roman x requires that and i quote no
health care provider shall discriminate
in any way against a person solely
because
that person elects not to participate in
the immunization registry
however paragraph
roman 4 permits a larger list of
entities access to the registry database
including non-healthcare entities such
as schools and privately owned child
care agencies
these entities could use their access to
the database to gain knowledge of who is
opted out of the database
and are free to discriminate on that
basis under current law
these entities may be financially
incentivized to do just that
a daycare may decide it's easier to
require all children to participate in
the registry rather than hound parents
for up-to-date health records
i must unfortunately admit i've been on
the staff time previously spent
following up with parents would be
realized as a cost savings for that
child care agency
we have enshrined in our law right to
opt out of the registry however this
right is meaningless if coercive
pressure not to use that opt-out
provision
is allowed to be put on individuals and
families
i asked you find this bill ought to pass
ensure the state granted right of
registry access is never allowed to be
used for discrimination
thank you for your time consideration be
happy to answer any questions any
representative nutteruppum had your hand
up first
thank you chairman and thank you for
how are people discriminated against
by opting you mentioned daycare
do you have other examples i'm a little
confused by
how you were
discriminated against by opting out of
something
thank you for the question
um
i mentioned daycare is one of the
concerns of i mean it's
difficult to say all the ways this might
happen uh the the vaccine immunization
registry is just getting booted up now
it's been theorized for a long time just
happening and i want to get ahead of
that and i noticed in the law it says
that health care providers are not
allowed to discriminate
but there's more than just health care
providers allowed access to the registry
and that just didn't make sense to me
that implicitly in the distinction being
drawn there
were saying that other people could
discriminate and i gave the example of
daycare providers possibly similar for
schools
they may want to you know say that
everyone all the students in their
school must participate in the registry
either to make it administratively
easier or because of
that
that's the belief they want to carry
forward
uh follow-up
follow-up
i think children in school are already
have to have their immunizations to
attend school for the moment
um
thank you for the question okay sorry um
uh yes that is true but they don't have
to their parent they and their parents
don't have to allow the state registry
to maintain those records they can
provide those records directly from
their provider to the school
instead of using the state registry as
the method of transmission
okay thank you
you may have already partially answered
this but my question was
wouldn't it be within the purview of a
private daycare provider
to
make whatever
regulations they
preferred for their daycare business and
parents get to either come and accept
their
regulations or
find a different daycare provider isn't
that an individual choice
and individual freedom of choice on
the part of the business owner
with respect to a private day care
provider not all these other things
thank you for the question um
i think the important factor here is
that even a private day care provider or
private school for that matter
would only be able to enforce that and
actually know if someone participated in
the state operated database
because of the special access given to
them by the state in our rsa to have
direct access to that database
so
what you said applies to many
circumstances but when the state is a
party to
the issue at hand
i think we have to look at what state
law authorizes and what it regulates
regarding that privately owned schools
use of their state granted access to a
merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question
what i'm trying this is following up on
representative webber's question
are we going down slippery slope or
telling the business how to run their
business
because at that point in time
if they decide to have vaccinations part
of the reason for their business and
it's a business decision they make which
we want to respect in the state are we
not somehow starting to infringe upon
their independence as a business person
to make that decision
thank you for the question and
i guess i'll start with the
clarification that this wouldn't change
what vaccinations would be required
and also this section law doesn't
address whether a
privately owned daycare or school can
exceed those state requirements that's
not the topic at hand
this is only whether those schools can
use their
special access to a state database
to require you to enroll in a state
program which is the vaccine registry
and it doesn't address the topic whether
all children have to be vaccinated to
attend school or daycare it doesn't
address the topic whether a particular
school or daycare could exceed the state
so basically
way i understand this
it's going to be incumbent upon the
parent or the individual to provide that
data if it's not in the database to the
individual that wants to have it in
other words if i went to a private
school the school wanted to have my
database for vaccination which is
required if it's not in the database i
therefore have to just have to provide
it to them is that what i'm hearing
thank you for the question yes it would
be they would have to provide what is
currently done in many places which is
your current health care provider
selling a health form which includes all
the information on
the the child's vaccination records in
this example um and that would
and the school would i assume you have
to accept that they just cannot say the
only way we accept the information is
i'm waving off because i had the same
exact question any other questions for
you seeing none thank you representative
thank you the chair calls on abby rogers
and anne marie mccurry who put on their
pink card they're here to provide
information
thank you representative pearson and
members of the committee abby rogers and
legislative liaison for the division of
services good afternoon chairman pearson
and members of the committee for the
record my name is anne marie mccurry i'm
the immunization section chief for the
department
the department is here to provide
information
on this bill
since uh no individual is required
to participate in the iis
and also that hb 1488 does not remove a
patient or parent of a minor
patient from his or her obligation to
comply with any immunization vaccination
requirement or infection control measure
set forth including rsa 141 c
20 a
immunization or
administrative rule hep
301.14 the department feels that it's
reasonable to amend this rsa to include
all other entities identified in
thank you any questions
any bits of information you really want
to know and we have the people to tell
you
thank you so much
thank you very much representative
pearson my name is laura condon i'm from
bedford new hampshire and i support this
bill
this bill is important because the
registry does not restrict access by
daycares and schools and doctors to
current clients students patients or
customers
without this bill those not in the
registry or those who may have
declined one or more vaccines remember
you can be swept in if you've declined
vaccines to be spied on and
discriminated against
for in particular day day private day
care services so it could be used as a
screening mechanism to
deny services
and no one should be allowed to
discriminate based on an individual's
privacy right decisions now it's been
raised here the question well in a
daycare does a parent have to provide
information about vaccination yes indeed
state law requires certain vaccines for
children entering daycares public or
private a parent must provide that
information or a medical or a religious
exemption so there's not necessarily a
vaccination record um
and you know absent you know if a parent
submits a religious exemption then based
on those religious beliefs a prospective
daycare provider could spy on that
parent to see you know if their child is
in the registry um so again i believe
this is um
a needed amendment to current law and i
appreciate the support on this bill and
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you
you weren't ready for me to end that
quickly were you
yeah i have the habit of going a little
longer trying to be quick
i owe you a minute and four seconds
thank you you're welcome i keep track
the chair recognizes jennifer smith from
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for taking my testimony
i apologize again for not being able to
state that i am representing the public
health association
because we're a little bit disorganized
this year and there's just way too many
bills to keep track of and we didn't
keep track of this one i'm afraid
but i think we would be opposed
i am opposed and i want to talk about
this section is about communicable
disease and sometimes i think people
lose sight of what that means
as a physician with a fair amount of
expertise and communicable disease this
alarms me
to read shall not well no health care or
provider any other entity identified
shall discriminate in any way
and that really gets problematic with
some of the communicable diseases
yeah i i actually ask a former health
care provider i retired some time ago
and i could have answered some of the
questions about primary care that were
up before
but you know your committee hearings
aren't going too long and i i do think
that this has some real problems to do
this and
the problems have been somewhat
identified
that
people need to be able to know if they
are running
these other entities
that they can assure
their
clients
that in point of fact
they are doing everything they can to
prevent
serious communicable diseases going home
with their child if it's a school or a
daycare center
and there are communicable diseases that
resurge quite regularly
when too many
kids
or adults
end up there
with no vaccination
two in particular worry me a lot one is
whooping cough
whooping cough can kill infants who have
not yet been able to be vaccinated
and whooping cough recurs regularly when
people aren't vaccinated
and i could go into great detail about
why that is just a reminder that we're
in the three minutes zone here all right
so i could go into great detail but i
won't the other one that worries me a
lot is something that very few people
really pay attention to and that is
rubella
known to some people as german measles
that is something that if a woman
failed her vaccination and that does
happen
and a child comes home from a school or
a daycare while she is pregnant
could cause a disaster for that
pregnancy
so i won't go further i can detail that
if you want but i've been warned about
the time limit thank you
representative cushman with a question
thank you mr chairman would you take a
question of of course um thank you
um
so
does anything in this bill prevent
the
as you see it i know you didn't write it
but
the way i read it nothing in it prevents
uh the daycare facility
from complying with existing law and
ensuring that they maintain
vaccination records for all those
children enrolled
but it does say to shall discriminate in
any way and if you have multiple
people coming in who
are not in the vaccine registry and have
presented to their physicians that they
have a religious exemption
now maybe
if you rewrite this bill you can make
clear that the private entity
or the school
is allowed
to say no you can't come in because we
have this requirement you know it's a
slippery slope in many ways and i guess
the one that worries me most is the
adult
employee saying i'm going to sue you for
not keeping me employed or employing me
when they refuse to be immunized against
things that they could transmit
that could be disasters for other people
maybe you can rewrite this in some way i
our next
hearing is scheduled for 3 o'clock and i
think we can sneak an exec session in
what is there a question of the chair if
so stated so i can hear it
no thank you
all right
open the exact session on house bill one
zero zero three and there are there is
a few more
and this is uh representative cushman's
bill
you get extra credit as a homeschooler
remember we heard this bill we thought
maybe some tweaking would make it better
and the amendment is the attempt
i can't hear you
my apologies my understanding was that
we had some bills that were ready to go
that didn't need amendments and i'm very
concerned about
um having to exact something with an
amendment we've only just seen
it has two sentences and i choose to go
okay
representative cushman would you care to
explain any material difference between
the bill and the amendment as we put
them side by side
thank you mr chairman yes so
representative merchant and i worked on
um well he signed off on an amendment
that i crafted
preferences for what it should say after
considering what we discussed in the
hearing
so it inserts the language into the
patient bill of rights
and it changes the
um
changes it from the provider shall not
or the facility shall not
to the patient shall not be
denied admission care or services based
and then i inserted the word solely
which i believe was representative
canerx suggested and i'm sorry if it was
someone else
after what was
said in the hearing and
so this this takes the burden off of
individual providers as was one of the
concerns and it places it just on the
facility it's just included in the
patient bill of rights this is a right
that a patient has they can't be denied
the care just based on their vaccination
status
would you care to speak to this
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and also thank you
for the question for uh running this by
me and working with me so to speak on it
as well and explaining it i think the
key word is solely which is what we
talked about before which clarifies it
because before without that key word in
there it was very broad this narrows it
down to something very specific which i
representative canuck
yes uh just a clarification you said
this would now place it on the
facilities but not the provider
but
why would that
be true i would think that if a provider
did not want to care on the basis say a
pediatrician said i don't take care of
kids in my practice not vaccinated
because of the risk to vulnerable kids
i don't see nothing here that exempts a
provider because it makes it blanket so
i'm
i agree just
it's confused
correct the
place this is in the statute is for
facilities not providers
thank you
bye apologies
yes and if i may clarify so it only
applies to
those facilities under that licensure
paragraph so it doesn't even apply to
primary care physicians it's really
truly
the larger facilities yeah we're still
in the process of finding the statute so
i could make sense of it thank you
any additional questions of the
amendment sponsors
seeing none the chair recognizes
representative cushman for a motion
thank you mr chairman i
motion to adopt amendment 2022
and representative merchant i will
gladly second thank you
it has been moved
amendment
2022-0702-h the motion is ought to pass
moved by representative cushman seconded
by representative merchant the clerk
please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative stephen
pearson yes representative cole fault
yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
representation representative soloway
representative cannon representative
nutter uppam yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods
yes representative merchant yes chairman
21 to zero 21 to zero
the motion carries 21 to
the chair recognizes representative
cushman for a motion
thank you mr chairman i motion that we
as a committee recommend ought to pass
on as amended house bill 1003
and we have a second representative
merchant i will second that thank you
sir
it has been moved by representative
cushman and seconded by representative
merchant
ought to pass as amended house bill
h motion is ought to pass as amended
would the clerk please call the rule
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative stephen
pearson yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes chairman pearson yes
21 to zero the vote is 21-0 the motion
ought to pass with amendment
on house bill
1003 passes
ends the
any objection to it thank you
[Laughter]
sorry
and representative cushman if you don't
have it ready already i'll take a nice
i'm looking for bills that i have cued
up and ready to go that
don't have amendments and they're
probably in the folder it takes me
opening the exact session on house bill
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program you will remember that
the prime sponsor
representative lang was very keen to
work with us
and things eventually came down to on
the wonderful form
the question of
should
the document be signed
the first time
you go to a particular provider
or shall it be signed
every time
and he says which way do you think
they're likely to go
and i said
make two amendments so we're ready no
matter what
so you will see coming around two
amendments
one
is
zero seven six six the other one is zero
seven one one they'll be coming by you
and take one of each
please
and the only difference
should be
whether it's done once or done every
time
and so we'll have a discussion on that
before we have a motion please
could i have a point of procedure mister
or a clarification as to procedure mr
chairman of clarification of procedure
yes you may
i am recollecting and i have now pulled
up
correspondence that we had yesterday i
believe it was
about which bills might be ready
for
exec
neither house bill 1003
nor house bill 1606 were on that list
uh
1616 1369
and
1633 were all on the list and i'm
wondering why we are
proceeding
with
a bill with two possible amendments and
um
seven minutes everyone else please re
read the amendments please while this is
going on
mr chairman
if i may yes point of order
i believe the last time we met
we had an ad hoc group
that was requested to get together to
work on this bill
and that
meeting is to be held this coming
wednesday
i believe you representative if that's
the case
um i apologize for stepping on
that meeting
and i will therefore close the exact
session on
1606 but keep the paperwork thank you
all right we're almost we're almost to
three o'clock we'll take a five minute
break
the one they just passed around
because i didn't get one of those so
okay
all right what numbers did she call out
um
opening a
hearing
on a
non-germane
amendment
zero seven
[Music]
to house bill 1271
i should have sent to everybody
recently
the
language of the original bill 1271
representative leon's non-germane
amendment to 1271
and also
the
statute
that would be
eliminated the language of that
i now hand out to you
a
an amendment from the prime sponsor of
the original bill
and could you make sure each person gets
one of these please while you're up
and this is an additional
amendment to consider
so
the chair now initially recognizes
representative erica leone to talk about
her amendment
thank you mr chairman for the record i'm
representative erica leon representing
derry which is rockingham six
this amendment would replace the entire
bill
and repeal the novel coronavirus disease
limited liability protection that was
passed last year
there were three other bills in the
legislature last year to give limited
liability protection for those who
follow guidelines
and have no protection for those who are
not following any guidelines whims or
dictates coming from the federal
government
the language of
what is now 21p 42a
goes further than any of those other
bills that were struck down
hold on sorry i'm being phone phone
called
it goes further than any of those
this
requires
our hospital acute care hospitals
assisted living facilities long-term
care facilities nursing facilities
residential care facilities ambulatory
care clinics and any other similar
facilities providing care to elderly or
infirm patients
to follow
executive orders
follow
let's say the executive orders
any of the rules that are given by any
of the
agencies up at the federal level
and it basically hands over control of
i think we have a fantastic department
of health and human services
i think that they are well capable of
helping guide new hampshire health care
here in this state
and i don't i think it does a disservice
to the people of the state to hand over
control of our hospitals to washington
d.c
by repealing this
we avoid making the same future mistake
of handing over control
and leave the decision-making where it
should be here in new hampshire
by the time this gets through the
coveted pandemic will be over and so it
will technically be a mute point
but the real problem is this sets a
terrible precedent
it hands over control
we have no say-so
and we need to get rid of this because
it is very damaging to our health care
system
so with that i'm willing to take any
questions
my suggestion to the committee is you
should have a side by side by side in
front of you
in any particular order
there is
representative kamtois original bill
there is representative lyons
amendment
which has been going around
and representative comtois amendment
which representative stephen pearson
passed out so that will help you to see
what the bill was and two possible
amendments
when was it ex
heard
is that your question
i'm going to give a few more minutes for
everybody
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i'll try and switch
back into question hearing mode rather
how
supposed
to square the circle with respect to
still existing
[Music]
mandates from other places
which have not only
um
operational consequences but potential
fiscal consequences for the state
with this bill because
um
although the current state of emergency
has expired there are still orders and
other things out there that this section
in law
might cover and it also there might be
further issues coming with respect to
covid which is the only thing i think my
understanding is that the underlying
statute covers
so
figure out whether they are to comply
with state mandates or
federal
which require
or federal mandates given that they may
not be able to do both and may be at a
significant fiscal
disadvantage if they comply with the
federal ones
thank you for the question
the statute that
i am looking to repeal with this
non-germain amendment
isn't the only reason why they might
comply with those orders
this does not prohibit them from
complying with any of those and from
applying with an executive order agency
order rule
it simply does not put the force of new
hampshire law to limit liability only
when you are following those executive
orders agency orders or rules
it goes silent on the issue and
it returns to where we are with
everything else where we go down to the
prima facie first do no harm
that is the way that we operate today
that is a way to successfully operate
and
only giving limited liability when
you're following executive orders agency
orders and rules
does a disservice to our state
it doesn't prohibit them from complying
however
representative canuck
yeah i'm still just a little bit
confused here because
when
i'm not
since the whole point of this was to
limit the liability because of the
potential conflicts or even just
for any of us who've ever been involved
in any kind of emergency issues or think
about how emergency triage can work for
hospitals
the decisions are not the usual
decisions and so i'm trying to figure
out how you made the comment this seeds
control and it really i don't understand
how
they're seeding control to the state
they still have the control of doing
everything this is really the purpose of
this was to absolve them from the
liability that might come about
because the decisions that have to be
made that are conflicting with our
normal decision-making process
can you explain that more i'm still
baffled
well thank you for the question when you
limit liabilities under certain
conditions you're specifically not
limiting liability under others
by limiting liability only when you are
complying with executive orders agency
orders or rules
that
specifically does not cover any other
actions it remains silent just as we are
otherwise but we heard discussion on
some of these other bills
that limiting the liability only to
those following the guidelines would
allow
punitive lawsuits to come against those
who were not following the executive
orders or guidelines
so by
passing this following that same logic
that i there was it was not this
committee it was a different committee
there were three different bills three
different committees
it show it would then follow
that if you're not doing that it is open
season on the hospitals file your
lawsuit and let's see what we can do
remaining silent is more protective
can i have a follow-up follow-up
i'm not quite sure why it would be open
season anymore than it already is
number one number two is what do you
think might be the impact on
getting group providers to happily
provide care in an emergency
uh that in particularly those who were
working outside of their usual purview
because they really had to do you
foresee any potential problems that
might come from trying to
recruit
providers to actually
care
if they are no longer shielded from
liability
well thank you for the question there
are some states that are pursuing this
route others that are resisting it
strongly
right now when you're operating in an
emergency there's there's certain
expectations
but normally you would look at your
patient look at your opportunities and
you would work within the toolkit that
you have
this limits the toolkit to those within
the emergency orders and agency orders
and rules to have protection
by specifically protecting some actions
and not others that sets up a scenario
where some things are viewed favorably
under the law and others are
thank you that sets me off on another
line of inquiry if i remember correctly
one of the
concerns and i'm not a fan of limited
liability myself
one of the concerns that
persuaded us to pass this just a year
ago
was that at the height of an emergency
health care providers and facilities
were sometimes required
to act in ways that were not in
accordance
with generally accepted practice
so
i don't know what the specific examples
are and there are people behind you that
can probably provide them but i'm
thinking that you know leaving a number
of critically ill patients out in the
hallway on gurneys because
it is not a good thing but if you don't
have any other place to put them it may
be something that you have to deal with
so
i'm
wondering
there was
a concern
specific to the pandemic and to practice
during a pandemic under emergency orders
that was very different
from all normal
practice and that would be why under
those circumstances
you would limit liability
solely for people who were departing
from their standard practice because
they were ordered to do so and that that
provides the differentiation between the
limitation of liability
under these circumstances and not under
i think i'll make a question out of that
um when you look to that and look to the
patients on the gurneys
out in the hallways that was not done
as an executive order or an agency rule
it was a consequence but there were a
lot of those consequences
and all of those actions
we do need to understand
are part of dealing with a triage
situation even when that triage lasts
for months or over a year
the an approach that recognizes that
doctors who are
putting patients
health autonomy and balancing the scarce
resources
when we are in an emergency situation
would be one thing but this is waiting
for orders to come either from executive
orders emergency orders executive orders
or agencies and that takes time
the biggest time when our physicians and
doctors and all of our other health care
protect professionals need protection
isn't once we start having some
guidelines of how things happen
it's while they're trying to do their
best to meet an emerging need
this is
i i i believe that this
was overreach and it only protects those
things that are under the executive
order and i do remember when we were
discussing senate bill 74 last year
talking about the need to be able to
access experimental therapies that was
one of the things that i was able to
work with with some of you in in moving
that forward and we recognized that
there needs to be a larger tool kit
but that tool kit
allowing emergent allowing experimental
use
that that hasn't been fully adopted
within within our attempt to deal with
this pandemic
so i think that the protections we would
need would need to be softer and broader
and not so laser focused where it's only
protecting emergency executive orders
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative taking my question
i'm looking at the last line in the rsa
21p 42a
this section shall not apply to actions
performed after such an emergency order
a rule is no longer in effect do we have
an emergency order in effect
no we do not so therefore isn't the bill
null and void
the statute itself
i would argue that that's a good reason
to repeal it
isn't it already repealed
i mean not not repealed from us but
repealed because of the way the statute
is written
um if they're
no because if there's a resurgence if or
for some other reason we have an
emergency order or rule that enables it
it would come back into play but it's
only if it's
for coronavirus yes
it's the only thing it applies to
yes
not to general emergencies
globally speaking
no it doesn't and i think that coming
forward in the fall was something that
better
allows physicians to practice as best
they can under an emergency would be a
thank you
i have a concern that even though the
emergency is over at this point
the worth some consequences that may
have come out of the fact for example
many hospitals
stopped doing all elective surgeries and
each patients that was supposed to be
scheduled for surgery and didn't get the
surgery
they could have some continuing
liability as a result of that
you know we had other situations where
field hospital tents had to be set up in
parking lots and patient beds were put
in that's very unusual set of
circumstances which could have had after
effects that even follows after the bill
is repealed
and
i think by specifically naming what some
of the protections against that
liability in during the period of
emergency and the wording seemed to
imply that any of the consequences that
occurred afterwards even after that
emergency
bill was
repealed or ended however it stopped
it would still be but under the
circumstances i don't know about what
even though there was some protection
while it was going on
that the way it's worded now or the way
you're suggesting that it would that was
continue to be for the like the elective
surgery or people that were treated in
rather
strange way and the other was that
for example during a good portion of
that whole emergency
hospitals complained that they could not
get the protective equipment that they
needed
representative snow wrap up your
statement that's an explanation yes i'm
sorry my question is
are there
possible consequences
to leaving it the way it is and not
leaving the exceptions in
that were written in the bill when the
emergency was going on and even to
follow up to it wouldn't that be a safer
route to take
thank you for your question and that
does bring up a very good point and i
think it it's exactly why we have
hearings on non-german amendments
i think the idea
of terminating that and not allowing it
to move forward
but maintaining that protection for our
facilities that were operating
underneath this limited liability shield
makes sense because the way that they
operated at that time was based upon
this limited liability i we can't strip
that out from them now and recognizing
that it existed and that's how they
functioned seems reasonable to me
but i
i don't believe that giving the force of
law to the executive orders and agency
orders is the right way to move forward
so i would like to see this
i would like to make sure that in
another emergency order or rule it
cannot be brought back
but i'm happy to continue to extend that
protection for whatever the lawsuit
duration would be for anybody who was
representative canuck
okay i'm still a little baffled um
you keep contending that this set some
kind of a differential protection
and that
those any actions then that are not
under the emergency would would somehow
almost be
have an increased liability but since
there's nothing in the original statute
that says that any actions taken that
don't comply that are sort of applied
but sorry that are not related to this
are uniquely
liable or
exposed to liability
the same liability that would always be
there for any other care that we give is
already there
all this does is extend it for the
unique circumstance the underlying not
your bill but the underlying extent that
only for that unique circumstance and
did not
increase the liability for things that
were not under the emergency order so
i'm trying to understand still
why you keep making that comment about
it being differential as though
we're at an increased liability if we
haven't if we're doing something that
doesn't have to do with the emergency
order anymore than we already would be
facing a normal practice
well thank you for that question in
in another committee in a hearing for a
very similar bill it was explained
by people with better legal minds than
mine
why that mattered
if we are past
this emergency
if we're past this we're past this let's
put this in the past let's figure out
how to make sure that we have full
protection because if the liability is
only limited under those orders and
rules then that has a larger reason to
have more and more of these orders and
rules next time around
it's just it's not good law making to
just hand everything over to a different
body
we have local control here we take great
pride in our health and human services
department and i believe that we can
and
follow up
now i'm getting more confused because
you talked about
under good hands with our department but
our department is
these executive orders didn't just come
out of the air from the governor they
were in consultation with dhhs were they
not
this speaks to orders coming from the
i
follow up i'm sorry
no
uh just to let you know where i'm i'm
going um
this is on one of the two amendments
before us
we have somebody from cmc dash
i think it's nhha which is new hampshire
hospital association
that
is wishing to speak to this specific
amendment
so if there were no further questions of
representative leon
other than representative cushman's
question i'm going to then call on jason
cole we will deal with 7 27 by
conversation then we will ask uh
representative contoir to come up and
explain her amendments so we're keeping
them in our minds in discrete lanes
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
uh thank you representative for taking
my question so
um while it is true that the covet 19
pandemic presented challenges in health
care that required flexibility and
deviations from standard practice
isn't it true that if any harm occurred
for which families and patients seek
justice that
civil liability for such harm should be
decided on on a case-by-case basis in a
court of law
and and
a second part of my question is
are you aware that malpractice and
negligence claims hinge on what a
reasonably competent medical
professional would do in the same
circumstances
thank you yes i do believe that it would
be hard-pressed to find somebody who
would give a civil judgment against
somebody who is operating
under these orders
i don't think that any reasonable judge
or any reasonable jury if it was a jury
trial would convict assuming that there
weren't egregious errors
this is something where we deal with
we deal with the fact that we have a
good judicial system and and yes i do
believe that um
my understanding of the malpractice
insurance is that as well that it's what
a reasonable person would do one
follow-up
one follow-up thank you mr chairman
uh follow-up
would you agree that giving blanket
liability immunity from harm
can cause a result
of
disincentivizing medical professionals
from speaking out against emergency
orders that could be resulting in
patient harm
yes i do think that that is a risk and i
also think it's a risk that
when you include things like vaccinating
your employees and saying that you have
no liability for that and citing this
law as your reason
that really gave gives me pause and
gives me a lot of concern
i'd rather leave it in the hands of the
judicial system if there is a true harm
that
that rises above the fact that we were
all just trying to figure out how to
deal with this
thank you mr chairman and i
i'm wondering if one of the underlying
[Music]
goals of
the
original legislation
was not only
to
um
so
i'm wondering if was
if you agree with me that one of the
goals
under the underlying legislation was not
only
to dictate the outcome of the legis of
of a court case but also
to prevent costly
long litigious
litigation from being filed and thus
diverting
more
much-needed
assets from the health care system
and
wouldn't
the existence of the statute as it is
at a minimum
deter those suits so they wouldn't have
to go all the way through the judicial
system
whether you agree with that as the right
way to proceed or not is wouldn't that
be the effect of having the limitation
of liability right there well thank you
and i this brings up why i'm thankful to
live in new hampshire and not california
our system is set up so that you don't
get the same kind of frivolous lawsuits
that you see in other states
it already is a high bar to bring a
lawsuit in new hampshire far higher than
many other states and i don't think that
you would see
lawyers bringing cases that bringing
frivolous cases forward
okay
thank you representative for introducing
your bill the chair recognizes jason
cole
from cmc point of procedure mr
chairman
yes
we are in a non-germane amendment
hearing that was noticed for
one
uh
amendment
okay and i
sincerely don't know the answer to
whether we can in a non-germane
amendment hearing
on a specifically noticed amendment take
up a different amendment i would think
that we could probably
um
put the hearing on recess then go into
executive session on the bill where then
we take up and look at the second
amendment could we
you would be within your rights to do
that i believe
thank you
but mr chair point of order why would we
not finish hearing the testimony on this
one thing our brain is on this now what
are you asking me i'm asking why would
we shift gears our brain is currently
working on this amendment and just
suddenly we are currently working on
this amendment that there is another
amendment the sponsor of the original
bill offered we could push this off to
march 7th and 8th which i fear is
becoming 7th 8th and 9th
but but could we not hear all of
amendment 1271 and the responses from
people who came here to deal with
amendment 1271
so they don't have to sit through the
next one if they don't choose to i'm
taking it in a specific order but but
could we not finish the hearing that we
just started yes that is what i'm
attempting to do
the chair recognizes jason cole come up
please
but we're still in the other in the
no oh i'm sorry no no i'm sorry stop i'm
sorry
oh i'm sorry i didn't i didn't
understand that i beg your pardon
we're even
okay yep yep
got it
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is jason cole
and i am the vice president and general
counsel for catholic medical center
i am here to testify in opposition to
the proposed amendment 0729 which
proposes to repeal rsa 21p 42
[Music]
rsa21p42a was sound public policy when
it was passed last year with
overwhelming support and it remained
sound public policy because the reasons
the law was enacted in the first place
remain in effect today
the law confirms the legislation
chairman
would you suspend please we only had 10
copies for a 21-person committee we will
attempt to get everyone in the committee
your written testimony
mr chairman i have another point uh the
i appreciate the
the chairman from catholic medical
center being here but he's literally
verbatim reading what he's passing out
do not read your testimony
i'll go off script thank you
you know maybe i'll do it by actually
just
kind of sharing my opinion to some of
the engagement that was done here
earlier
i do think that there are a number of
reasons why
you still need
this bill in place
you know in terms of the liability one
the statute of limitations
are still open
so the risk and the liability is still
there
second there's no insurance coverage for
this liability
you know most insurance coverages that
apply to hospitals have a lot of
carve-outs almost carving out all of the
coven-related liabilities
and third the need is still there and
one question was is rsa
21p 42a null and void um no
it's it's not our position that it's
null and void i mean there are still
emergency orders in place
the governor's order has been um you
know taken away
but there still is a public health
emergency order by dhhs
which is in place and that further
adopts a lot of these
waivers and things that were put into
place
and second the national order from the
president is still in place originally
so and you know one question
representative weber um you were sort of
describing
the need and the view of um you know
some of these things that were needed by
the hospitals to address the issues and
the concerns
and uh i'm struggling to kind of view
this as mandates
i think from the hospitals perspective
these things were that were adopted to
give the hospitals flexibility
to meet the needs that were needed these
were things like going beyond our
license numbers to increase our capacity
to do testing in parking lots and in
tents
to expand telehealth beyond what was
permissible at the time from cms
and there's there's other examples on
and on and the doctors had concerns the
doctors came to us and said wait a
minute i know we need to do this because
of the emergencies and the needs placed
in the community but this is going
beyond the standards of care and the
licenses where is the liability for that
going to fall
and it was very comforting for them to
know
that
their actions
were within the definition
of emergency orders within the
definition of our emergency management
system
and within the definite that their work
as healthcare workers was in um you know
as part of that system as well
and i think that the immunity is narrow
very narrow i put a lot of stock in the
last two sentences of that statute
where it's you know first of all it's
specific to covin
you still have to have reasonable
actions
and you have to be reasonably trying to
address and comply with the flexibility
as it's set out by the regulating
authorities
to act so i mean there are still our
standards in place
which i think keep the actions
reasonable
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so
so is the reason for
the
dhhs state of emergency
is it because the of the president's
state of emergency orders
since our
state emergency orders that were put in
place by our governor
have been lifted why why is is dhhs like
its own entity and and has more power
than the governor i i'm not i'm i'm
confused so at a high level and again my
colleagues can chime in if they have a
different take on this but at a high
level for something like cms for example
medicare
um you know the the national order went
out
they then
defined some waivers and things that you
can do
to have non-traditional ways of care dhh
essentially adopts
those waivers that are set by cms
and so the i think the current emergency
status that's in place is their way of
continuing to accept this flexibility in
place enabling the hospitals and other
health care providers i'm from a
hospital so i tend to see it from the
hospital's perspective but other nursing
homes and others so in order for them to
adjust the way they're providing care to
meet the needs dhhs is adopting those
so cms and dhhs can override the
governor
when he
relieves state of emergency orders
is that right is that am i correct there
i'm not viewing it as they're overriding
the orders i think there are certain
aspects that came from the orders that
dha determined that in the pursuit of
patient patient safety pursuit of
meeting the health care needs they have
continued to adopt some of those things
that are permissible from
thank you
yes
counselor i we were handed a
handout and it says
my name is john freiberg yes i don't
think you are
i'm not i apologize yeah i mentioned it
over here and i should have made it so i
passed out
is written testimony
from john freiburg who's general counsel
for solution health he was unable to
make it but he wanted to chime in with a
letter i also handed out and i'm the one
who brought only 10. i apologize
copies of
my written testimony does somebody have
one of his that we can make additional
copies for everybody
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question i'm a little um
slow so i could use a concrete example
of the kind of practice that's gone on
during the
emergency that might
a hospital or a provider might be held
liable for so are you saying
that
operating under the changing rules for
medicare for telehealth for example
that
health care was delivered by telehealth
as opposed to in person and therefore a
diagnosis of a serious illness was
missed and that person
suffered the consequences of that
and they
chose to sue
is this the kind an example of the kind
of thing
liability
the law about liability would address
i think that could be an example yeah
that you did tell the health and maybe
something was missed but you did that
because you didn't want you wanted to
decrease community spread you want to
also protect the doctors who are you
know meeting with a lot of people that
are sick
but other examples are the alternative
care site which i understand ultimately
wasn't activated but here
um you know elliott dartmouth cmc got
together under the the purview of the
national guard to put together the first
alternative care site that was designed
to handle overflows and if you think
about it it was going to be staffed by
elliott dartmouth cmc doctors and nurses
we were going to pitch in work together
well so how do you track that liability
there if you've got
one doctor from one organization and a
nurse from another i mean it was pretty
much a you know a headache trying to
figure out how that was going to work
this immunity enabled us to
get that together and have it in place
for a number of years
and one more example would be
um you know i think this this was done
by a lot of other hospitals i don't
think we did this at cmc in the last
surge but you know if you ran out of
beds even i think somebody mentioned it
you have patients potentially in
non-rooms i mean these could be the
hallways or office rooms i mean there
were adjusteds there that's that's an
issue with your license so they were
giving us the flexibility to do it
uh follow-up
so
um
let's say one of those things happened
with a negative consequence to a patient
if this is repealed
would the immunity
the liability immunity
remain in place if the event original
event happened when this bill
was in effect i mean when this statute
was in effect
you know that's a good question my
understanding is that the repeal is is
retroactive but i'm
i'm not sure i guess i need to clarify
that but i would also say though that
you know
i'm not sure you you're going to see the
suits later in time so if it's not in
place there i think it's definitely
going to be something people are going
to argue over and i think you're still
going to litigate these things even with
the immunity you're probably going to be
litigating the immunity i think it could
have that effect that you were talking
about representative weber in terms of
um you know perhaps
uh you know
maybe streamlining some of that but
ultimately if you look at the language i
think people are going to argue okay it
wasn't reasonable or you know argue
maybe it wasn't following the um
you know the the the the waivers that
you were trying to follow so i'm not
sure it's taking away someone's day in
court it's just giving another tool for
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
helping clarify all this stuff
i'm looking at the underlying statute as
it exists which would be repealed under
what would happen
under the current statute
if there was a new wave of coronavirus
resulting in new emergency orders would
that still provide the protection or has
it
pretty much expired of its own weight by
virtue of the last
sentence which says this section shall
not apply to actions performed after
such an emergency order or rule is no
longer in effect
it's a good question it's a good point i
i think it would um
if there was a new emergency order
declared and under that authority they
were looking to give more flexibility
for health care providers to address the
need then this would be activated and of
course it also has to apply to covid
that's another way that this is limited
but i mean
yeah that's that's another benefit of
having it in place here if things get
bad or change or the variance change in
a way that you know people get really
sick you'll still have this in the
toolbox to address it
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
for taking my question
can you help me understand the interplay
between
this law and the prep back at the
federal level because i believe the prep
act which was activated back in march
2020 and subsequently modified many
times along the way provides a level of
immunity to a lot of players in the
market from
not just providers but manufacturers and
so forth etc with their products can you
help me understand
how that is different than what this is
and are they duplicate are they
supportive of each other help me
understand the interplay between the two
you know i apologize representative i'm
not sure and i want to get ahead of my
skis and give you a an incorrect answer
so i haven't looked at that one in a
while i don't know if
follow up follow up if you could because
what i'm trying to understand is that if
this was to go away
that is there a federal blanket that's
going to protect the hospitals and
providers regardless of what we do at
the state level
so i would like to follow up but i'll
take a stab i mean i i don't think so i
don't think this is duplicative i mean
there are i think 32 states that have
put in these immunities it's because you
get the immunity through state law
and i i don't think you get it through
representative konorick mine is just a
clarification of something i think i
understood you say
so you are not certain whether it is
i'm not
okay yeah
represents under the impression that it
was but again i don't want to i don't
want to mislead i i need to check that
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um can you clarify is
um are visitors currently limited
because of this statue or is this statue
what enabled um you know visitors from
um
you know i'd have to check on that too i
don't think there was a specific waiver
addressing
visitation
policies
those things stem from the patient bill
of rights they stem from the hospital
policies
um so i i don't think there was a
mandate or order coming down on that
representative
another hopefully short one uh one of
the things i was at this was
we have 21 people
part of that whole
exemption because that seemed to cover
them i thought
originally but is this just to clarify
it make it a little more drive the point
home
it was to clarify and um you know a lot
of work was done by the attorney
general's office on this question and
you know i i being an attorney i mean
it's a pretty thorough opinion that they
issued kind of slogging through the law
and the authority on this and they
concluded that yes this this work falls
within the health care um
you know the the emergency work of a
health care worker um so it was a
clarifying point but an important one
you know relying upon an ag opinion
versus having it in the statute is a is
a much different position when it comes
to
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um could you please
provide um some examples of the kinds of
me of some of the medicare and medicaid
waivers that um the hospitals needed
this immunity from
yeah i'll take a stab but i'm gonna go
high level because you know again i'm
just the the attorney on this and and
not involved in operationalizing these
things and i know it could be pretty
nuanced but i think that
the example i mentioned of seeing
patients in tents and parking lots and
things like that or doing testing in
these alternative sites
is a good example of those waivers
going beyond the number of beds that
your license provide i think is a good
example of those waivers
again i go back to the telehealth i
think that was really more of a billing
issue
that they were enabling you to use that
as a as a means to see patients um and
we're able to bill for it so it's those
follow up
thank you mr chairman
um
okay so
for those things and i i'm sure that
there are more
now
my understanding is that the malpractice
and negligence claims they hinge on what
a reasonably competent medical
professional would do in the same
circumstances
now in the in these dire circumstances
that the hospitals were faced with
i believe that in most scenarios since
there's so many of you weighing in on
those decisions that you'd have a
reasonable argument in court that
competent medical professionals would
make those decisions
would you agree so there really
shouldn't be a need for you to have
immunity from liability if you have
plenty of ground to stand on in court
you know maybe but you're leaving it up
to a
a judge that might not see it that way
or a jury that might have a different
interpretation
and
you know at the end of the day you're
going to have somebody saying that here
is what should have been done and this
is what you did
and without the immunity i think you're
missing the link to explain
why this was done
and it was done to meet the needs
and to ensure we can we can address this
public health emergency
question from the chair um
i know from my lawyer friends that any
case just about can be brought at any
time no matter what
nevertheless
when a lawyer who hopes to be paid when
that lawyer wins sees the language about
immunity
he realizes or she that it's a higher
bar
than that language not being there would
you agree
i would i would agree thank you
any other questions for
general counsel
thank you so much thank you
also on this specific non-germane
amendment according to the hearing as
advertised paula minihan from the new
hampshire hospital association
uh
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals community
hospitals as well specialty hospitals we
are opposed to house bill 1271
and i um this is um
we
honestly were a little unclear why the
sponsor believes this repeal is
necessary senate bill 1749 which was the
bill that was passed last year
passed by the full senate 24 to nothing
and by this committee 1802 in the full
house back in may
created this statute that is now um
being attempt attempting to repeal and
we believe their law does remain
relevant and necessary and we are
concerned with repealing this could
effectively
make what was legal in the past possibly
retroactively at least unclear and could
lead to possible legal challenges
so um we
the now that
those that did exactly what the law
asked of them are now exposed to
liability for following the law and we
don't
we
that does not make sense to us and we we
um we don't believe that should be
allowed um i attached to my testimony
the referenced attorney general opinion
that attorney cole referenced
it is long but as he said it was very
thoughtfully done by then attorney
general gordon mcdonald
and i encourage you to read that but
again that was not enough
it was determined by our hospitals that
it was not enough and we needed this to
be codified in law and fortunately the
governor um and and the legislature
agreed and it was signed into law back
in june
um
and
um i am referencing others that uh have
um legal um background that can answer
more specific questions but represent
excuse me um
attorney cole already did that so i
think he answered a lot of your
questions and mentioned the federal
public health emergency and i think to
representative delemus's point there's a
public health emergency and then there
is a state of emergency two different
things and so the commissioner
has the authority under under her
authority to state law regarding the
public health emergency that's the
distinction i am also happy to provide
more details on the cms waivers there
are signif there are a number of them it
had to do with signatures being required
for certain things because of
those that were not available it had to
do with
case management and certain things like
that but i'm happy to provide with to
the committee some of the waivers that
remain in effect today under cms which
is again medicare and medicaid um so
that's why the state is
following those as well happy to answer
try to answer any questions
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question ms minahan i'm
looking at the attorney general opinion
and i am looking at the question that
you asked of the attorney general well
i'm sorry commissioner shibana asked um
and
the answer
to this question the question being does
the immunity provided in
21-p colon 41 apply to emergency
management activities
under the state of emergency and
medicare medicaid waivers rules
etc and the opinion was that yes that
that rsa
does did apply to those
facilities employees and volunteers that
were engaging in those
management activities
as long as they were complying with or
reasonably attempting to comply with
applicable state of emergency orders or
rules
so if that is true then why do we still
need this section of law if there was
already a section of law that gave that
immunity um i think again in reading the
entire
opinion from the attorney general i
think it's it's very instructive so i
would um i would just suggest that
that's why he went through step by step
and again
yes there may be those protections but
that was not sufficient
in the determination of of folks that
were working on this and we requested
that it be codified in law and we
appreciate that the governor did sign
that
seeing none thank you thank you
and now um i'm going to ask my our
committee
parliamentarian
representative weber um i want to walk
through this and let me know if i'm on
good ground i want to close this hearing
because we finished what was noticed i
want to open an exact session on the
bill so we can look at the second
amendment that's been prep thank you so
much
and at that point you could also
entertain any other suggestions that
other people have for modifications just
preparatory for somebody preparing
even more amendments if necessary oh joy
the chair opened the question sir do we
have any more people that signed to
testify on the amendment or not
no or i would have heard them thank you
though um
i probably should have said i hope i
would have heard them
but thank you
open the exact session on house bill
1271 the chair will not entertain any
motions
and the chair recognizes representative
barbara comtois the
author and chief sponsor of the original
bill
and the author of amendment
2022-078-h
0783-h
and that has been passed around to you
and tell us about your amendment please
thank you mr chairman thank you
honorable colleagues um
the the only changes on this year was we
changed it from a two-thirds vote to a
three-fist vote and we updated the rsa
that it related to uh
on the very on line 10 rsa 141c 16 and
rsa
141c20 as was heard last week that the
reference
was no longer valid
because ols had not had the updated
statutes at that time and they
referenced the wrong one
so that is the only change the original
bill
and uh
so i just wanted to make that
clarification
but not to put too fine a point on it
your amendment does not remove section
21-p colon 42-a it does not remove it
it never did it iraq only amends
rsa
21p53 it it has no reference to p42
does anyone have any questions for
representative controls
thank you mr chairman else thank you for
taking my question i want to commend you
on trying to find a way to use two words
emergency legislative body in the same
language
so in saying that my concern is going to
be three quarters of a vote like you did
before it does reduce the barrier or the
bar if you will but i do concern myself
about the word emergency and the word
legislature in the same paragraph
because i don't see them
it's almost like an oxymoron quite
frankly so i'm looking at this saying if
it's going to truly be an emergency
i don't see the legislative body being
the place to go to resolve it
okay um but
thank you for the question and thank you
for the comment um the only thing i'm
going to say to this body as we just
heard in the previous testimony is that
there is a difference between a state of
emergency and a public health emergency
which means that the
in no reflection on the commissioner of
health and human services because i
think she's doing a great job and she
has a great background however in the
future
we may not have a commissioner with such
a fantastic background
and may choose to act on their own
without consultation as we had mentioned
follow-up representative merchant
i
i think i'll
ask the question also to the chair does
not have to be a question this is an
exact session we can get away with our
usual policy wow legally
in saying that one of the other things
it was a compromise not trying to solve
with a type of sex session
there is a
legislative oversight body
to the department health human services
there is is it possible at that point in
time that that body becomes the place
that you go to versus the full
legislative body is that a po i'm trying
to thread the needle here it can be and
there's also a couple of other
individuals in groups that are working
their way through as point persons
in an emergency for basically being a
flying squad
representative soloway speaking of that
thank you mr chairman
just a quick question representative you
use the word legislature i assume that
that term excludes the body on the other
side of the wall
i believe that they qualify as a
legislature as well would you prefer to
use the term
i do believe that we would need both
bodies
to pass any law because that is how we
do it in new hampshire
and it's both bodies that represent the
constituents so i do believe legislature
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman just
looking for a clarification on exactly
how this plays out so the
commissioner
just decides that he or she would like
to order an individual
to
receive treatment
uh
or maybe quarantine
if that's what it's alluding to under
preventing an incident or a threat of
disease
and
that in order to oh okay and then
it may include immunization as necessary
so they can they can require it if they
get a three-fifth vote of the
legislature but even if the legislature
votes by three-fifths an individual may
still refuse treatment or immunization
thank you representative cushman for
i was seeking to limit
one person being able to dictate to the
entire state versus in specific
individual but ols put it under this
particular
um
rsa
so i will defer because like you said
there is which wasn't in statute when
this bill was being drafted was the rsa
141 c16 um that was not
they did not reference that and did not
notice that so we were only looking at
the other statute that didn't recognize
that
so maybe um
i would defer to this committee to make
the appropriate um
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman this is just a
question about the mechanics of how this
would happen um
and it says three-fifths of the
legislature so would that imply
three-fifths of the house and then
three-fifths of the senate or would it
be
thank you for the question it would it
any further questions
representative canarck
um
you have a little baffled i'm i'm still
concerned about tying the hands of our
public health
experts in terms of dealing with a
rapidly
moving public health emergency that no
matter how fast we think we can do
something
there is a delay in the legislature you
have to have a notice that we're going
to be having
some kind of a bill or something i'm not
sure we'd have to have hearings then we
have to convene a house session then we
have to vote
uh we've just heard a lot of interesting
things about liability is there any way
we ought to think about the liability of
the legislature for causing an increased
number of deaths as you're waiting in a
miniature meningococcal outbreak
and not allowing us to mandate uh for
example immunization and knowing that we
might have a lot of people would die
because of the delay
thank you for the question
representative kanark and i can
understand
the concern
however i don't believe that a public
health emergency
is
done immediately and i at least i would
not
i would hope that it's not done
in haste
and therefore
there should be time
for one to declare a public health
emergency
we they should be consulting with other
folks and as we know we have a great
commissioner however i'm looking at the
future
and i'm looking at somebody who could be
in there that does not have the medical
background that she has
and the knowledge that she has and may
not consult and maybe the the the answer
to this is maybe not the legislature but
one of these other commissions that she
has to consult with
um
so i'm just going to put that out there
thank you representative
weber thank you in light of the language
which
appears to me to give any individual the
right to say
i'm not going to have an immunization
you know maybe maybe quarantine maybe
thank you representative weber for the
um
question
so
i know that the individual may refuse
treatment
but
maybe
they're being forced to or against their
will or something
i can't think of a circumstance at the
moment and i would hope that i would
never think of a circumstance where it
could happen where somebody is being
forced to against their will
however
is it better not to have some safeguards
in place now
before that happens
okay thank you
sorry would it be helpful in terms of
the issue about delay
if
number one under
roman numeral five if it said the
commissioner in consultation with the
medical director of his department and
dr chan would have his title is
could then issue a thing and then
the epidemiologist right and then at the
end where it says the three-fifths
majority if you think this is
appropriate
and within 30 days that would have to be
approved by a three-fifth majority of
the legislature that would seem to give
you i don't know if 30 days is enough
time but i'm trying to keep it as short
as you can as we discuss it but this
would mean it would seem to protect us
against a commissioner that may be a
lawyer as was happened the last time but
at least he'd have to have
consultation with medical experts who
could also call in other people if they
so needed
and then you'd have a 30-day delay
before the legislature had to approve it
would that
seem to ease people's mind a little bit
about this
no
sorry
okay so do i still say thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
okay
it doesn't have to be a question it
could be okay statement um well it is a
question have you ever seen the state
respond
in a couple of days
thank you for the question
representative gay i can't say that i
have personally but i'm not going to i
mean but we do have people that respond
to emergencies on a daily basis so i
would never i would not you know
just going to put that out there follow
up follow up
but in the context of what we're
discussing a massive response to an
but in a medical situation
there was no question
that the rollout of the
immunizations
took a
long time the idea that we can't wait
five days to make a decision to me seems
a little
disingenuous
thank you for the question uh
representative gay
and
so
you are correct in this regard i mean we
were using emergency
immunizations
for a pandemic
so there was you know and it took
several months for this to roll out
stephen pearson
thank you mr chairman i
i had a thought here in reference to
representative kenner's statement about
the legislature having
liability and i was just envisioning the
size of the prison that would exist if
legislators were held liable for
screwing something up
historically
but along with that i have a question
and now this is a substitute teacher
question right because you know i don't
hang out with you guys normally there
was some reference to the oversight
committee
in in dhhs and i'm wondering
does that committee have statutory
authority
to
interfere with the declaration of the
commissioner of health and human
services
since i'm chair of that commission
no i do not believe we do however we do
give advice
the commissioner comes to us every month
and gives us an update and
the worse the situation out there the
longer she gives us an update and she
listens to us
so we have
an advisory role presently
fantastic and i think that's probably
where the the
the core of this comes from is it has to
do with
the fact that
this is a check
a check which the oversight committee
does not
have
full authority to conduct and that's
as i'm trying to wrap my brain around
what we're asking here so that's uh
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair i just following
up on the
other representative
peterson's question
you meet once a month as the oversight
committee
do in fact
is it does exist do you have issues that
say this came up the day after a meeting
you say oh we need to meet again and you
have that ability or is it strictly
the one month i called one special
meeting
because we were behind
are you you have that capability yes
thank you
so we could get together on the fast
enough
to as a group
render
anything else seeing nothing else i
behalf of what i suggested well hang on
i closed the exact session
but i am wondering
if there would be a group of four or
five people who would like to hash over
or
next time we meet
we vote on
amendments
and another amendment can be made before
then
so that's your choices
uh i'm not asking for a vote but sort of
a head roll side decider up and down
what is your thoughts about an ad hoc
group trying to pull it all together and
maybe i'm misunderstanding the question
i can't hear you maybe i misunderstood
the question yeah i'm looking for this
if you don't think it's a good idea to
have a group i'm looking for this if you
do
i was saying i would be happy to be a
part of a group all right i don't see a
or how about a show of hands
could i just say i can't speak for
anybody but me
i don't want to work on it so that's
fine
i'm shaking my head i don't object to
anybody else who wants to work on it
working on it i just wanted to make that
clear because i'm i'm shaking only for
myself any such group would represent
people who are on a variety of opinions
on this otherwise it really doesn't help
how many of you
would
think a work group is a good idea put
i don't think we have enough
and if we did it would only be probably
people pretty much on one side so we
will look on this
on march 7th
now we've got a few more things
and
we can execute these few more things
on the list
i had
sent to
the
minority ranking member and who reminded
me of that list which i totally forgot
obviously was house bill 1369
relative to covet health and safety
policies at new hampshire performing
arts venues
i open an exec session on bill 1369.
we heard it on february 7th
and
i might even have
the numbers
do you have the numbers
i thought we did i mean shapiro is
representative leon to the rescue she's
punching up numbers i thought i packed
and this is amendment 707 and i told the
representative i thought 707 would fly
[Music]
representative canark when you're seated
tell us what amendment 707 does
yes sir thank you very much um as we
worked on this bill you may recall that
there were
a lot of uh issues that came up about
trying to make it a little broader
actually i should first say what it all
had to do with the initial bill had to
do with coven
but we realized that it probably doesn't
make a lot of sense to do a lot of
legislating on covid and it might be
better to think about being communicable
disease in a general sense
the question had been brought up as to
why this bill was even needed to begin
with and the discussion was simply that
as venues tried to
deal with this they sometimes had
patrons who were complaining um and said
you're not allowed to do this so as the
patron sorry as the venue representative
said it was simply to give them the
backup yes indeed they did have the
authority to set their own
uh rules but as representative lang so
nicely pointed out
there is a contract between the venue
and the um patron and that needs to be
respected that uh if you're going to
suddenly change the rules on them you
should offer them a refund so we did
work together in committee that day kind
of did a little mini exec session and we
did some work together to
uh come up with some wording that would
work reasonably well
regarding giving
uh refunds
now the problem is then as i worked with
the sponsor he said well you know the
venues already have disclaimers on their
website that things could change
um and so i did insert that but i
didn't quite agree with him completely
because he just wanted to say that they
you know that they could do that but i
when i worked with some other people as
well i think including tim lang we
talked about the fact that it should be
acknowledged so the bottom line is
gets rid of all of the references to
covet 19.
it simply talks about communicable
disease because that makes it scalable
for future issues
and even for any past issues i mean in
other words we may have it doesn't have
to be a new disease there could be an
outbreak of meningococcus or any other
number of things but this just allows
the venue
operators and by the way just to clarify
too this is a replace all bill so you
don't have to look at side to side you
just look at this anyway allows the
venue operators
to put in whatever health and safety
policies they wish it gives them the
right as a business to set their own
policies regarding masks or vaccines or
testing or a combination
for to protect the patron staff
performers and their own investments
but the point is the important lines
that are new are page sorry lines 17
through 20 that if the policies posted a
time of ticket purchase relative to
these issues change after you purchase
the ticket that they shall therefore
that's not an option shall refund the
ticket price at the patrons request
unless the patron has acknowledged that
all orders are subject to venue policies
at the time of the show which may be
different than policies at time of
purchase
and we all have clicked those little
boxes when we set up a hotel reservation
airline reservation whatever we click
the box that says i've read the policies
and i understand and those are things
that tell you that you know you have to
cancel more than 24 hours in advance or
that the airline reservation cannot be
altered and so on
so this means it's stronger than just
that they have something on their
website but that the the patron has
actually acknowledged that they saw that
so it it tries to respect
the
right of the venue to set their own
rules respects the right of the patron
to demand a refund if the rules change
but still respects the venue that if the
patron is aware that it might change uh
and they that and they've agreed to that
that then they don't have to have the
refund so it kind of kind of tries to
thread that needle for all those various
things
thank you mr chairman i i just recall
when we had the hearing on this
and
uh
i just think this is well-meaning
but they are this already exists
and then i think what really got me was
one of the people who testified said
that it would be the big bad government
putting teeth into it which means that
they can sort of you know hold us up and
say see the government said we have to
do this and i'm i'm just sort of
if this if the power already exists for
the venues to do what they're going to
do announce whatever they're going to
announce put it on their websites give
them the options of this that or the
other i just find this unnecessary
may i respond representative connect to
respond yes representative weber it
doesn't tell them that they have to do
that at all it gives the business the
opportunity to set their own policies
and it does clarify in statute that they
have that authority to set their own
policies since we've seen a number of
bills trying to restrict their ability
to set their own policies during this
very legislative session as a result
this will allow them to have that carve
out so that they do still have that
authority
and representative weber
thank you and i think the other
issue that the venue's brought up
is they can currently say this is my
policy
but if a patron shows up and says i'm
not going to comply with your policy
they have no recourse
to enforce their policy and all the
people who signed up because they were
relying on the policy
then are stuck dealing with somebody who
doesn't buy into that and the other
thing that i heard very clearly from the
venues is that often these policies
these restrictions do not
originate from the big bad government
they originate from the performers or
the act that they are booking
and those people will not come to new
hampshire
if they can't
set their terms and have their terms be
complied with
and we're a very small state so they can
book places in maine or vermont or
massachusetts and new hampshire people
will go there
and our performing arts venues and all
of the people around them who provide
meals and transport and other things
that relate to the poor performing arts
venues
will suffer because those people will
simply choose not to come here
which is why i think we need this it's
not so much what the government will do
it's what the performers who are being
booked here want to see
and what the audiences want to see
and the
venues are going to set their policies
based on
the acts that they think they want to
book and the people who are willing to
pay for tickets if people don't agree
with the policies they won't come and
the venues will change their policies
that's free market and it appears to me
that this cuts right across the
ideological and cultural perspective
one performing group may insist on masks
and maybe even personal protection suits
all around
the next group is bubba's jug band and
hell no
representative leon
thank you mr chairman
we had some good up close experience
with this in derry because we had a
facility that changed their their
policies and watching what happened with
the different constituents the attorney
general did a very good job of
first start making sure that money
people's money would be refunded when
there was no policy and then holding it
to the policy that was in play
watching this play out right in my
backyard let me see that right now we're
handling this well
right now they are able to set their own
policies right now they are denying
access to people who are not following
their policies
we have trespass if you're not allowed
on the property you're not allowed on
the property um and they do have the
right to do that as private businesses
so i i see this as
possibly setting up dueling legislation
and
if we have because it seems like one of
the reasons for this is as a blocking
move against large against anything that
is prohibiting people from um
that would prohibit this type of action
if we don't think that that sort of
thing is going to pass or come towards
us i don't understand why we would need
this and if we believe that that has a
strong chance to pass then i'm not sure
why we'd want to have conflicting
legislation so while i appreciate the
effort to get an amendment that that
better reflects that that contract which
is very important um i i just
just in general i think that this is
something that's already well handled
without without legislation
but a number of the venues who came said
it wasn't so
maybe it was handled well in one case
but it isn't working for everybody which
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
um i will definitely echo what
representative leon said this is totally
unnecessary they can already do this
it's just a way of them kind of being
like
oh well the state says that we have to
because that was mentioned you know that
they can point to it and and act like
they're not responsible but the
legislature is
and
the other thing is i just have a
question i wonder if anybody knows the
answer do these
performing arts venues accept any form
of state funding
in the form of grants or
contracts or anything like that
representative canarch
that i'm not certain of though there was
some funding that did come to help bail
them out when they were in financial
difficulty due to this the goal of this
bill was actually to
not need to do that so much because it
would allow them to stay open and
function but i'm also still troubled by
people continue saying that the state
says you have to it does not say that
if you look at the line on line 14.
venues located in new hampshire shall
have the authority to establish in other
words it's not that the state says this
is what you have to do it establishes
that they have the authority to set
their own
business policies
and that is a perfectly fine thing i
don't
think there's a problem
thank you
in regards to the
amendment
one of the things that is clear and i
think
our constituents deserve to have that
kind of protection
is how they handle refund
because right now we're leaving it up to
the individual facility
how to handle a refund
so therefore
by statute it clearly tells the patron
what they're
able to do as far as how to get a refund
if we rely upon the facility
to make that dictate then we'll
basically
not giving our constituents the
protection of being a patron to getting
a refund they really deserve because
businesses basically can wiggle around
the policy i don't think that's our
intent we want to be sure that they're
representative gay
i agree
i think that uh
we already have the policy where the
venue can
uh
can notify people they seem to be doing
that now but
prying money out of some people's hands
is really hard
so it seems like this this is a
guarantee for the purchaser of the
tickets
representative folsom
thank you um
it's late in the afternoon and and i
need coffee really badly um
and so i'm having i i
i'm trying to go back to english grammar
class which just makes it even that much
worse
um
i'm reading this sentence and it says if
policies posted at the time of purchase
relative to the blah blah blah
change after the ticket purchase is
completed the venue shall refund the
ticket price of the patrons request
unless
the patron acknowledged that all orders
are subject to venue policies at the
time of show which may be different than
the policies at the time of purchase
so to me it's like saying
um
unless the
patron knew that there could possibly be
a change in the policies you're out of
luck
i mean that's kind of how it can yeah if
you couldn't explain that representative
yes and i i really thank representative
merchant for saying this better than i
said earlier yeah that's the whole thing
it protects them because it says
if you if the patron has not been
notified that things could change
they have the right of a refund
if the patron has been notified and not
just notified in fact that was the
choice for maddie matt wilhelm wanted
representative wilhelm wanted to just be
notified i said no needs to be
acknowledged if the if the patron has
acknowledged that they were informed
that it could change
then they do not have that right so
therefore it protects
i'm trying to clarify the question you
ask
so it it
what it does is it clarify it protects
the patron
so that they have that right if they
were not
like if they did not acknowledge that it
could change it protects the venue to be
able to get that uh
to not have to get that refund if they
did tell them
so it protects both that's what i was
trying to achieve
representative soloway uh mr chairman
without meaning to go out of order i
have checked and it seems that the late
february monsoon has begun
east and south of us
and the february blizzard is beginning
west and north of us and i'd like to
know if the chair does not exercise due
diligence guarding the safety of the
members of this committee is he liable
for suit no since you described
directions everywhere but right here
we're in good shape let's wrap this up
it isn't rocket science can we move on
to a vote representative pearson thank
you i just i'm looking at this and
from the outside and as a guy who's
gonna have to vote on this on the full
floor
this is this is what i'm asking looking
at this here you're talking about
communicable diseases
this and i i'm asking to make sure that
we have this right if this if i'm
reading this correctly the venue has the
authority
to
require to have testing requirements
for patrons to enter for a communicable
disease
yes i mean the point is we
one of the things we've tried to do over
the last couple of last month or so is
not
take away some the specificity of covet
19 references because that may not still
be there and likewise some of these
things might be more applicable to other
diseases that may be present i think it
would be prudent to look at the list of
communicable diseases in the state of
new hampshire
and what you're opening your self up to
for a venue to have the authority to ask
for here
well one of the things i think that's
important again this is the free market
issue and i think representative weber
said this
if some venue is being totally bizarre
in their policies
no one will go there they will go to the
other venue that actually has it i don't
think this is anything nefarious by
communicable diseases there's not we
don't have a specific list of
communicable diseases in the state
well okay but i mean we're we're looking
at things like meningitis uh chicken pox
versus all those things let's say you
had a measles outbreak that was really
quite severe in an area and they they
wanted to be able to do something now
testing is not something we do there but
that would allow that but this is this
is not really
i'm not sure this is not as broad as
you're making it out to be it could
apply but it's i don't think a venue is
going to start doing unreasonable things
they'll be out of business in no time
flat
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
this brings the question of will you
have facilities that are advertising
themselves as std free are they going to
be testing people for stds before you
come to the rave at whichever facility i
think that i appreciate the attempt to
move outside of covid but i i think the
ticket policies are really the most
important thing and that's just a pure
commerce thing once we start talking
about testing for communicable diseases
are you denying access to people who are
hiv positive what else are you doing
beyond the patron
we're now going down the slope or
telling a business how to run their
business
and i think i'm really having a
difficult time to dictate to a business
and say to them well you can run your
business this way because with the
government we're going to tell you how
to run your business
and i think
it's a free market if the business wants
to run the business that way
and if patrons don't want to patronize
it they won't be in business
so therefore the free market is going to
rule here not
the government and i think we should be
clear about this is the government is
the issue here and we're basically
telling the business you can run your
business as you wish and we're not going
to interfere with you
representative nutter upham
we're
very good in this committee of coming up
with
way out there scenarios something that
could happen
and talk now this is my first time um
quoting
uh
tim
lang lane
lang okay
um so you know he said in his testimony
and in a private conversation that he
he works for
concert venues
he attended over 53 concerts this summer
that he worked at
and many of them required
uh proof of vaccine or proof of negative
and he said that they had a testing
station you know 15 minute testing
station and i think that's what we're
talking about not testing for stds or
or nasal congestion or
um
headaches
so i and this was a specific covid kind
of thing so
i
think we should leave it at that
representative cofoult
uh thank you mr chairman so
i i think uh representative merchant
brought up the point that we don't want
to tell businesses how to operate
i would argue that we don't need a
statute to tell businesses that we're
not going to tell them how to operate
um and and then the the other thing is
although the the language here does say
notwithstanding any other provision of
law
i would point out that uh legislation
passed last year
um
any any
[Music]
subdivision of the state governmental
entity quasi governmental entity
um
or any public benefit or or any
organization
essentially
driving or offering a public benefit at
the state expense
needs to be not
discriminating on based on vaccination
status so i would have to revisit that
but i do believe that given the
performing arts
grants that are available through the
state
we we may be running afoul of that as
well with this legislation
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman um i think we're
just going to probably disagree on this
but i i
i don't see why we need this when
private businesses are allowed to do
um right now what and they are they're
doing testing they're doing um proof of
vaccination they're they're doing all
these things and we heard in testimony
um you know people talk about yes we are
we're doing this but it it's not
enforceable
um and so that they needed some type of
legislation to enforce you know the mask
wearing i'll use that as an example and
we heard that but but they it is
enforceable because it's their house so
they can as it is now
enforce that and so i just i don't know
that
making this a law is the right path
forward and i i do want to say i don't
think we're i mean
this is covid specific and i know it i
know it's been broadened but i don't
think we're going to be dealing with
this types of issues much longer anyway
so i i i don't know i guess we're
probably just gonna disagree on that
representative i do not believe the
wording of the amendment
makes it covet specific would you point
in the amendment where it does please
it doesn't sir and i said this did
broaden it so it is not code it's
specific it's communicable disease and
i'm sorry about that that's okay
i've already made the same point three
times so i'm going to wave off and hope
to god that gets us to a vote
that ship has sailed a long time ago and
i'm not even aggressively mature anymore
for those of you new on the committee
that's a charlie line those are charlie
lines
representative kenner would you like to
make a motion please
yes sir i would like to move amendment
number
zero seven zero seven to house bill
representative
gay
seconds
the motion before us is the amendment
to house bill
1369 moved by representative
canaric and seconded by representative
gay would the clerk please
call the roll
representative leon no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom no representative
kelsey no representative
stephen pearson no
representative cofoult no representative
delemus
representative weber
yes
representative mckay yes representative
snow yes representative knurk
yes representative soloway
absent
oh
sorry representative
cannon yes
representative nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
yes
motion carries eleven
to nine representative canuck would you
like a follow-up motion
i would i thought you wanted the honor
of that you said in your email
do you not do you not wish the honor of
that at this point sir
i don't want to write this blurb you do
it
no sweat then i have only so much card
move
ought to pass
hb1369 with amendment
0707 h
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amendment on house bill 1369.
as amended by
2022-0707
h moved by representative canark
seconded by representative m pearson
when the clerk is ready please call the
roll
representative leon no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom
oh represented folsom no
representative kelsey
no representative steven pearson no
representative kofalt no representative
delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
cannon
representative nutter uppam yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant
chairman pearson yes
and that is
in spite of the fact they still haven't
booked me for an organist gig yet
thank you for that
and representative canuck you get to
write
we'll be glad to and it is it is
officially eleven to nine is that
correct thank you
thank you and do i have to put in the
vote that the two pearsons voted on
opposite sides i mean in the blurb
we shared a car coming up here
that
should be fascinating
um who wants to write the minority
report
it's up to you guys
rock paper scissors i think
i think it would be fun if the two
pearsons
no
wouldn't it though
all right we can do one more but the
winter storms come in let's do an easy
one
all right here's the deal folks
this will be done all of the bills we
heard today
all of the stack of bills that have not
been exact yet will be done and if this
means we have to book wednesday march
9th
we have to
and by the way it is only rain there is
no snow for those of you who are
concerned oh look at that it's all green
all right just again give me hands how
many want to stay
easy let's split the difference all
right we'll split the difference 16 16.
we can split the difference we can do a
16-16
hypodermic needles
commission
this is right representative your keller
rockingham 33.
um
as you know leadership in both parties
has uh really put the word out
we don't want to commit e
we don't have the troops to phil commit
ease
so i went to him as i went to
representative donovan fenton earlier
and said don't you think it would be
better
if
you pulled together an ad hoc group of
people with the kind of people who could
speak well to this and then you do your
work and don't come in with a bill
asking for committee come in with a bill
asking for policy
so that is what i said to him and i
suppose before that you heard me say i
opened the exec session on house bill
1616.
and so the conversation i had with
representative yokala was we don't
really want a commission
what do you think and we had a nice chat
and this is a big red juicy
what
okay we need expertise on epipens but
what i understood was they're not
dangerous to carry but right now they're
illegal and it just seems nuts that
somebody up to 18 can't carry their own
epipen so i don't want a committee
either but it would be nice if we just
had a real simple bill that said you can
carry an empty pin but we don't we have
this bill this bill is being exact it's
about a committee or commission
mr representative merchant
in regards to the epipen
i don't know of any reason or any law or
rule or regulation if the pen's been
prescribed to the child
that child can use that epipen
the other question is going to be quite
frankly if somebody else is with that
child who has the epipen with him
that person could administer the epipen
to them so i don't know if we need to
worry about the epipen part of it at all
okay
sounds like we have two people who can
any further discussion if you re-read
syringes and needles
whether the restrictions should be
eliminated it's a discussion group the
bill is a discussion group if you vote
for this bill you do not get anything
so any further
to report somebody
oh would somebody who wants to write the
report movement i'll write a report all
right and we'll make no more coffee
we'll buy her coffee
okay i i am moving
itl
have a
democrat second
yes
the motion was itl on hospital 1616 fn
moved by representative folsom we owe
you and seconded by representative
merchant
you look ready i'm ready
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative stephen
pearson
yes
representative kobalt yes representative
delemus representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
cannon
yes representative nutter uppam also yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
representative chairman pearson yes 20
to zip
the motion
carries 20 to zero and this is the time
when i'm reminded i heard consent
consent
representative folsom gets to write the
committee report and we all owe you a
this committee my penis meeting is
finished
go home and this winter storms begin
is it actually coming down out there now
it's raining now
okay
you